Ich freu mich, dass Sie dabei sind. Heute ist der internationale Weltbestseller-Tag, sozusagen der Bestseller-Tag bei HSE 24. Neben mir auch so ein kleiner Bestseller, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, seit vielen, vielen Jahren.
Ich bin's, Tim.
Zum Beispiel haben wir eines alle gemeinsam und haben alle zu wenig Platz. Das stimmt. Die Russen, Italiener, die Portugiesen, alle haben zu wenig Platz und deswegen haben wir einen Platz Sparer heute.
Das sind sogenannte Mesh-Bags.
Das ist ja klemmend. Das ist praktisch.
Ich hab die großflächig im Einsatz.
Und da kann man natürlich auch Dokumente hineingeben.
Fantastisch, gerade für solche Adaptersachen. Und ich hab halt für unterschiedliche Einsatzzwecke immer ein Täschchen.
Und schauen Sie, Sie haben dann hier sofort den vollen Überblick, was ist drin.
Genau, also in einem Täschchen hab ich einfach ein normales Netzteil mit Euro-Steckerverlänger.
Also das ist nicht irgendwie so hingeklebt, sondern das ist wirklich ganz massiv und sauber vernäht. Also ich find das unheimlich schick und elegant.
Diese Mesh-Bags, die sind nicht totzukriegen.
Hat den Hintergrund, dass ich hier einfach keine Motte reinfressen kann. Wir haben bewusst etwas genommen, dass die Motten absolut nicht mögen, dass ihre guten Sachen auch geschützt sind.
Gerade wenn so alles in einem Sammelshorum anfängt. Genau. Sachen, die immer nur verstauben, die rumstehen, die kein Mensch braucht, die man aber nicht wegschmeißen möchte.
Die geben sich hier rein und es verstaubt nichts, es verkehrt nichts, es kommen keine Motten rein, keine Merden, haben hier Platz, Medikamente. Also wirklich alles, vielleicht auch ganz viele Bilder, die sie haben oder so ein Zeitschritt, die man aufheben will.
Die haben da einen super Platz. Und es sind leider die letzten Möglichkeiten, jetzt bei 472 Stück.
Wenn ich sogar den an Null kriegen würde, kann ich wahrscheinlich komplette Co-Moderatoren vorhalten. Ja, noch 450 Stück auf Lager. Rufen sie jetzt an.
Rufen sie jetzt an.
Und dann unsere freundlichen Kundenberater. Ja, verkaufen ihnen alles, was wir möchten. Hallo, wir sinds. Genau, und heute ist ein besonderer Tag, weil wir später dann noch was anzukündigen haben. Aber bis dahin werden wir euch erstmal mit ein paar langweiligen Themen erhaften. Erstmal die guten Nachrichten. Genau, also ja, alle da außer Clemens, Hucke, Dennis, Roddy und Icke. Check. Die Sonne scheint, es ist Sommer. Kann man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer behaupten, denn das muss man häufiger rauskommen aus deinem Keller, nicht immer nur alle zwei Wochen.
Dann musst du auch da Sendung machen.
Da kann man jetzt auch nichts machen.
Auch nichts machen.
Der Drops gelutscht.
Der Drops ist gelutscht. Ja, ansonsten sieht es irgendwie wie immer aus. Keine bahnbrechenden Neuerungen. Man muss sich jetzt mal wieder so aus Gerüchteküchen ernähren und was natürlich so alles die Developer-NDAs bricht.
Da stehen wir ja drauf wie eine Eins.
Oder?
Ich habe kein NDA unterschrieben.
Ich auch nicht, obwohl. Ne doch, für iOS nicht.
Unterschrieben habe ich es auch nicht, ich habe es nur geklickt.
Ich habe für iOS nichts unterschrieben.
Wir wurden ja schon gescholten, wir seien die, was war das nochmal? Die CDU des Podcastings oder so?
Parteiausschlussverfahren einleiten.
In welchem Zusammenhang denn bitte? Buckel ist zu leise, das stimmt. Ich will mich ja leise hören, aber ich dachte schon...
Wenn du zu leise bist, dann musst du hier dein Gain einstellen.
Und ich spreche ins Mikrofon.
Du kannst auch einfach das Mikrofon ein bisschen näher in deinen Mund rein machen.
Warum sind denn alle so leise? Ich bin ja auch so weit runter, oder wie?
Das OSC ist out of sync.
Nee, Dennis, bei dir wollen wir schon noch ein bisschen mehr hören.
Der war vorher ganz unten.
Also auf seinem...
Und der erste ist immer noch ganz unten.
Ja, weil das ist das Problem mit... Das ist das Problem, wenn man zwar... Wenn man nicht gut genug programmieren kann oder es nicht häufig genug tut. Nee, es hat keiner gemacht. Das ist ja das Problem. Also wäre ich so ein toller Hecht, was ich ja nicht bin, aber wäre ich ein toller Hecht...
Hättest du das mal gefixt?
Dann hätte ich nicht nur was gefixt, sondern hätte ich mir überhaupt erst mal hier die Software selber geschrieben, die ich hier schon immer haben wollte. Von dessen Funktionsweise und Aufbau und Struktur mir auch glasklar ist, aber ich bin ja kein toller Hecht. Und deswegen habe ich die Software noch nicht.
Gibt es das Hauskontrollen Zeug?
Das Zeug, auf das du da zeigst, das ist ja ein iPad mit TouchOSC drauf. Und das macht ja nur OSC. Das ist quasi nur ein Dump Terminal. Das zeigt einfach an, was ihm gesagt wird. Das Problem ist, ihm wird nicht genug gesagt. Und das wiederum ist ein Problem von State. Weil wenn ich jetzt hier so ein iPad habe, was versucht, den Zustand eines digitalen Mischpuls wiederzugeben, oder zumindest bestimmte Aspekte davon, dann geht das ja quasi nur dann, wenn dieses Mischpult auch der Meinung ist, es müsse diesem Gerät sagen, dass sich was geändert hat, oder überhaupt mal sagen, wie die Dinge eingestellt sind. Es gibt allerdings auf diesem Yamaha-Mischpult keine Möglichkeit.
Yamaha.
Yamaha. Yamaha.
Gibt es keine Gelegenheit, also kein Kommando.
Für Updates.
Für Schick mal alles, schick mal dein State. Was auch damit zu tun hat, dass der State recht groß ist. Deswegen machen sie es wahrscheinlich nicht. Weil da so viele Knöpfe und Einstellungen und Channels und...
Aber das ist Gigabit, super fancy, awesome, Power-Switch, musst du das doch kennen.
Nein, die Philosophie ist eine andere. Die Philosophie ist, über State redet man nicht, State hat man.
Ja, genau, da ist was dran und also das ist das eine Problem, das könnte man noch dadurch lösen, dass man was weiß ich hier in den Skript schreibt, was so regelmäßig irgendwie diese Dinger da irgendwie durchtrollert, aber auch dann weiß ich gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt triggern kann, etwas abzufragen, ohne es zu ändern. Also wenn ich quasi jetzt ein Wert ändere, dann gibt das Mischpult das auch gleich wieder auf dem MIDI raus und sagt, hat sich geändert, der neue Wert ist jetzt ein Heisenberg-State. Aber wenn er sich nicht geändert hat, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, vielleicht gibt es auch ein MIDI-Komandum, mit dem ich ihn auffordern kann, einen Wert einfach wieder raus zu echoen. Da wüsste ich jetzt aber nicht welcher. Also jetzt nur so ein normaler Fader, ne? Sag mir deinen Volume.
Sag mir deinen State, ich sag dir meinen. Du sagst mir deinen State, ich geb dir meinen.
Also long story short, die Software ist okay, dein Mischpult ist nicht...
Ja, es ist noch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil eigentlich möchte ich ja hier Dinge abbilden, die quasi für das Mischpult so gar nicht abbildbar sind. Also sagen wir mal, bevor die Sendung beginnt, dann sollen die Mikrofone ausgeschaltet sein, aber da, wo die Musik kommt, das geht dann durch und dann geht das schon mal auf den Stream und dann würde ich ja gerne meinen Studio-Zustand ändern und dann auch mehrere Updates auf einmal machen. Das heißt, ich brauch ohnehin so eine Makrofunktion, die eben gleich mehreren Kanälen irgendwie sagt, wie sie sich zu verhalten haben, wie Augse sind, ob die Kopfhörer eingeschaltet sind. Hier hat ja jeder Kopfhörer einen eigenen Mix. Das ist ja ein ziemliches Brimborium. Eigentlich brauch ich so eine Art Studio-Abstraktion. Ich brauch eine Software, die einfach mein Studio abbildet und das dann quasi entweder in MIDI auf dieses Mischpult draufrendert, so nach dem Motto. Meiner Meinung nach sollte sich das Studio in diesem Zustand befinden und dann sorgt es dafür, dass dieser Zustand auch hergestellt wird. Und wenn es auch bedeutet, dass er z.B. regelmäßig diese Werte immer wieder neu schreibt, einfach davon ausgehend, dass sich unter Umständen irgendwas geändert hat. Wenn ich z.B. so ein iPad mit hier neu einschalte, TouchOSC starte, dann muss das ja auch erstmal diesen State sich reinsaugen. Und wenn das hier regelmäßig gebroadcastet werden würde, wogegen ja nichts spricht, dann würde es sich halt binnen kürzester Zeit selber fixen. Und das ist aber alles nicht der Fall, weil ich kein toller Hecht bin und hier keiner mir seinen State sagt.
Dramatische Szenen spielen sich ab.
Ja, dramatische Szenen im State Department.
Ja, und Midi hat keine State-Abfrage, gibt's nicht.
An sowas hat nämlich irgendwie kein Mensch gedacht. Und OSC ist da jetzt auch erstmal per se erstmal keine Hilfe, sondern man braucht da so eine Software und dann sitzt man dann so da so als Altschuler und denkt sich so, ach, scheiße, hätte ich mal mehr Pearl gelernt.
Jetzt muss ich doch mal blöd nachfragen. Ich meine, Midi ist doch so irgendwie aus der Mitte der 80er. Ja. Und bis jetzt ist keinem aufgefallen, dass da was fehlt, dass man vielleicht den State von irgendwas wissen will.
Ja, das scheint für die meisten Leute nicht unbedingt ein Problem zu sein.
Oder ist Midi per se stateless? So nach der Art, ich schick dir was und du machst was damit?
Ja, Midi ist sehr änderungsorientiert. Also man geht immer davon aus, also überhaupt, dass man so komplexe Szenarien mit Midi beschreibt und dass darüber alles Mögliche gesteuert werden und so Remote-Control-Sachen und so. Das hat man sich damals halt nur sehr eingeschränkt gedacht. Ich meine, es gibt ja zumindest diese Automatiken, wenn du jetzt hier so ein, was weiß ich, ich kann ja hier auf dem iPad diesen Fader drehen, der hier mein Mikrofon-Lautstärke ändert. Ja, kann ich ja machen. Ich kann aber auch hier direkt am Mischpult dasselbe tun. Wo bin ich? Hier. So, und dann bewegen sich die ganzen Fader ja auf allen iPads mit. Das ist ja schon an sich schon mal ganz...
Und am Mischpult, was ich sehe.
Genau, Motorfader.
Motorfader, leider arschteuer.
TouchOSC ist der Motorfader des armen Mannes. Wenn man aber noch richtige Motorfader hat, ist es geil. Ja, stehe ich total drauf. Und macht ja auch wirklich diese Steuerung hier, das ist ja schon alles viel toller geworden. Was habt ihr damals immer geschrien? Zu laut, zu leise, hast nicht gesehen. Jetzt könnt ihr da einfach direkt...
Jetzt schwenken nur noch die Hörer, die bräuchten jetzt auch noch ihr eigenes Touch OSC.
Touch OSC ist... Ach so, um hier mitzumachen, hab ich auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht. Also im Prinzip, in dem Moment, wo man nämlich eine Software hat, die so ein Studio-Setup beschreibt, und zwar einerseits konkret, was so die Kanäle betrifft und was da offen und geschlossen gerade ist und was angeschaltet ist und wie der Gain ist und all diese ganzen Klim-Bim, auf der nächsthöheren Metaebene sozusagen, kannst du ja dann quasi auch den kompletten Sendungsverlauf abbilden. Also gerade so dieses Pre-Show, On-Air, Post-Show, lalala, was davon wird aufgezeichnet und so weiter, kannst du halt koppeln, auch natürlich mit irgendeinem Agenten im Netz, der sich zum Beispiel an den Chat rankoppelt und sich da halt Dinge sagen lässt, die man dann zum Beispiel auf den iPads auch einblenden lassen könnte.
Und es gibt auch in all der langen Zeit keine richtig tolle populäre Alternative zu MIDI?
Na, OSC.
Ach, ist so generell ein Ersatz?
Ja, OSC ist ja so gedacht, dass es quasi alles das kann, was MIDI kann, plus deutlich mehr mit gleich über IP und so weiter und das kannst du halt einfach mal mit UDP durch die Gegend joggeln und das funktioniert ja eigentlich auch relativ zuverlässig.
Eigentlich auch relativ.
Du findest es halt noch nicht überall. Also, was weiß ich, Ableton Live hat es eben nicht drin. Logic hat es drin. Reaper hat es drin. Dein Reaper hat OSC out of the box. Zwar buggy, aber immerhin schon mal drin. Who cares about errors? Ich habe das nämlich ein bisschen getestet. Und was bei Reaper zum Beispiel ein bisschen gaga ist, unter anderem wird ja auch so der Playhead, also wo er sich gerade in der Zeit befindet, auch per OSC rausgeschmissen. Da dachte ich, super, habe ich immer gerade so aktuell den Recording-Zeitpunkt, nur dass der Wert halt ein anderer ist, als der auf dem Bildschirm und der so über die Zeit langsam so divergiert, bis er dann irgendwie mehrere Minuten auseinanderklaffte. Das ist nicht ganz so meine Vorstellung von, wie das so zu funktionieren hatte.
Da hab ich dann mal schnell wieder die Finger davon gelassen.
Das scheint mir noch nicht so unbedingt so, den Härtegrad deutschen Engineering nachweisen zu können. Ja, so ist das. Na ja, gut. Also da geht noch eine Menge und dann frage ich mich natürlich, welcher Programmiersprache würde ich denn das schreiben und so. Und ich würde sagen, wenn man jetzt hier so auf dem Mac so was macht, was würdet ihr denn sagen? So muss irgendwie gut asynchron sein, weil man sollte nicht hängen bleiben mit den ganzen Messages, die in alle möglichen Richtungen geschickt werden. Sollte also schön asynchron sein. Sollte ans lokale MIDI vom OS X ran bammeln können, ohne dass man gleich Colonel Treiber schreiben muss.
C-Sharp. C-Sharp? Aber was ist denn das für eine Frage, in welcher Sprache wir das schreiben? Also wenn es um GUI geht, dann wird es ja...
Nee, GUI braucht überhaupt keinen... Also was das an GUI braucht, kann man komplett über ein Web-Interface machen. Also Ruby wäre sicherlich so ein Kandidat. Ich würde schon meinen, dass es da Ready-to-run, MIDI-Zugriff unter OS X in irgendeiner Form zu installieren gibt über irgendeinen Jam. Hab ich jetzt nicht gecheckt. Mit der Asynchronizität sieht es dann wiederum etwas mauer aus. Erlang wäre sehr schön asynchron, aber Erlang schreibt man halt auch mal nicht so eben gerade sich so mal nebenbei.
Das wird immer besser, je mehr man das macht.
Schnell ein Core-Audio-Erlang-Interface basteln.
Wenn man ein toller Hecht ist. Aber ich dachte ja gerade. In C könnte ich das irgendwie sicherlich... In C bin ich ja mal in den Topf gefallen für. Also alles, was man in der Jugend lernt, das kann man ja dann immer. Das verlernt man ja auch nicht. Also C verlerne ich nicht, weil das habe ich genug gemacht. Aber C ist halt scheiße.
Für solche Aufgaben ist es auch auf jeden Fall...
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Da war ich übrigens sehr überrascht, in einem Podcast zu hören, dass hier up.net tatsächlich im Wesentlichen Python, also die ganze API, was sie so machen, ist Python. Im Hintergrund murmelt dann irgendwie MySQL und Redis, wie auch immer sie das miteinander verstritten haben. Und die Streaming-Sachen, wobei Streaming bei up.net bedeutet, du lieferst so permanent alle Messages in Strom, das machen sie mit Go. Was mich überhaupt nicht überrascht, weil ich immer das Gefühl hatte, dass so ein bisschen Go auch so den Appeal hat, der auch Python-Leuten gefällt. Ich mein, das kommt ja von Google, weil Google ist in diesem ganzen Systemautomatisierungsbereich Python sehr stark. Sollte sich das nicht irgendwie in den letzten zwei Jahren geändert haben, aber das war immer mein...
Na ja, Python war so First Class Citizen der Google App Engine immer.
Richtig, genau.
In dem Zusammenhang hab ich es ja auch schon mal verwendet.
Ja, natürlich, auf dem Level sogar ganz extrem. Also Python spielt auf jeden Fall eine besondere Rolle. Und Go ist ja letztlich auch bei Google entwickelt worden von den alten Zehhasen. Und geht genau dieses Problem an, wo halt Python seine Schwächen hat, nämlich bei Performance und bei Gleichzeitigkeit. So, wie ja auch Erlang. Vielleicht wäre er auch...
Vielleicht wäre auch mal Go mal interessant.
Ich mag das Go nicht.
Naja, aber es appeals to see...
Go ist schon interessant, aber irgendwie ist der Funke da bei mir nicht übergesprungen.
Ich als Nicht-Zeher sowieso.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dieses Rust, das sollte man im Auge behalten. Also wer dieses Jahr noch keine Programmiersprache gelernt hat, und Go und Erlang schon durchhält, der sollte sich mal an Rust machen.
Aber hattest du dich da nicht drüber beschwert, irgendwann mal?
Da sind so ein paar Sachen, die sind komisch und die habe ich nicht auf Anhieb verstanden, aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Also sag niemals nie.
Deine Paella-Pizza, die war auch interessant.
Die war sehr lecker.
Ob das interessant gut oder interessant schlecht ist, das weiß man nicht so genau. Ah, wenn Tim seinen Kopfhörer wechselt, können wir mal schnell das Thema hijacken und darüber sprechen, wie... Jetzt guck mich nicht so fragen an, jetzt springen wir mit einem Thema zur Seite. Wo ist die Themenliste, verdammte Axt? Jetzt haben wir es in der Hand los, Dennis Dennis, wo bist du? Vielleicht hätte er den Kopfhörer wieder auf. Oh, und zu spät.
Naja, die Themenliste ist auf dem Beamer, du Nuss.
Weiß ich doch. Ich wollte für Dramaturgie sorgen. Ich verrate doch nicht meine...
Ja, ich bin halt ein bisschen langsam. Ja, nee, also jetzt irgendwie... Also ehrlich gesagt, ist ja immer sehr einfach, immer alles Scheiße zu finden, was man nicht kennt, ne?
Das stimmt.
Aber wenn man das jetzt mal umdreht, müsste man sich auch mal selber ein bisschen Scheiße dafür finden, dass man was nicht kennt.
In dem Zusammenhang, man soll ja jedes Jahr eine neue Programmiersprache lernen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wofür findest du... Also für was du nicht kennst, findest du dich scheiße. Also ich hab da so...
Schwer zu sagen, ich kenn's ja nicht.
Ich hab verschiedene Worte. Nee, aber manchmal ahnt man's doch schon. Man ahnt, dass man eigentlich es besser wissen müsste. Oder? Selbst wenn man mal in ihre Hand wirft. Also ich hätt einiges gern besser drauf. Ich würde dann wahrscheinlich auch kluger da herreden können. Noch klüger.
Bei mir ist das noch nicht mal offen.
Ja, ich mein...
Also ich hab's ja mal mit Peißen probiert, aber es war...
Na ja, auch schon mal gesagt, eine Sprache, die mir vorgeht, wie ich zu indenten habe, da komm ich auch irgendwie nicht drüber hinweg.
Das ist ehrlich gesagt meine geringstes Problem an Python. Mein größtes Problem an Python ist, dass irgendwie in dieser Sprache alles eine Exception ist. Und selbst ein Zündungserror ist eine Exception. Da schmeißt dann einfach die Sprache als solche eine Exception, dass sie das Pfeil nicht richtig pasen kann. Ich finde das völlig absurd.
Weil du änderst irgendwie Code und du kannst nicht mal so richtig vorher checken, ob es geht. Sondern erst, wenn es losläuft.
Vielleicht habe ich zu lange Compiler verwendet. Um so etwas irgendwie abzugeben.
Meist, weil es nicht at Compile-Time entschieden wird.
Oder Load-Time.
Genau, gerade wenn du so Edge-Cases programmierst, die seltenst auftreten, und dann kommt aber auch der Fehler, wenn du da einen gekodest hast, nur dann, wenn es soweit ist und nicht, dass er schon vor sagt, ja du hast da irgendwie was vergessen, was falsch gemacht oder so.
Das ist aber das Dilemma aller dynamischen Sprachen. Ich meine, wenn es nicht die Syntax ist, dann ist es halt irgendwas anderes. Irgendeine Typisierung, die bricht.
Ja, aber da fühlt man sich auf anderen Sprachen schon ein bisschen wohler dabei.
Ja gut, von Syntax-Fehlern sollte dich unter Umständen schon mal dein Editing-Environment bewahren.
Autokorrekt-Me.
Gibt es das eigentlich so?
Autokorrekt? Das wäre doch mal was für X-Coach.
Schau dir mal vor, die würden so Autokorrekt einbauen.
Es gibt ja diese ewige Completion schon.
Nee, nicht Completion. Einfach Autokorrekt. Einfach gar nicht erst irgendwas vorschlagen, sondern einfach Pess.
Es gibt ja jetzt sowas für Kommentare. Das ist total geil. Wir haben jetzt in den LLVM-Compiler eingebaut, dass er Kommentare parsen kann. Und zwar sowohl DoxyGen als auch Hedadoc. Und wenn du jetzt eine Methode machst, die zum Beispiel kein Return Value hat, und du schreibst aber in den Kommentar oben drüber Returns das und das, dann wirft er dir eine Warning aus, dass du in deinem Kommentar zur Funktion reingeschrieben hast, dass sie was returnt, obwohl sie nichts returnt.
Damals wird endlich mal dafür gesorgt, dass Doku und Code auch in Sync ist, weil es ist immer das größte Problem, wenn die Doku nicht zum Code passt.
Was für ein Besserwisser.
Ich mein, bei Erlang gibt es ja da diesen Dialyzer, wo du dir auch über deine Funktionen quasi so ähnlich wie Dokumentation kannst du so ein Speck halt hinschreiben, was da reinkommt und was da rauskommt, und da nölt er dich dann auch voll, wenn das inkonsistent ist. Ich benutze es aber ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Doch, Compiler sollten mehr nölen. Ich will den Tim unter den Compilern.
Ja genau, ich dachte auch gerade so. Das hat so ein bisschen was von Podcast-Moderation.
Aber ich komme ja aus der Ruby-Ecke. Ich bin ja so voll dynamisch, metaprogrammatisch unterwegs. Und das hat ja auch großen Spaß gemacht. Naja, jetzt mache ich halt ja beruflich eher Erlangen ganz viel. Und da bringe ich ja dann eher so noch ein paar Ruby-Ismen mit zurück in die Erlangen-Welt, als jetzt den vollen Erlangen-Stock im Arsch-Approach irgendwie über mich ergehen zu lassen.
Das ist aber das Typische, was man macht, wenn man von einer Sprache zur nächsten wechselt. Man schleppt natürlich alle seine alten...
Nein, nicht alle meine alten, aber...
Aber eine Menge schleppt man erst mal mit.
Aber die Erlangen-Community, die waren eine ganze Zeit lang so unter sich, so in ihrem Telco-Dorf. Und die haben sich da auch ganz gut eingeschneicht. Und jetzt kommen halt so ein paar hippe Kids vorbei, die so denken, wir brauchen hier mal Concurrency für unsere fancy Web-App. Und nehmen jetzt so dieses Erlangen und Furzen halt so mal dazwischen und sagen so, ja, wat, irgendwie seit 20 Jahren ist das so und euch ist nicht mal aufgefallen, dass man das vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen toller machen könnte.
Füttet denn das zur Verbesserung? Also ich meine, hier gibt's da Fitbit?
Naja, doch, doch. Also das muss man den OTP-Team schon zugutehalten. Die werkeln halt schon von Release zu Release mal ordentlich was rein. Also das mit diesen Line-Numbers ist ja dieses großartige Beispiel, was wir ja auch erst vor einem oder zwei Jahren da eingebaut haben, dass es ein Stack-Traces-Line-Numbers gibt.
Ja, das fand ich auch geil.
Und wenn da nicht jetzt irgendwie so viele Leute jetzt aus so dieser Web-Eck oder so da reingespült werden und so irgendwie, was? Keine Line-Numbers? Dann wär das wahrscheinlich noch heute so. Also da gibt's schon ein bisschen Bewegung, aber wie bestimmte Dinge zu machen sind, wie man da Applikationen, die Private-Unreleases baut, wie man dies und das und jenes macht, ist halt so alles auf diesem Telco-Kram so dokumentiert und gemacht und so weiter. Und ja, im täglichen Leben, wenn du mal eben so eine API da hochzimmern willst, da brauchst du halt ganz viel Kram. Ich hatte ja diesen kleinen Talk da auf dieser Erlang Factory Lite, das habe ich ja schon skizziert. Vielleicht können wir den Show notes ja gleich noch die Slides nochmal verlinken. Da gibt es halt so ganz viele Sachen, die so einfach da sind aus Tradition, die aber so im 21. Jahrhundert so ein bisschen so im Staubwedel drüber könnte und sagen, das ist halt, habe ich das schon mal erzählt, mit diesem Mentalitätsunterschied zwischen Programmierern, den ich da bei VUGA jetzt auch feststelle, so zwischen den Ruby-Hackern und die, die so von der Uni und so Erlang First und so kommen. Das Ganze ist so...
Die Leute, die an der Uni als erstes Erlang lernen?
Ja, die so in Schweden halt da an der Uni waren und so, wir haben ja so ein paar... in Uppsala und so. Wir haben auch einen, zwei, die mal als Erlang-Consulten gearbeitet haben. Also es gibt so zwei Schulenentwickler bei uns, die Ruby-Hacker und die Erlang-Universitätsleute und ich kann glaube ich neben jedem Backend-Entwickler da so sitzen und weiß genau, ob er vorher Ruby gemacht hat oder nicht. Nee, einfach auch so der Approach so. Weil die Ruby-Leute, die sind so, was denn das hier, irgendwie die State-Machine, die halt keine Transition-Events und so weiter und so. Ja komm, hackt das Pfeil auf, wir machen jetzt unsere eigene Gen-MSM oder Borny halt mal ein bisschen aus. Und die Erlang-Leute, ja, nee, also das heilige Gebot der drei Apostel des Erlang-Konsortiums. Also die haben sich das ja gedacht für dies und das und jenes und das sollte man auch so machen. Da wäre ich ganz vorsichtig und uh, nein, jetzt hat das Pfeil aufgemacht. Jetzt kopiert er sich da die Gen-MSM, ja. Und schreibt selber was rein. Und so die Ruby-Leute, die sind halt so, weil da kannst du ja eh alles machen in der Sprache. Was finde ich auch so schön an Ruby, die geht dir ja so komplett aus dem Weg, wenn du willst. Ach du willst das, der Hash, anders funktioniert ja kein Problem. Hier, bitteschön. Metaprogrammierer und so die Ruby-Hacker, die gehen auch bei Erlang oder bei anderen Sprachen, die gehen dann halt einfach so ganz anders ran. So wenn irgendwas nicht so ist, wie es sein soll, komm Rup auf die Scheiße, wir machen Fork, wir machen das jetzt selber. Ja, das find ich eigentlich ganz sympathisch. Hat auch seine, hat natürlich nicht nur...
Nicht nur Vorteile.
Hat nicht nur Vorteile, aber ist so ein bisschen, ja. Und so ist das halt dann eben auch bei der... Ja, eben bei diesen ganzen anderen Sachen in Erlangen. So alles so ein bisschen so, ah nee, das machen wir schon seit 20 Jahren so, das ist schon gut so, es muss so.
Ich schreib ja gerade an Kotum, wo man sehen kann, dass der vorherige Programmierer Java-Coder war. Weißt du, objektivistisch, was das ist? Aber es ist alles voll mit Exceptions. Und? Was sagt uns das? Objektivistisch benutzt man keine Exceptions. Also, wo benutzt man die? Der kommt von Java. Und dann Garbage Collection, alles voll davon.
Eine Exception ist halt ein Fatal Error mehr oder weniger. Wenn du anfängst, Exceptions zu fangen, dann machst du schon was falsch.
Warum?
Weil der Code, den du geschrieben hast, kaputt ist, wenn eine Exception fällt.
In anderen Sprachen ist es üblich damit umzugehen, in Objective-C sorgt man dafür, dass es nicht passiert.
In Objective-C ist es so, du setzt ein Breakpoint auf Exception Throw und wenn du auf diesen Breakpoint stößt, dann hast du einen Fehler im Programm, den du fixen musst. Weil wenn eine Exception fällt, dann ist es ein Fehler.
Nein, es gibt auch Exceptions, es sind kein Fehler.
Nicht in Objective-C? Doch.
Nee, soll aber nicht so sein.
Soll nicht so sein.
Was ist, wenn die Platte voll ist?
Da wird das File nicht geschrieben. Du kriegst einen NSR Award zurück.
Genau.
Ah, Fehlermeldung, ja. So wie bei C damals. If return value gleich minus 1.
Der Punkt an Objective-C ist, dass du viel über returned-Objecten machst. Also du kriegst entweder ein Objekt zurück oder kriegst nil zurück. Da du aber in Objective-C auf einen nil-Pointer eine Methode aufrufen kannst, die dann auch nil zurückgibt, das ist egal, aber du kannst auf einen nil-Pointer immer eine Methodenaufruf machen, ohne dass das Ding abschmiert.
Ah, und dann läuft er einfach weiter eine halbe Stunde und führt nur nil aus und keiner merkt was.
Da kannst du ja irgendwann checken, ob nil zurückkommt. Ja, aber du brauchst da nicht dieses try exception tralala Zeug schreiben. Mein Coder ist voll davon.
Ja, gut, egal, da bin ich anders geprägt irgendwie.
Ja, das Problem an Exceptions ist halt, dass du einen zweiten, du machst einen zweiten Execution Path auf, den du auch testen musst, den du durchspielen musst, den du handeln musst. Und wenn du eine Exception in eine Exception wirfst, dann wird es nochmal komplizierter. Dann bekommst du einen dritten und vierten Execution Path und irgendwann, weißt du, der Punkt ist, wenn du eine Exception wirfst, sowas wie Array Out of Bounds, dann hast du halt vorher schon ein Problem gehabt. Naja, aber wenn Array fünf Elemente hat und du willst aufs sechste zugreifen, dann ist es ein Programmfehler. Das musst du vorher fixen.
Ja, naja, vielleicht.
Und wenn du deine Library in eine Exception wirfst, nur weil die Platte voll ist, also was ist das nächste? Du wirst eine Exception, weil der Speicher alle ist, und dann kannst du aber das Exception-Objekt auch nicht mehr generieren, weil ist ja kein Speicher mehr da, für das Exception-Objekt.
Nein, du behandelst dann diesen Fehler. Na, indem du zum Beispiel ein Fenster aufmachst und sagst, lieber User.
Yes, no.
Mach mal Platze vor Platze.
Ja. Der Mechanismus in Coco ist aber anders. Du bekommst einen NS Error zurück und du kannst aufgrund des NS Errors, den du zurückkriegst, kannst du was machen oder du kannst sagen, First Responder, Present Error. Und dann geht der Error aber die normale Responder-Chain, die andere Events, ganz normal, so wie es wie Maus Moved oder Maus Down oder so Events, nimmt dann der Error und wird am Ende von der Applikation als Fenster angezeigt.
Ja, gut, das ist halt immer noch...
Die Convention ist bei Objective-C halt keine Exceptions zu coden. Die sind ja da, die sind ja möglich, die gibt es auch in Spezialverhältnissen, aber normalerweise nicht.
Das Problem ist, Exceptions sind halt auch so schwer zu debuggen. Weil, wenn du einen Code hast, der bevor du eigentlich an die Exception, die dich interessiert, schon fünf Exceptions wirft und fängt, dann kannst du halt auch keinen Breakpoint auf Exception Throw setzen, weil da wirst du ja arm. Weil du ja immer wieder auf diesen Breakpoint läufst und nie deine Exception findest. Wenn du allerdings an der Stelle guckst, wo die Exception gefangen wird, dann ist halt auch gerne mal dein Call Stack schon weg. Gut, also ich meine, bei einer NS-Exception ist es so, dass er den Call Stack der ursprünglichen Exception mit dazu liefert, damit du eine Chance hast, das zu debuggen. Aber mach das mal unter C++.
Ich guck erst mal, ob wir noch Hörer haben.
Das hat mich jetzt gerade einmal mehr davon überzeugt, dass ich mit dem C und so in diesem Objective-C, das lass ich sein, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ihr habt das falsch verstanden. Guck dir einfach mal Java an, wie die das mit den Exceptions machen.
Ja, Java ist bestimmt noch schlimmer.
Ich sag ja nicht, dass das nicht auch toll ist. Es gibt allerdings auch schon wirklich andere Ansätze. Manche Sprachen machen es ja so, dass sie quasi eine Exception wirklich als normale Bedingung definieren.
Ja, und das ist halt ein Problem.
Nicht immer, wenn die Sprache damit ein bisschen anders umgeht als jetzt.
Also zum Beispiel in Dülln, ja. Weißt du, was ist da draußen los?
Da wird ein Kind geschlachtet.
Ach, da ist ein...
Im Prenzlerberg gibt es genug Kinder. Weiter.
Die Kinder stehen da oben auf dem Balkon und freuen sich ein.
Deiner oder was?
Nein.
Mach mal Fenster zu, das Quietschen macht mich wahnsinnig.
Mach du mal, Rotti.
Also ist halt immer so eine Sache mit den Ansätzen. Wir müssen das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt total vertiefen. Aber wir stellen jetzt einfach mal fest, man muss schon ein toller Hecht sein, um irgendwie sich mal eben eine Lösung für sein Kram aus dem Ärmel zu schütten.
Wir hingegen streiten uns erstmal eine Runde über Exceptions und dann ist dieser Nummer vorbei.
Hast du mir nicht mal einen Erlang Refresh angeboten?
Willst du das nicht mal machen?
Ja, kann ich machen. Mittlerweile fühle ich mich fit genug. Nach meiner zweiten Produktionsapplikation.
Da gibt es sogar schon einen Code, auf den man aufbauen könnte. Na ja, gut. Machen wir mal ein anderes Thema, oder?
Wir hatten ja noch gar keins, oder?
Das war jetzt schon ziemlich, also, ne? Wir haben ja mal, weil das halt passiert ist. Dinge passieren halt, ne? Ich dachte, ich wollte mal, aber bevor wir es vielleicht vergessen. Ja, unser David, der immer diese tollen Intros macht, wie auch dieses.
Ja, das war ein sehr schönes Intro.
Genau, der geht jetzt auch unter die Podcaster. Und will selber podcasten. Und zwar über Crowdfunding. Und dazu hat er ein Crowdfunding gestartet. Das ist aber glaube ich schon durch.
Er meint auf Twitter, das geht noch 30 Tage oder so.
Hat er eigentlich ein Podcast gemacht zu seinem Crowdfunding, zum Crowdfunding-Podcast? Ne, das nicht, ne?
Was nochmal? Vergesst es nicht.
Ob er zu seinem Crowdfunding, für den Crowdfunding-Podcast auch ein Podcast gemacht hat?
Ich glaube ja. Ich muss gerade mal schauen, wo hier...
Wie viele Millionen Euro?
Ja, er hat noch keine Millionen Euro. Hier genau, und zwar heißt das Schwarmtaler. Ich schmeiß das mal hier kurz in den Chat.
Den Namen, der ist so schwarmig.
Ja, genau. Also die Initialfinanzierung ist auf jeden Fall schon durch. Aber vielleicht hat er noch jemand lustig da zu engagieren, hier für unseren Helden des Beginns. Ansonsten warten wir mal ab.
Es geht um Crowdfunding-Projekte.
Ich bin selber noch ein bisschen gespannt, wie sich das dann konkret herausbilden wird.
Wenn ich ihn recht verstanden hab, dann will er Projekte vorschlagen, von denen er der Meinung ist, dass sie Crowdfunding-würdig sind.
Und dann mit den Leuten sprechen.
Damit er weiß, wie Crowdfunding funktioniert, macht er erst mal sein eigenes. Das hat er zumindest in seinem Intro-Movie erzählt.
Kann man schon mal machen. Schwarmtaler Erdbeermarmelade. Schreibt gerade alle im Chat, dass sich der Name wie so ein Marmeladen-Label anhört.
Das hieß Schwartau.
Manchmal ist das mit der Assoziation...
Wobei ich finde, dass Schwartau ein komischer Name für Marmelade ist. Ich stelle mir da so fette Schweine auf einer fetten Weide vor. Das hat nichts von Erdbeermarmelade.
Assoziations-Kettensägen-Massaker.
Ich finde, wenn wir die nächsten beiden Themen tauschen, macht das mehr Sinn. Ja klar, erst kommt der alte Scheiß raus, dann kommt der neue.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich erst mal über das neue berichten und dann darüber diskutieren, was wir mit dem alten machen.
So rum geht es natürlich auch.
Achso, du meinst deinen alten. Achso, ich meinte meinen alten.
Ich weiß, dass du deinen alten meintest, aber ich wollte jetzt mal von meinem neuen reden. Vielleicht von meinem alten und dann wollen wir uns jetzt noch weiter auf der Metaebene diskutieren.
Ja, hurra!
Also ich habe ja letztes Mal schon verkündet, dass ich ein Mac Book Air 11 Zoll gekauft habe. Ich hatte ja schon ein Mac Book Air 11 Zoll. Hab die letzte Generation ausgesessen und diesmal aber zugegriffen, weil die Verheißung war ja so groß.
Akkulaufzeit!
Akkulaufzeit, genau. Also es gab mal wieder so ein Feature, was gesagt hat...
Kauf mich!
Dinge könnten besser werden. Dinge, die dir wichtig sind, könnten besser sein. Weil mich das einfach gestört hat. Ich fand einfach die Laufzeit, zumindest mit dem Satz an Software, das ich benutze, war irgendwie unbefriedigend. Und vielleicht liegt das auch an der Software im Wesentlichen. Keine Ahnung hier so. Dropbox wurde irgendwie verstärkt in den Verdacht gezogen in den letzten Wochen, dass die doch ganz ordentliche Power-Hogs sind. Und das kann ich soweit auch bestätigen, wie ich immer so die CPU-Monitore beobachte.
Da reiße ich kurz den Finger in die Luft. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das letzte Mal schon gesagt haben, aber angeblich habe ich, oder ich habe glaube ich einen Screenshot gesehen in Mavericks, da wird ja im Activity-Monitor jetzt der Stromverbraucher an dir zeigen.
Genau, das wird dann hoffentlich auch dazu führen, dass diese Programme sich da mal ein bisschen...
Schämen.
Ein bisschen schämen und ein bisschen am Puller reißen. Weil irgendwie...
Ich möchte nicht drauf eingehen.
Ja, wollen sie ruhig mal verstehen, wie es gemeint ist. Dann wirkt es vielleicht auch. Aber...
Und was machen die weiblichen Entwicklerinnen?
Ich wollte jetzt keine Sender-Gebatte los treten, sondern ich wollte einfach nur darauf hinweisen, dass es bestimmte Software gibt, die sich an Körperteilen reißen sollte. Genau. Außerdem bin ich davon überzeugt, dass Entwicklerinnen nicht so eine Software abliefern. Das ist so typische Männer-Software.
Na ja, komm hier so ein Bad rein oder raus.
Ja, CPU muss glühen.
Wir benutzen nur sieben. Kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Schnell noch Lipp-CPU-Burn mit reinkommen.
Wenn sie es mal tun würden. Na ja, jetzt bin ich mit dem Gerät ein bisschen unterwegs gewesen. Und, oh Wunder, oh Wunder, oh Wunder, tatsächlich...
Nein, Tim ist wieder zufrieden.
Was für mich immer so ein Gradmesser war, ist, kann ich mich mit so einem vollgeladenen Gerät in so einen 6-Stunden-Zugfahrt reinsetzen und davon ausgehen, dass egal was ich tue, ich bis zum Schluss Strom habe. Das ist für mich die Definition von Es hält ein Tag.
Und, konntest du?
Ja, ich hatte noch eine Stunde Akku über. Und ganz großartig, also mit Internet dazwischen und so. Ich hatte jetzt keinen WLAN im Zug, von daher konnte ich jetzt nicht so diesen dauerhaften Betrieb haben. Ich hatte auch keinen WLAN an, weil das Netz quasi über USB kam. Also von daher sagt man so schön Grain of Salt. Also das ist jetzt kein abschließendes Urteil, aber ich kann bestätigen, dieser Rechner hat deutlich, deutlich, deutlich, deutlich, deutlich mehr Power. Und was mich aber noch sehr viel mehr freut in dem Zusammenhang... Ich bin ja sogar beim Prozessor sogar noch einen Schritt zurückgegangen. Ich bin ja wieder... Ich habe ja i5 gewählt, also die Basisausstattung. Letztes Mal hatte ich halt ein i7 und naja, das war eigentlich doof, weil ich brauchte keine schnellere CPU.
Also am letzten Mal war doof.
Ja, die Entscheidung war wahrscheinlich falsch. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe ja jetzt nur auch das i7 Modell gehabt und nicht das i5 Modell, aber ich wollte jetzt von vornherein einfach auf maximale Stromersparnis, alles im Minimum, was potenziell Strom fressen kann und alles im Maximum, was potenziell Daten vorhalten kann. Also viel RAM, viel Flash.
Das heißt, das 12-Stunden-Gerät, laut Apple?
Nein, das 12-Stunden-Gerät ist das 13er. Das ist das 9-Stunden-Gerät, laut Apple. Und ich würde sagen, das kann auch durchaus sein, dass es an diese Zeit rankommt. Aber das ist für mich insofern auch jetzt nicht relevant, ob das irgendwie am Ende 7, 8 oder 9 Stunden sind.
Solange es mehr als 6 sind.
Aber ich könnte jetzt sagen, der schafft, egal was ich da mache, immer 5. Und das ist schon so ein, ich meine, damit ist einfach mal auch so der typische Berliner Café-Besuch abgedeckt. Ich weiß doch, wie das läuft.
Das ist der typische Berliner Café-Besuch.
Also ich als gebürtiger Berliner hab noch nie 5 Stunden im Rechner im Berliner Café gesessen.
Du hast noch nie 5 Stunden in einem Berliner Café gesessen?
Die komplimentieren einen vorher mal raus.
Ja, weil dein Akku alle war.
Weil was will ich da 5 Stunden in so einem Café?
Da Kaffee trinken, reden und hacken. Wenn man Netz hat.
Ich trinke kein Kaffee.
Erdbeerkuchen essen.
Marte trinken.
Danke, Oberholz.
Naja, das war nie so mein Ort. Dennis, wir sind doch oldschool. Wir hatten doch schon aus Internet-Cafés gemacht, bevor das hip war.
Das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Bevor es überhaupt Kaffee gab.
Mit Internet und mit Laptop im Café Lifestyle. Der war halt total cool.
Bis es cool wurde.
Und mit dem Oberholz ist mir der Spaß eigentlich schon weitgehend vergangen. Trotz alledem merke ich immer wieder, dass ich extrem produktiv bin in so einer Umgebung. Das mag anderen Leuten ganz anders gehen. Aber ich kann mich wahnsinnig gut auf Sachen konzentrieren, wenn ich in so einer Umgebung bin, wo es um mich herum wuselt, aber dieses Gewusel mit mir nichts zu tun hat. Also es wuselt zwar, aber das Wusel will nicht an mich ran.
Das ist keine echte Ablenkung, wie zu Hause, wo man sonst noch was machen könnte.
Ja, genau. Oder wo so Arbeit noch liegt, um die man sich eigentlich auch schon immer hätte kümmern müssen. Du hast einfach nur dein Laptop, dein Dokument.
Lass mich raten, du kannst auch voll super im Zug arbeiten?
Ja, im Zug im Prinzip.
Ja, wenn das mit dem Netz besser wäre. Also ich hatte jetzt ein paar Mal ICE mit WLAN über die Ost-West-Strecke. Das Problem ist natürlich jetzt durch dieses scheiß Hochwasser, ist dieser Luxus jetzt auch schon wieder im Arsch.
Sollen wir wieder auf der Strecke?
Doch.
Ist nicht wieder offen und die wird auch bis Ende des Jahres geschlossen sein. Und das ist wirklich hart.
Na ja, in denen die Gleise weggeschwommen sind, also ich meine...
Da steht immer noch Wasser unter dieser Brücke, also das ist sozusagen...
Also es steht immer noch Wasser da, wo es nicht zu stehen hat, also das ist immer noch nicht abgezogen, das Wasser, also noch nicht vollständig zumindest. Na ja, und jetzt wissen sie noch nicht so ganz genau, was was ist, und es kann halt sein, dass sie die ganze Brücke neu bauen müssen oder sonst irgendwas, ne?
Die...
Was wollte ich denn eigentlich erzählen? Ich wollte eigentlich auf meinen Mac Book Air, genau so. Und das Ding ist, das ist das eigentlich Geile an diesem Teil, es ist kalt! Es ist kalt! Es ist kalt! Also, natürlich entwickelt es auch Wärme, aber...
Aber heißt das, dass es gar keine Computronen mehr verbraucht? Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Aber laut der Computronen-Quantum-Vogomechanics werden noch die Computer warm, weil die Computronen verbrauchen.
Es braucht halt nicht mehr so viele Computronen. Man muss weniger Computronen hinzufügen. Diese großen Teile, also alle Geräte, sind eigentlich völlige Toaster. Und dieses Gerät, zumindest seitdem ich es so benutze, hab ich noch nicht warm erlebt. Ich hab auch diesen Lüfter noch nie gehört.
Ja, aber das kann ja auch nix.
Alter, das hat PCI-Flash.
Alter, ich hab hier Quad-Core-Tralala und du mit 2,3. Du hast da irgendwie Dual mit 1,3. Kannst ja wohl vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen temperaturmäßig irgendwie und so, ne?
Ja und? Und wie viele DVDs rechnest du da gerade durch? Das Ding eilt doch auch nur auf irgendeiner Webseite und exekutiert ja was.
Nein, Alter, ich chat in Unicode, das brauch ich nicht.
Für jedes Byte einen Chor, ja?
Also für UTF 16 brauchst du schon irgendwie Quad-Core.
Ja, es gibt auch UTF 32.
Ich hab auch letztens gelernt, sehr schmerzhaft fast, dass es UTF 8 MB4 in MySQL gibt. Für alle, die mal Emojis in der MySQL-Datenbank speichern wollen, den empfehle ich.
Also ein Feldtyp.
Ja, den empfehle ich gleich. Das Charset UTF 8 MB4. Was heißt denn MB4? Ja, das MySQL, das macht so opportunistic best effort UTF 8 und speichert... Und hat da so maximal drei Bytes für so was vorgesehen, für so einen Character und wenn es dann halt mal vier werden, dann sagt das, oops, I accidentally the emoji icon. Nee, dann musst du UTF 8 MB4 und dann garantiert dir, dass MySQL auch vier Bytes.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall, mein altes R war ja nicht schlecht. Es war ja nicht alles schlecht mit dem alten Mac Book Air. Aber es ist, sagen wir mal, für Leute, die Lüfter nicht mögen, also in so, wie soll ich sagen, so grobenen Normal-Situationen, wie ich nehme einen Podcast auf und hab da mal so vier, fünf Ups gerade laufen, die Dinge tun, dann macht das offensichtlich schon einen Unterschied. Also ich finde, muss man ganz klar zu sagen, dass Apple da ein echt gutes Engineering gemacht hat bei diesen Geräten. Und ich kann nur davon ausgehen, dass das 13 Zoll ähnlich und wenn nicht sogar noch ein bisschen beeindruckender ist, weil sie da halt nochmal mehr Akku reingeschmissen haben.
Auf gut Deutsch, du bist tatsächlich zufrieden.
Ah, es kommt noch was besseres. Genau, und das ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht diskutiert worden. Vielleicht ist das auch einfach so eine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre gewesen, die ich so ein bisschen verschlafen habe, aber ich kann mich da bei meinem Vorgänger Mac Book Air so nicht dran erinnern. Vielleicht lag es auch am Wetter. Ich saß nämlich vor ein paar Tagen in strahlendem Sonnenlicht, was von hinten in meinen Bildschirm rein krachte. Und ihr wisst ja, was man normalerweise auf Bildschirmen so sieht. In solchen Situationen nämlich nüscht.
Sich selbst.
Ja, oder nüscht halt. Und ich sah alles mit brillanter Klarheit. Und ich dachte so, haben die jetzt irgendwie da so wie bei LBM so Spiegel eingebaut, dass sie so das Licht von hinten irgendwie nutzen. Ja, fiel mir nur einfach auf, dass mein Hintergrundbeleuchtung voll aufgedreht war. Aber es konnte sich sozusagen voll gegen dieses Sonnenlicht behaupten. Das war mir auch neu. Hab ich da irgendwas verpasst? Gab es irgendeinen Breakthrough? Stand da was in der Bild?
Achsespringer, nichts gesagt.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall sehr universelles Gerät. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ist gut.
Ich finde ja auch dieser 11 Zoll Formfaktor, das ist überhaupt der größte Wurf, den sie je gemacht haben. Also sowas von praktisch. Da, ich weiß gar nicht, also das iPad ist vor allem auch deshalb so unheimlich uninteressant für mich, weil es irgendwie dieses Gerät gibt.
Ja, du hast ja kein iPad Mini.
Das stimmt.
Ich hab jetzt schon das zweite und ich bin voll zufrieden.
Nachdem du das erste geschrottet hast.
Vor Wut an die Wand geschleidert hast.
Nee, das war im Rucksack. Ich hab den Pullover rausgeholt und weil das iPad Mini ja auch so schön leicht ist, ist es mit rausgekommen und ist direkt auf die Glasseitefläche gefallen.
Auf die Butterseite.
Auf die Butterseite, genau. Und weil ich so in schnellem Schritt war, hab ich es dann noch zur Krönung nochmal mit dem Fuß gekickt, sodass es so mit der Butterseite nach unten noch so ein paar Meter über den Asphalt genommen hat. Und die Rückseite, die war tadellos und vorne war halt auch nicht zerkratzt, gleich gebrochen. Das ist wirklich hartes Glas. Das bricht halt dann. Es hat 219 gekostet.
Am Kudam.
Am Kudam. Ich bin direkt in den Apple Store. Die meinten, ja, hm, ja, ne, kann man machen, kostet so und so viel. Und dann, das Machen bestand dann darin, dass jemand von hinten ein neues geholt hat und mir ein neues iPad in die Hand gedrückt hat für diese Strafgebühr von 219.
Also so richtig original eingeschweißt?
Ja, natürlich nicht in der bunten Box, sondern in so einer grauen Schachtel.
Wie mit dem iPhone, die haben so eine Pub-Schachtel, da ist auch kein Netzteil drin, kein gar nichts drin, nur das Device, ohne alles.
Die Verpackung ist nämlich das teure. Aber sie haben ja sozusagen ein altes genommen und wussten daraus, können sie nochmal was machen, weil da ist ja eigentlich alles in Ordnung, da müssen sie nur mal ein Display austauschen.
Du, keine Ahnung.
Klar, das wird refurbisch.
Es hat auch eine neue UID, also man muss es dann neu in seinem Developer-Account anmelden.
Das finde ich aber schon fein, dass sie das so machen.
Kann man eigentlich bei Apple Dumpster-Diving machen?
Diese Art von Dumpster sind, glaube ich, abgeschlossen.
Ich meine, wo kriegen die ganzen Dr. iPhone und wie die ganzen komischen Läden alle heißen, ihre komischen Ersatzteile her, die sie für teuer Geld verhökern? Kriegen sie die auch von den Original-China-Firmen, die dieses kleine Zeug da machen, oder kaufen die den Müll von Apple, oder wie geht das da? Und wirklich, was macht Apple mit seinem Müll? Na, sein kaputten iPad jetzt zum Beispiel.
Nein, das wird wahrscheinlich schon refurbished.
Na ja, sicher, ein Großteil wird refurbished. Also auch viel der Austausch. Es kann sogar sein, dass das Gerät, das du da jetzt hast, refurbished ist.
Das kann auch sein.
Das ist sogar nicht ganz...
Aber es war, ich hab's mir genau angeguckt, das ist also komplett ohne Graupf-Spuren.
Ja, refurbished heißt nicht zerkratzt, sondern eben...
Das Board rausgenommen, in ein neues Gehäuse gesteckt.
Ja, das kann durchaus sein, dass das Mainboard schon mal irgendwo in Betrieb war und schon mal getauscht wurde, weil irgendwas anders war. Das Glas ist natürlich neu. Das sind dann eben auch so im Wesentlichen die Kosten, die du da bezahlt hast. Und sie wissen auch, dass es für sie cooler ist, dir gleich eins in die Hand zu drücken und dich glücklich aus dem Laden rausmarschieren zu lassen, anstatt so, ja, das müssen wir, da kommen sie mal in zwei Wochen wieder, dann kriegen sie mal ein neues und so.
Nee, das ging relativ schnell.
Das ist überhaupt sehr elegant gelöst, so in diesen Apple Stores, mit diesen ganzen Reparatur- und Genius-Prozessen.
Kommt aber demnächst ein bisschen anders, ne?
Ich hörte sowas, aber ich hab da keine...
Die haben ja angekündigt bei Apple, ganz offiziell auch irgendwie, dass sie, ja eben war es glaube ich, der Displaytausch beim iPhone und so, der wurde früher auch direkt getauscht. Und das machen sie jetzt aber ab jetzt oder irgendwie so nicht mehr, sondern sie tauschen im Store. Da gibt es jemanden, der da live sozusagen das irgendwie macht.
Ja, das haben die bei mir auch schon mal gemacht. Das geht aber schnell.
Ja, aber das war vorher, hast halt ein neues noch bekommen.
Das wollen sie jetzt generell nicht mehr machen, oder was?
Ja, die wollen jetzt bestimmte Sachen direkt im Store reparieren und eben kein neues mehr rausrücken.
Ist doch ok, wenn sie das ordentlich machen.
Ja, dann bleibt dann noch deine Judy-ID, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, war voll der Drama hier mit meiner neuen...
Ja, ich hab auch jetzt gerade hier mein altes da auch nochmal zur Reparatur gehabt. Weil da war irgendwie so was mit dem Lüfter.
Das alte... War offensichtlich langweilig.
Ich kann nicht niesen, wenn du gehen musst.
Nein, das war so ein obskurer Fehler. Also der Lüfter funktionierte eigentlich wunderbar. Also außer, dass er zu oft anging für meinen Geschmack, aber jetzt ungefähr so einmal im Monat und dann aber auch den ganzen Tag über macht er immer so komische Geräusche, wollte die sich nicht so richtig in Wallungen bringen lassen.
Monthly Script.
Klack. Klack. Klack.
Und das den ganzen Tag. Klack. Du bist komplett bekloppt bei.
Klack. Das ist, wenn sich die NSA einloggt.
Genau. Ich hab da einen Prism-Lüfter. Könnte ich die gegen Papst austauschen. Naja, das hältst du auf jeden Fall behoben.
Auf Deutsch hast du ja was einverlassen, damit du noch mal ein neues kriegst.
Nö, ich hab genau erzählt, was Sache ist. Ich hab das schon mal in Dresden gehabt, im Apple Store. Da haben sie dann irgendwie mit Reinigungen und Pipapo, aber da hatten sie mir halt schon einen Austausch angekündigt, wenn sich das dann nicht ergibt. Und das hat sich dann halt nicht, hat sich nicht von alleine gelöst oder wurde nicht durch die Reinigung gelöst. Und da sind sie dann eben auch immer wieder sehr kulant zumindest, wenn man Apple Care hat. Dafür ist das ja sehr gut, ne?
Genau.
So, und jetzt muss ich mich halt wieder fragen, was mach ich denn mit meiner alten Hardware? Das ist ja immer die große Frage. Es gibt ja so Leute, die legen dann wirklich jede Generation an Rechnern, die sie schon mal gehabt haben, ins Regal, so?
Ins Archiv.
So, Wassergeier und irgendwie... Ich bin so nicht drauf. Ich hab, glaub ich, den Großteil der Rechner, die ich hatte, was heißt denn Großteil? Alle hab ich, glaub ich, verkauft. Hab ich irgendwas behalten? Ich hab auch kaum noch alte Computer von mir.
Nee, bei PC ist es was anderes. Da benutzt man das Gehäuse weiter und schmeißt dann diverse Motherboard-Kram irgendwie raus und weg, aber...
Nee, eigentlich schmeißt man die Gehäuse auch weg, weil die sehen scheiße aus und sind voll gestaubt und alles und Gehäuse kostet 30 Euro.
Ja, aber ich meine, ein PC-Gehäuse sieht von Anfang an scheiße aus. Es wird nicht dadurch besser, dass man Neues kauft.
Doch, Neues ist sauber, das Altes ist dreckig.
Ich hab noch meinen allerersten Mac. Mein allererstes Powerbook. Das allererste Mac Book. Also, das hab ich nicht zu Hause, aber es ist noch in Betrieb von diversen Familienmitgliedern von alt. Also, nee, mein erster Mac, der steht bei mir zu Hause im Regal, aber...
Ich hab gerade jetzt...
Warte mal, also wer Lust hat, mein altes Air zu kaufen...
Schon, wir waren ja bei der Werbeveranstaltung.
Frisch general überholt und frisch geputzt. Und ohne Prissen. Kommt demnächst auf die Bucht.
Kriegst du Tims Device ID?
Mach Unterschrift drauf. Dicken Erding so.
Tim. Timme.
Pritzer.
Ich kann noch eine Autogrammkarte von dir reinlegen.
Ja, lass uns das mal machen. Wir versteigern hier das Mobile Max Mac Book Pro mit Autogramm von Huckel. Das sind noch Mobile Max T-Shirts. Das müssen wir noch Clemens unterschreiben lassen.
Und dann noch ein Funktional kaputt. Und ein Bumzack-Return-T-Shirt.
Das gibt es dazu.
Für wahre Fans. Genau, für echte Fans.
Wartet bitte.
Er hat mir super Dienste geleistet. Will mich ja überhaupt nicht beschweren über das Gerät.
Also für die, die Zweifel haben, ob das Gerät wirklich was für sie ist, dann hört doch mal die Folgen von Mobile Max, wo Tim über diesen Rechner spricht. Positiv wie negativ.
Ich glaube, da habe ich mir gar nicht so negativ zu geäußert zu dem Gerät, weil das ist eigentlich toll. Wie ich schon sagte, dieses Mac Book Air 11 Zoll, dieses Format, das ist einfach eine Wucht. Das ist einfach echt super. Vor allem diese Verarbeitung. Oder? Also ich meine, früher, was ist noch hier, Titanium G4, als das irgendwie losging, wie die Teile aussahen nach zwei Jahren, vollkommen zerhebelt und zerschrotet und gebrochen.
Am schlimmsten waren die G3s eigentlich.
Nee, am schlimmsten war das Titanium G4.
Wo dieses mit dem Plastierrand noch irgendwie um dem Alu, oder hatte so eine leichte Plastik-Dings oben.
Ja, wo der Deckel so komisch aussah.
Wo dann alle so, wo die Hand drauf lag, da ist langsam dieses Alu...
Nee, das war die Generation danach, das waren die G4s, die Alu G4s. Ich rede noch von dem Titanium. Der erste nicht schwarze, der erste silberne...
Mit der Klappe hinten.
Mit dieser Klappe, was so mega quadratisch, äh, nicht quadratisch, rechteckig war.
Titan als solches sieht halt nicht so unheimlich gut aus.
Das hatte so eine Plastikleiste, so eine ganz schmale.
Titan als solches sieht halt auch nicht gut aus, deswegen hatten sie noch irgendein Belag da drauf, der sich dann runtergeschubbelt hat. Aber ich hatte noch so ein G3, so ein schwarzes und da stimmte der Abstand zwischen der Tastatur und dem Display nicht und das hatte nach einiger Zeit haben sich die Tasten halt in den Screen reingearbeitet.
Deswegen hatten noch alle so Lappen zwischen der Tastatur.
Ich glaube der Rahmen war Metall und das außen drum oder irgendwie so, naja. Aber ich meine, es war ja schon ein schickes Gerät damals.
Es war ein schickes Gerät, aber diese ganze...
Also guck mal, wenn man sich jetzt den Rahmen anguckt, das ist schon ganz schön fett eigentlich, oder? Also ich meine, der ist schön schmal, sieht echt riesengroß aus.
Das Ding war revolutionär damals. Ich meine, auch wenn man das jetzt vom Design her mit dem heutigen vergleicht, finde ich, das besteht immer noch.
Die kleine Space-Taste, die sah die wirklich so klein?
Das japanische Keyboard hier auf dem Foto, das ist, glaube ich, da ein bisschen anders. Nee, aber hinten da, diese Hinges da, also wo das Display dran war, die hielten halt irgendwie nichts aus.
Die sind irgendwann immer gebrochen.
Diese ganze Titanium-Konstruktion hat einfach nicht verhalten.
Ich hab mal ein Display getauscht für jemanden. Da hatte einer eins, das war so durch, da war die Platine irgendwann gebrochen, da hat er keinen Bock mehr gehabt, aber das Display war noch gut. Und ein Freund von mir, der hat sich das Display kaputt gemacht und dann haben wir das eine Display aufs andere Ding draufgeschraubt. Das mach ich auch nie wieder.
Was macht ihr denn mit euren alten Macs?
Ich mach ja gerade meine Bude neu und hab auch gedacht, der alte Scheiß muss mal raus und hab in so einem kleinen Wahn, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es bereue, hab ich einen alten Power Mac 7500 entsorgt. Den hab ich sogar, der hat ja 100 MHz, ich glaub, ich hab da mal so eine Karte.
Das war aber einer von den Geilen.
Das war der erste PCI Mac.
Das wär übrigens mal ein Sport für uns hier, vielleicht können wir das ja heute machen. Wir müssten einfach mal die Hall of Fame der besten Macs ever. Oder wir können ja in jeder Sendung einen Mac wählen. Und ich würd sagen, dieser 7500, da ist einer.
Wie gesagt, aufgerüstet auf 233 MHz mit irgendeiner Original Apple-Karte, glaube ich. Und der Müllmann hat gesagt, schmeißt schön nach hinten, damit die Tonne auch wirklich voll wird. Hab ich gemacht.
Wie am Recyclinghof so in die Container ganz nach hinten geworden.
Und dann hab ich weggeschmissen so ein Duo G4 mit 500 MHz von 2001 oder 2000. So ein Mirror Drive Duo-Teil? Nee, der davor. So ein buntes, blaues Ding. Blau war es, glaube ich.
Nee, blau waren die G3s, die G4s waren glaube ich nicht blau.
Aber dieses Mirror Door war noch nicht, da war dazwischen noch eine ohne Mirror Door.
Eher so grau oder eher so?
Eher so grau.
Ja, irgendwie so. Und den auch so weggeschleudert. Und der war auch so um Aled Maxed, weißt schon? Am Ram und Aled. Und sogar irgendwann mal den DVD-Laufwerk gegen den Schreiber getauscht.
Also sozusagen diese Ursuppe des Aufstiegs. Mac Pro-Designs, so.
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Damit ist ja jetzt vorbei. Zu Ende.
War mein erster Dual-Rechner und da hab ich ja angefangen diesen Diva, diesen Videodekoder, sozusagen der Vorgänger von Handbrake, könnte man so ein bisschen sagen, zu programmieren. Weil ich wollte unbedingt mal was hier mit Dual-Core-Koden und so. Hat ja auch eingeschlagen, war ganz gut. Und ja, fand ich, hat Spaß gemacht. Aber der stand auch jetzt nur rum. Ist halt ein Power-PC, kann man nichts mehr machen. Da kriegst du maximal 10, 5 drauf und sonst nichts. Danach ist ja vorbei. Und ich wollte es ja eigentlich immer so aufheben wegen Lidl und Big Engine, weil es ja doch immer ein bisschen Spaß macht, deinen Code irgendwie so sauber zu halten. Kann ja heute keiner mehr. Und hab ich aber nie gemacht und dachte mir, ja, Tonne. Mein Traum war ja eigentlich mal, Bitcoin nochmal in Big Engine irgendwie hinzukriegen. Aber nachdem, was die da verbrochen haben, hab ich gedacht, nee, das tust du dir nicht an.
Apropos Code sauber halten, das wird ein irrsinniger Spaß, wenn iOS 64 Bit wird. Ich freu mich jetzt schon drauf. Ich kenn da genug Code, der da nicht vordenkt.
Bei dir oder bei Apple?
Ich möchte mich nicht äußern. Im Prinzip ist ein gelöstes Problem. Aber ja, es wird trotzdem ein Riesenspaß.
Kommt noch, weil Amen64 kommt ja das nächste Jahr. Aber was ich jetzt noch erzählen wollte, noch meine Aufräumaktion, was ich nicht weggeworfen hab, ich hab noch zwei Sachen gefunden. Und zwar hab ich noch, ich würde gerne eigentlich loswerden, aber nur an Leute, denen das was wert ist. Wie soll ich es besser ausdrücken? Nur an gute Hände. Denen das was wert ist. Ich hab noch eine Apple Extended-Tastatur. Dieses Monster-Flaggschiff. Die war schön. Hat 400 DM gekostet.
Extended 2?
Ja, dieses fette Ding. 2 glaube ich war es.
Kannst du da mal ein Bild aufmachen?
Mach mal ein Bild auf und schmeiß mal einen Chat.
Das ist die gute.
Die gute, genau. Die hab ich noch.
Die war schön, ja.
Und die hab ich nicht weggeschmissen. Man musste ja damals mit dem Power Mac 7500, der kam ja ohne Tastatur, die musstest du ja dazukaufen. Ja, genau das Teil.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Bevor es den Mac Mini gab, gab es ja sehr lange bei Apple diese Politik.
Die sozusagen schon immer, also damals.
Ja, Tastatur gibt es nicht dazu. Maus war aber immer dabei, lustigerweise.
Ja, kann sein. Ja, und da gab es von Apple auch diese komische Billigtastatur und dann gab es aber auch eben diese Apple Extended Keyboard 2 und das ist es. Und die ist cool, die habe ich noch. Und was ich noch habe, ich habe noch ein CD-ROM, so ein SCSI CD-ROM Laufwerk. Ich glaube, das heißt einfach nur 150. Das ist dieses uralte SCSI CD-ROM Laufwerk von Apple.
Apple CD 150 heißt das.
Ja, das Ding habe ich auch noch, wenn einem...
Mit Caddy.
Nee, mach keinen Scheiß.
Der Apple CD 150 war doch mit Caddy. 150 und die 300?
Dann habe ich, weil ich habe gerade noch, ich habe es noch nicht weggeschmissen. Ich habe zu Hause nämlich noch einen Vierfachbrenner von Yamaha, der ist so ein kleiner Tom. Und den schmeiße ich auch noch weg. Und da habe ich schon das Caddy zugelegt. Und wenn es aber von dem Apple CD 150 ist, dann muss ich das da wieder wegnehmen. Wie gut, dass ich es noch nicht weggeschmissen habe.
Diese riesen Scassi-Stecker drauf. Und wenn man das Kabel verdreht hat, dann steht das Laufwerk immer so schräg hoch.
Also du meinst nicht, wenn das Kabel falsch ist, sondern weil die Kabel so dick waren, hat sich das ganze Laufwerk wurde angehoben. Aber wo ist das jetzt das Ding? So sieht es nicht aus.
Sondern noch älter, ne?
Ja, ich glaube eher noch älter.
Das sieht schon, das ist zu kantig irgendwie. Ja, das ist die neue Generation hier.
Ich hab eins, das sieht so richtig schön, so easy peasy, das würde super zum Quadra 700 passen, so einfach. Ich glaube, das da. Ja, könnte sein.
CD600E steht da.
Das ist aber schon mit Slot-Loading hier.
Ja, dann hab ich es vielleicht auch mit Slot-Loading. Ich glaube auch, dass das Caddy-Ding eigentlich diesem Yamaha-Brenner irgendwie da gehört.
Du sagtest 150 oder 300er, weil die waren definitiv noch so. Das sind noch Zeiten.
Aber das ist doch auch noch was für Leute, die wirklich Geduld haben, oder? So ein altes CD-ROM-Ding.
Naja, das ist halt vor allem, wenn du ein SCSI-CD-ROM brauchst.
Ach geil, da dieser alte CD-Player von Classic Mac OS stimmt, so sah der aus.
Kennst du doch diesen alten Stecker, der da genau bei diesem Laptop dranhängt? Dieser quadratische Stecker, der dann zu SCSI wurde? Meine Fresse, der hatte doch sogar einen Schalter irgendwie mit dran, aus irgendeinem Grund, ne? Da war irgendwas. Man konnte da irgendwas hin und her schalten. Ich weiß nicht mehr wofür, aber der hatte einen Schalter. Weil der konnte nicht nur SCSI sagen, der konnte ja irgendwie zwei Sachen. Dann konntest du so hin und her schalten. Oder war es für den Transfer-Mode oder sowas? Irgendwas konnte der. Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Naja, das sind auch wirklich Geräte, mit denen sich heutzutage wirklich herzlich wenig anfangen lässt.
Das ist nur für Liebhaber, wer noch irgendwie Zeug am Start hat.
Also wer noch ordentlicher am Vintage-Computen ist mit dem Abfüll, der kann sich bei Dennis noch was abholen.
Du sollt ordentliche Gebote einfließen, damit es nicht...
Ich weiß noch, der 7500er Mac. Der war damals wirklich so einer von diesen totalen Befreiungsschlägen.
Der PCI kam halt in die Apple-Welt.
Ja, und der hat auch irgendwie auch ein korrektes Gehäuse gehabt, aber der war leicht zu öffnen.
Mit zwei Händen greifst du so drunter, dann kannst du den Deckel so zu dir ziehen. Dann hast du einen Deckel, den kannst du so aufklappen, da waren die PCI-Slots. Und bei dem anderen konntest du so einen kleinen Plastik-Schnuffi erstmal zur Seite machen und dann das ganze Ding so hoch 90 Grad hochheben, dass es dann so wie so eine Motorhaube so hochkant auf dem kleinen Plastik-Schnuffi stand.
Genau, und unten ist es so ein bisschen eingerastet, dass es steht, ne?
Genau, voll geil.
Eigentlich war da alles super. Und die Festplatten waren auf so ein Plastedings draufgeschraubt und die konntest du da so reinschieben und das hat so richtig geil so, so wie bei Ethernet, bei RJ-514, so ding gemacht, wenn die so eingerastet sind. Und ja, auch alles Gazi innen drin. Mit den G3s später haben sie dann auf IDE umgestellt, genau.
Mein erster Mac war auch der erste Mac, der auch in der ähnlichen Hinsicht schon überzeugt hat, das war nämlich der 2CI 68.030, eine Rakete, 25 Mhz, ging ab.
Ich hab noch das Mac.
Der hatte 20 Mhz, das war ein satte 25% mehr.
Ich hab noch ein Masterboard vorne mit Quadra 840 zu Hause rumstehen.
Diese Quadras, die waren wirklich komisch.
Schnellste 68-Km-Mac ever.
Ja, wobei es gab einen Quadra, der glaube ich das Gehäuse von dem CI noch übernommen hat hier.
Der Quadra 700, den hatte ich auch total geil, bis er irgendwie kaputt gegangen ist.
Sieht ja aus wie NextCube, nur in weiß.
Genau, erstmal finde ich das Design geil, weil das eigentlich nur so eine Box ist. So halt noch diese alte Frog-Design, Linien ganz straight, hier auch so dezent.
Sagt mal, kommt nicht der Johnny Ive von Frog-Design?
Ja, das kann sein. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher.
Schauen wir sofort mal.
Und hat der die schon gemacht oder hat der dann noch in die Windeln geschissen?
Das würde mich jetzt über, wie heißt der nochmal? No Frog-Design.
Aber wo kommt der denn her? Mir war es, als hätte ich was aus England gelesen.
It's a Brit.
Jeder tritt ein Brit.
He designed the second generation of the Newton.
Ach, das hat er schon gemacht. 110.
92 schon.
Ja, der Typ ist wirklich schon verdammt lange dabei. Das ist überhaupt erstaunlich, wie viele Leute sie da wirklich sehr, sehr lange dabei haben. Oder?
Hört man ja auch hier bei den WWDC-Talks, dieser Bud Tribble, Angestellter, Single-Digit-Numbers irgendwie hält noch Reden bei WWDC und dann dieser Dave, wie heißt der? Angestellter Nummer 1 ist er, glaube ich sogar, deswegen hat Jobs sich später, weil er es verpasst hat, irgendwie sich die Null geben lassen oder so. Zwei, ich hab keine Ahnung, auch so der dritte Mitarbeiter oder so was, der hält auch immer noch WWDC-Reden. Irgendwas mit Z heißt er, glaube ich.
Der 1 war doch, glaube ich, Wozniak oder nicht?
Ja, dann halt der. Deiner als 2 war Physik.
Steve Wozniak ist aber schon lange nicht mehr bei Apple.
Ja, den meine ich auch nicht.
Weiß ich ja nicht.
Er hat ja als Praktikant angefangen irgendwie und ist da bis heute und...
Und schreibt immer noch auf seinem 2C.
Chris Espinosa, hier, unser Chat weiß es.
Neulich bei der BPR noch eingefunden.
Doch, nichts mit Z. Der mit Z war ein anderer.
Also... Also ich fand sowieso irgendwie damals, als dann diese Power PC-Geschichte losging, da bin ich ja sowieso auch erst mit Computern so richtig... Da dachte ich mir, okay, das sieht ja mal aus wie ein Computer und dann hat ja ein Kumpel von mir diesen 6100er, den ersten, das war ja glaube ich der erste, der Power PC hatte 601.
Ja, der damals den einen Ausschalter genau an der Stelle hat, wo PC ist, normalerweise den Eject-Button vom Diskette-Later hat.
Ah ja, stimmt, genau, stimmt, da war...
Das wäre so diese super Idee.
Aber das war so, ich weiß noch, als ich den das erst mal gesehen hab, dachte ich mir so, wow, irgendwie, das sieht ja mal nach einem Computer aus, irgendwie so, auch so schlangelegant, irgendwie.
Das war das erste Modell noch mal.
Der 6100er, also der...
Das war der allererste Power-PC, ja.
Auch die noch ohne PCI.
Superflache Pizzaschachtel. Aber immerhin auch mit einer...
Es war nicht alles schlecht mit Nubus.
Auch mit einer AV-Karte drin, immerhin.
Ich hab nicht behauptet, dass Nubus schlecht war.
Nubus war super.
Hier, mach mal den 6100er auch noch mal kurz auf die Show.
Vor allem, wenn man parallel mal so ein PC hatte, der noch mit Industries dann als Architecture gearbeitet hat.
Was sich mich ja geärgert hat bei dem 7500er, dass ich den weggeschmissen hab, also nicht den Rechner, aber ich hätte noch was ausbauen sollen, und zwar das Kettenlaufwerk, weil ich hab da hier mit so einem Arduino irgendwie mir so einen Controller gemacht, der irgendwie die Laufwerke so nativ auslesen kann. Und die bei Apple hat noch immer so einen Motor drin, der automatisch die Diskette auswirft. Und damit hätte ich ja gerne noch mal rumgespielt. Das wär's ja noch, wenn so die Diskette wieder rauskommt. Das kennt ein Waldwurf so mit dem Arduino.
Ja, wenn ich mal irgendwann meinen ersten Mac schlachte, kannst du den Super Drive haben. Mach mal kurz den 6100er auch noch auf dem Schirm. Ich will es nochmal sehen zum Abschluss aus der Graubart-Serie.
Übrigens, hier dafür empfiehlt sich für alle Leute, die es zu Hause auch ein bisschen drin stöbern wollen. Es gibt ja diese Mac App, Mac Tracker oder so. Da sind die alle drin auch mit Images und so. Ja, das sieht ganz schön scheiße aus, aber oder?
Ah, ich weiß nicht. Damals fand ich, dass die anderen hatten so diese fetten, diese Phobis-Computer oder irgendwelche PC-Müll-Eimer.
PC sahen damals noch viel schlimmer aus.
Ja, ich mein, der war halt schlank und das war halt schlicht und simpel und schlank. Der hat einfach die PCs auch locker in die Tasche gesteckt. Ja, da rannte das Photoshop. Da gibt es schon SVGA, wo die PC-User halt noch da irgendwie mit VGA rumgekrepelt sind. Hatte eine AV-Karte drin, dem Ding. Und da konnten wir schon mit dem Camcorder von den Eltern, wollen wir da schon unsere kleine Schull-Nachrichtenshow aufzeichnen, ja.
Mir war das gar nicht bewusst, dass das jetzt der erste Power Mac war.
Ja, PowerPC 601, genau.
Ich hab übrigens noch was zu Hause gefunden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich herhabe. Eine Dutt-Cleaning-Kassette von Apple. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo das Ding her ist. Ich hab nie ein Dutt-Laufwerk gehabt.
Apple hat Dutt-Laufwerke verkauft?
Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab eine Dutt-Cleaning-Kassette von Apple.
Also heute ist wirklich die Vintage-Ecke hier mal ganz ausführlich am Start.
Na, da kann ich nicht so richtig mithalten.
Ja doch, da! Apple External 2GB bei DDS, SCSI, Dat Drive, Relove Max.
In diesem Monster-Kasten?
In diesem Network-Server?
Wo AIX drauf lief?
Ja, das könnt ich mir jetzt mal vorstellen.
129 Dollar nun noch. Oh, und ich hab jetzt gar kein Rechner mehr, wo ich das reinmachen könnte.
Refurbished Part allerdings.
Ja, also wer noch so ein Ding hat, ich hätte da noch eine... Ich glaub, die sind auch original verschlossen, natürlich.
Ich bin total geschockt.
Apple Workgroup-Server, so hieß der.
8.550.
Das war dieses Teil, was so aussah, wie so ein Wägelchen von Stewardessen im Flugzeug.
Ein bisschen was hat's davon.
Ja, mein erster Mac war ja ein Performa 475. Ein ganz fürchterliches Ding.
Quadrad 950. Das Ding haben sie tatsächlich mit DAT ausgeliefert.
Dann ein Schack.
Warum nicht? Also ich meine als Server. Damals hat auf DAT ja noch was draufgepasst.
Naja, das war wahrscheinlich sogar der einzige Computer, wo sie jemals DAT reingetan haben, weil das jetzt irgendwie eine besondere Geschichte aufgebaut hat bei Apple. Da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
200 Megahertz Thunder Schock.
Naja, das sind alles so Zeiten, das kann man sich gar nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen. Interessiert wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal jemanden.
Wenn wir noch unser höherer Meter am Start hätten, dann wäre wahrscheinlich jetzt schon so ein Knicker.
Wir müssen auch mal ab und zu mal vom Krieg berichten. Keiner wie es war damals.
Heutzutage gibt es ja nichts mehr zu berichten.
Wir hatten ja nichts.
Was ich noch gefunden hab?
Es gibt wirklich richtig viel Platz sozusagen.
Er hat nicht von allen Sachen gesagt, dass er sie weggeschmissen hat.
Genau, die DAT-Cassette hab ich noch. Und das CD-ROM und so. Was ich noch gefunden hab, ist eine Original Rhapsody CD. Oder DVD, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ist nicht sowieso mal alle OS-Releases gesammelt?
Ja, aber die ist ja noch älter, bevor ich gesammelt hab. Also die lag da auch noch rum.
Irgendwo hab ich auch noch so eine Rhapsody DR2. Intel sogar.
Ja, die ist die so gelbliche.
Weil da gab's mal von Apple Deutschland so eine Aktion nach der Art, schreibt uns doch mal, was ihr für eine App-Idee habt, die ihr auf Rhapsody schreiben wollt. Und dann schicken wir euch einfach eine Rhapsody-Ding ins Daumen. Da dachte ich mir, kann ja nicht schaden. Richtig, schreibst du mal was hin. Und kam tatsächlich ein Päckchen und da war die CD drin.
Richtig beeindruckt wäre ich jetzt, wenn du eine Copland-TV-CD hättest.
Apropos Päckchen, lass uns doch mal kurz hier die Hörerpost vorlesen, die wir haben.
Hallo Tim, Dennis, Uke, Roddy und Clemens. Da ich in meinem verregneten Urlaub in Kroatien nur Podcasts als Lichtblick hatte, habe ich euch was mitgebracht. Ich habe verschiedene kroatische Biere probiert und das beiliegende Carlo Vatschko war eindeutig vorne. Ich hoffe, das spricht man so richtig aus. Auf Wunsch von Dennis auch etwas Schokia. Sehr gut. Nehmt euch mal ein Beispiel. Wäre ich gleich mal ein Essen. Bitte nur für Mobile-Max-Event, da Holgi für Vrindt ein eigenes Päckchen erhalten hat. Also, hast du gehört, Holgi, du kriegst nix. Du findest Informationen zu diesem Bier auch unter der in der Einweste Null Halde. Also hier mit Link und so. Sollte es in diesem Jahr wieder eine Mate-Krise geben, zeigt euch der beiliegende Zeitungsartikel warum. Ja, den kannten wir schon, aber haben wir gesehen hier, warum den Mate-Unfall hat er uns hier so einen Zeitungsausschnitt mit Bild...
Das Internet ausgedruckt.
Ja, das ist ein Originalausschnitt sozusagen, aber das Foto hat es ja nun wirklich sehr schnell...
rum gemacht, ja.
Ja, dieses Carlo Vatschko, die Eri heißt er.
Prost und Grüße aus der Nähe der Mate-Quelle Eri.
Eri heißt er.
Ja, vielen Dank Eri.
Vielen Dank Eri. Mir hat er ja persönlich auch noch ein Fläschchen geschickt nach Hause und ich hab das auch schon verblockt. Wer will, kann unter Winkenschürfel mal gucken, wie ich das fand.
Na guck ich mal, bevor ich es mir hole.
Nämlich gut fand ich das.
Ah, dann hole ich es mir gleich. Kannst du mich mal kurz muten?
Welches Bissen willst du hier, ne?
Schon gemutet.
Und bringst du mir mein Eis und meinen O-Saft mit, bitte?
Du bist ja immer noch fleißig am Bierbloggen, ja? Herb, Herb, Herb ist das Pivo.
Ja, bitte.
Ja, mach mal wieder auf. Die Kinder haben sich jetzt auch, glaube ich, beruhigt da draußen.
Nee, die sind im Bett.
Ja, da kommt jetzt auch so ein frischer Wind auf.
Der Kinderbefriedete Prenzlauer Berg weht wieder in dieses Studio.
Gut, kommt auch frischer Themenwind auf.
Ja, ich bin fertig. Wenn ich noch mal was finde beim Aufrahmen, sage ich Bescheid. Meine Amiga hab ich aufgehoben, nur mal so nebenbei.
Meinen Amiga übrigens, den habe ich mal gespendet. Und zwar an das erste Computer- und Videospiele-Museum, was es gab in Berlin, was irgendwie so ein Anhängsel an die Seabase war.
Das ist auch das, was es heute noch gibt.
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall, den habe ich das mal geschenkt. Man erkennt den immer noch daran, dass ich, da war bei diesem Amiga irgendwie zwar eine deutsche Tastatur dabei, aber noch mal ein großer Burgen mit Tastatur-Aufklebern zum draufkleben, falls einem die deutsche Tastaturbelegung doch nicht behagt und man wieder amerikanisch haben will, dann hätte man alles überkleben können. Nein, die war deutsch und es gab amerikanische Aufkleber dazu. Und weil da aber auf diesem Amiga dieses fette Commodore noch draufgeprintet war, was mir missfallen hat, habe ich einfach einen Teil der Space-Taste genommen und über diesen Commodore-Schriftzug geklebt. Also wenn da irgendwo ein Amiga rumsteht, ein Amiga 1000, der allererste, wo der Commodore-Schriftzug überklebt ist, dann ist der, den ich mal gespendet habe, vor sehr langer Zeit.
Weil bei den ersten Amiga 1000 stand da nämlich noch Amiga, ne? Das wurde erst später zu Commodore umgelebt.
Nee, da stand da gar nichts. Die hatten irgendwie, wenn ich mich recht erinnere...
Lotus 3, den Haken.
Rechts oben war das Amiga-Logo mit dem Haken. Und links unten hatten sie dann dieses hässliche Commodore-Schriftzug draufgeprintet später. Aber die ersten, diese NTSC-Amigas, die die geringere Auflösung hatten, die hatten nicht den Commodore-Schriftzug. Und nur die PAL-Amigas mit der größeren Auflösung, die hatten eben unten diesen Schriftzug. Stimmt, der Amiga-Schriftzug war links oben.
Na ja, was sollten wir jetzt auch anderes erwarten? Heute sitzt hier mit dem Commodore 64 Basic V2-T-Shirt.
Ja, mein allererster Rechner war ein Commodore 64, aber das ist noch am Rande. Der Amiga ist übrigens daran schuld, diese Amiga 1000, dass ich, was das Mausen angeht, ein Rechshänder bin. Ich bin ja eigentlich Linkshänder, aber die Maus gar nicht nur mit rechts, weil bei diesem Amiga 1000 waren die Anschlüsse für die Maus rechts. Und das Kabel war so kurz, man hätte die Maus gar nicht links benutzen können. Das heißt, man musste die Maus... Ja, man musste die Maus rechts benutzen und deswegen bin ich...
Schonmal hast du von DB9 Verlängerungskabel gehört?
Hier ist eigentlich unsere Links-Rechshänder-Verteilung hier. Rechts. Wir haben jetzt keine Ahnung.
Das war jetzt wichtig.
Nö, ob es wichtig ist, weiß ich nicht, aber... Vielleicht später mal. Man muss ja auch ein paar unnütze Daten sammeln. Ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht möchte ja jemand was über uns...
Vielleicht kommt die Erkenntnis des Pattern erst später.
Das Programm gibt es ja viel her.
Das geilste Feature an diesem Amiga 1000 war ja immer noch, dass man die Tastatur drunter schieben konnte.
Allerdings, sonst wäre die nämlich jetzt schon mal mir zugestaubt.
Und das Tastaturkabel war auch so, als Spiralkabel gebaut, dass das genau gepasst hat. Man hat die rausgezogen, dann hat das Spiralkabel sich ein wenig verlängert, so dass man die Tastatur benutzen konnte und wenn man sie wieder reingeschoben hat, hat sich das wieder so verkürzt, dass das genau alles...
Perfekte Hinterlaken einer Tastaturbreite. Willst du mich mal besuchen, camarade? Ich hab das alles noch genauso am Start. Nur der Fernseher dazu, der ist jetzt auch im Müll. Ich hab kein Bildschirm mehr dafür.
Ich hatte diesen...
1084.
Ich hatte den Monitor, ja.
Hier, skipp mir jetzt mal sonst, artet das aus hier.
Ich war ja damals so ungeduldig für den Amiga, weil das sich ewig verzögert hat. Das Ding kam nicht und kam nicht und kam nicht. Und dann hab ich so einen großen Fehler gemacht und hab mir einen Atari ST gekauft.
Der hatte einen super Monitor und eine super beschissene Tastatur.
Ja, und ein super beschissenes OS und war eigentlich auch überhaupt...
Ja, das war nur so ein halbes OS, ne?
Ja, das war so ein DOS-Klon.
Was ja auch nicht ausgeliefert wird, sind diese Bitcoin-Miners, ne? Das ist auch so krass.
Diese Geräte.
Ja, diese ASICs, Miner, die...
Die wir ja schon ein paarmal gesprochen haben.
Ja, die immer noch nicht...
Ja, was meinst du? Die haben eine große Halle angemietet mit einem dicken Stromanschluss.
Ich liefern sie ja aus.
Wollen wir das Thema nach hinten schieben? Weil dann wollen wir eh nochmal mit Bitcoin kommen. Ich würde jetzt ganz gern mal wieder ein bisschen in die Zukunft kommen, nicht dass wir jetzt hier so einen Alte-Leute-Podcast machen und uns irgendwie gegenseitig dafür auf die...
Da können wir ja gleich dicht machen.
Schultern klopfen, was wir für schlechte Computer hatten.
Was hast du gegen die 80er?
Gar nichts.
Das ist schade.
Nichts Gerichtfestes zumindest.
Ja, keine Ahnung, es gab hier von iOS 7 das tolle neue OS, was alles total neu und anders und weiß macht.
Diskussionswürdig zumindest macht.
Gab's eine neue Beta?
Wird immer besser.
Hat sich irgendwas dramatisch geändert?
Ja, die Schrift wird dicker.
Wir sind jetzt von Helvetica Neue Ultra oder Leit Ultra auf Helvetica Neue Normal irgendwie. Können wir leider nicht, weil es da...
Ach, die Schrift, die war, wie soll ich sagen...
Nimm mal sein Testtelefon hier.
Ich könnte dir ja auch noch so ein iPhone 4 irgendwie opfern.
Bitteschön.
Ach, da immer noch diese Icons.
Ja, die Icons sind schon noch da.
Ja, die Schrift, die war schon sehr magersüchtig.
Aber was sie jetzt zum Beispiel geändert haben, wenn Apps installieren, dann gibt es halt so ein Tortendiagramm.
Die hast du sogar automatisch gestellt.
Ja, aber wenn du da gerade zuguckst, dann machen die das.
Wenn das Icon erst dunkel, dann kriegt es so einen Kreis und dann füllt sich der Kreis so tortenmäßig langsam aus. Und wenn er voll ist, dann wird das ganze Icon hell.
Dann machst du noch so Pssst, Pssst, Pssst, Feuerwerk, links und rechts. Aber im Wesentlichen füllt es sich jetzt mit der dritten Beta noch stabiler an und hackt weniger und rebooted weniger und...
Ja, ist jetzt selbst auf dem 4S benutzbar.
Also ich meine, große Änderungen habe ich jetzt bisher sonst noch nicht feststellen können, aber...
Ich glaube, die Icons haben sich auch nicht verändert.
Also, ja, die Schrift ist jetzt schon auch so ein bisschen angenehmer für das Auge.
Ich habe den Unterschied erstmal gar nicht so richtig mitgekriegt.
Ich auch nicht.
Weil es gibt nämlich unter Accessibility gibt es nämlich so einen Schalter, dicke Schrift verwenden. Und wenn du vorher den Schalter anhattest und dann die neue Version installiert hast, dann hat sich nichts geändert, weil sie jetzt halt standardmäßig die Decare-Schrift benutzen. Also, ich meine, das ist jetzt so von die Schrift ist so von Magersüchtig auf Model. Mal sehen, so richtig adipös wird die nicht mehr.
Nee, aber jetzt ist genau richtig, finde ich.
Bis auf die Uhr im Homescreen, da habe ich oder Log-Screen, da habe ich immer noch das Gefühl, die kann ich nicht richtig erkennen. Das ist so, wenn ich morgens der Wecker klingelt, ich habe die Brille noch nicht an.
Du weißt das jetzt aber im Log-Screen oben, mir die Lays haben es auch dicker gemacht, ne?
Zum entsperren streichen?
Slide to unlock.
Ja, immerhin steht da jetzt mal was da. Also bei der ersten Beta war der nur entsperren, bei der zweiten Beta war der entsperren und zwei größer Zeichen, damit du weißt, in welche Richtung du da schieben musst. Und jetzt steht da...
Wir brauchen jetzt das Video von dem kleinen Mädchen, was irgendwie das iOS 7 nicht entsperren kann. Scheiße. Sevenlock, Baby Girl, ist sogar deutsch, ne?
Aber was halt wirklich eigentlich so das schönste Feature immer noch ist, ist dieses Auto-Updaten. Also das ist wirklich toll. Also man denkt gar nicht mehr drüber nach und freut sich einfach, dass...
Auto-Updaten von was? Aber dann weiß man ja nicht mehr, dass sich was geändert hat. Kann man das auch abschalten?
Kann man glaube ich auch abschalten.
Im Prinzip kann man das abschalten, aber auf der anderen Seite, da man sowieso immer alles updaten drückt, ist das auch egal.
Aber ich lese immer die Release-Modes vorher durch.
Du kannst die immer noch, weil du kriegst die Update-Historie angezeigt.
Und du kannst auch ausscheißen, dass er das nicht über GSM-Dingens macht.
Was hat sich geändert? Das kriegst du immer noch angezeigt.
Also du kannst in den App Store klicken, dann gibt es da so Updated und siehst sowas, was sich so geändert hat.
Und wenn da gerade kein Netzhaus steht, da pending, dann macht das demnächst, wenn du wieder im WLAN bist.
Es gibt so einige Ups, die haben so großartige Release-Nodes, wo ich mich jedes Mal wegwerfe. Grad bei Updated scheint das sehr verbreitet zu sein. Da gibt es gerade so einen Schönheitswettbewerb mit den lustigsten Release-Nodes. Also ganz weit vorne ist dieser Typ, der ist dieser ehemalige Twitter-App-Programmierer, der dieses Game gemacht hat. Genau, der hat mal die Release-Nodes von Letterpress gelesen.
Der macht da mal voll die witzigen Sachen rein.
Ich dachte, ich sterbe vor Lachen. Das war so komisch. Ich krieg das jetzt nicht mehr zusammen zitiert.
Seine Frau hat gesagt, er soll da was ändern, sonst gibt's Ärger und so.
Ja, genau so was. Das war wirklich lustig.
Klickt mal das Video da.
Video klicken.
Was heißt hier, Soundsystem routen?
Ja, aber da fehlt ein Space, deswegen musst du das von hinten bis zum HTTP kopieren. Da kannst du nicht direkt klicken.
Von hinten?
Wo ist da jetzt was falsch?
Ah, bei mir hat das nicht funktioniert.
Und das gibt jetzt auch ohne Bild was her? Für unsere geschätzte Hörerschaft?
Nee, ohne Bild nicht, aber für uns erstmal.
Das sind 35 Sekunden.
Man sieht das Kind, macht ein Slido-Unlock und benutzt irgendwelche Apps.
Das ist keine 4 das Kind, oder?
Das Kind drückt den Home-Button, kriegt den Log-Screen, guckt komisch und weiß nicht, was es tun sollte.
Das brauchen wir aber gleich, die Arme. Und ich meine jetzt nach wie vielen Wochen gibt es iOS 7 jetzt vier, glaube ich. Nach zwei Wochen kam das Update und dann noch mal zwei Wochen, also vier Wochen. Und ich habe auch immer noch Probleme, morgens schlaftrunken oder wenn du gerade nicht so fit bist, mein Phone zu anlocken. Der optische Hinweis fehlt in welche Richtung?
Vor allen Dingen haben sie die Richtung geändert.
Also es ist irgendwie, also irgendwas ist da komisch. Und wir haben es ja gesehen bei dem Kind auch, es geht einfach nicht mehr.
Ja, das sind so kleine kosmetische...
Ja, ich finde es jetzt auch nicht mega schlimm.
Das finde ich alarmierend mit dem Baby. Ich kann es gerade gar nicht mehr benutzen, weil es irgendwie gelockt ist.
Ja, aber eine Kleinigkeit, was wir noch geändert haben, bei Beta 3 ist, dass jetzt im Log-Screen oben die Info-Zeile ist jetzt eine Größe größer. Hier, weißt du, was ich meine? Also hier, das oben ist jetzt fett, als wenn du drin bist.
Was ist größer?
Im Log-Screen, die Uhrzeit, ne Quatsch, die Signalstärke, die Batterieanzeige und so. Die Status-Zeile. Genau, die ist...
Also sie wollen immer noch bei diesen komischen Bubbles da bleiben, ja?
Bubbles heißt?
Weil sie haben da diese komischen...
Die Signalstärke.
Seifenblasen für die Signalstärke.
Also da muss ich sagen, das stört mich jetzt nur so mäßig.
Nimmt halt viel mehr Platz ein. Fand ich jetzt nie so mega wichtig, dass das jetzt unbedingt nochmal mehr Raum bekommen müsste. Oder?
Und im Kalender gibt's Änderungen.
Ja, es gibt jetzt so wie im alten Kalender so Bubbles, wenn da was ist.
Ach so, die Bubbles. Ja, ja, das ist wichtig.
Aber die sind ein bisschen zu unscheinbar.
Ja, ist ein bisschen blöd, wenn man halt an jedem Tag ne Bubble hat.
Ja, aber die sind nicht...
Das ist so...
Bubble, Bubble.
Aber waren die vorher auch farbig?
Die waren vorher glaub ich farbi...
Man denkt ja immer, früher war alles besser und dann war es eigentlich schlechter. Ja, aber an sich, also im Detail, kann man da sicherlich an dem einen oder anderen rumkritteln, aber ich muss sagen, hier so mit dem Scrolling. Ich hab jetzt auch das Gefühl, ich fühl mich jetzt auch wirklich ein bisschen verstanden. Mit dem Scrolling, ich meine mal ehrlich, so durch die Wochen durchzuscrollen, das ist doch wohl der... Das ist doch der totale No-Brain-er, oder? Ich meine, so wollte ich das immer haben. Und jetzt haben sie es genau so gemacht. Du kannst auch hier mal durch die Jahre, also auch genau so, das ist auch schick.
Schönen Applaus.
Mach mal Landscape Mode.
Na, da kommt immer nur die Woche. Genau.
Obwohl, man kann die schieben, aber nur eine ganze halt immer oben.
Wie eine ganze was?
Na, man kann die Woche halt hier so. Nee, doch nicht, man kann auch weniger schieben.
Ja, aber es ging auch schon vorher. Ja, weiß ich nicht, so diesen Wochenview nur auf Landscape zu beschränken, das finde ich ehrlich gesagt doof. Ich will eigentlich immer alles in beiden Views machen können, oder mindestens in Porträt. Das macht einfach nicht Sinn.
Und es gibt im Landscape-Modes keinen Today-Button?
Wir sind begeistert. Wie ist es mit deinem Eis, Alter?
Alles geil.
Ich weiß nicht, an der Farbgebung kann ich mich immer noch nicht so richtig gewöhnen, aber das ist wahrscheinlich alles mal wieder nur Gewöhnungsfrage.
Mit diesem Hintergrund? Na ja gut, ich habe jetzt auch einen komischen Hintergrund gesetzt. Vor allen Dingen, damit man schön sieht, wie sich alles bewegt, ist er halt so kleinteilig. Aber so ein bisschen, finde ich, wirkt es billig. Weil es doch nicht so perfekt funktioniert. Dass eine Illusion entsteht, sondern es schwabbelt so ein bisschen rum. Und man hat so das Gefühl, so wollen die mich verarschen.
Was man aber machen kann, ist, man kann...
Ich finde, es funktioniert überhaupt nicht... Also wenn es wirklich irgendwie dahinter wäre, dann müsste es ja auch was bringen, wenn man das Telefon...
Ja, dieser Parallax-Effekt...
Ja, du kannst da, warte, du kannst da ein Landscape-Foto dahinter packen und dann kannst du dein Telefon so bewegen und dann bewegt er sich im Landscape so rum. Das ist voll geil, muss man machen.
Gib mal so ein Panorama-Bild.
Ja, genau, Panorama, mach mal.
Ich hab an der Ostsee ein paar schöne Panoramas gemacht.
Panoram... Panorami-i. Das erinnert mich daran, dass das Pluralizer-Modul von Ruby on Rails die korrekte Mehrzahl von Octopus bilden konnte.
Aber wir wurden doch... Wurden wir nicht letztes Mal wieder mal für Dummheit und Ignoranz geschunden?
Stimmt, genau, Moment. Das haben wir nämlich... Das hast du elegant wegmoderiert. Wer hat uns mit der CDU verglichen? Was war der Kontext bitte? Und wen können wir da... Eben können wir da...
Abbildte leisten.
Wer hat gesagt... Ich will...
Joannet connected to the Internet, sagt er mir hier gerade. Ich komm mal kurz.
Warst du im Blog oder was? Im Kommentaren?
Muss ich das jetzt skalieren? Einfach klein lassen. So, festlegen.
Na, guck ich da auch mal in die Kommentare und suche nach CDU.
Das war nicht in der letzten Sendung, sondern glaub ich in der vorletzten Sendung.
War das CDU oder war das...
Piraten.
Ich war nicht sicher, aber irgendwann irgendein Vergleich kam doch auf.
Das fasziniert mich jetzt noch nicht so sehr.
Gut, also, wir machen mal kurz so eine kleine Warteschleife.
Was denn?
Auf ADN war der, hier guck mal, da gibt's einen Link, Kampfhase hat im Chat gerade uns einen Link zum Up.net-Post geschickt, wo angeblich dieser CDU... Ach so, die Mobile Macs sind auch immer mehr die Christdemokraten unter den Mac-Nerds. Alles neu erstmal ablehnen, weil anders. Krasses Scheiß.
Interessant, das ist aber genau das, was ich vorhin meinte, was ich irgendwie vermisst habe. Und jetzt machen sie das sogar.
Ja, wenn ein Bild halt nur so einen Winkel abbildet, dann ist... Aber es ist so ein blödes Feature. Also es ist nicht mal ein Feature, das ist irgendwie nur Spielerei.
Ich finde es auch nicht hilfreich. Also kann man das eigentlich abschalten? Nein, dann nicht. Denn wenn du an der Sendung teilnehmen willst, empfehle ich dir den Einsatz eines Mikrofons. Ja, dafür hast du eine Rolls-Bars-Taste, die funktioniert auch mit Eis essen.
Die ist doggelbar.
Dann sei einfach ruhig und isst.
Ich könnte für dich die Rolls-Bars-Taste drücken, weil wenn du isst...
Also sehr viel sinnvoller, fände ich ja, und ich glaube, irgendeines dieser mobilen, anderen MeToo-US macht das, glaube ich, auch. Das, wenn ich jetzt so ein Landscape-Bild habe und ich gehe jetzt auf dem Homescreen von Page zu Page, dass dann das Bild mitzieht, das wäre doch mal hilfreich, weil dann sehe ich nämlich auch auf den ersten Blick, wo bin ich denn eigentlich.
Aber da hat Android ein Patent drauf, das dürfen sie nicht.
Ehe, keine Ahnung, aber...
War das überhaupt Android?
Die hatten aber so ein Feature, wo man so durchslidet und das Bild dabei wandert.
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen anstrengender. Also das können sie sich von mir aus noch sparen. Mit der Parallaxe.
Ja, ich finde diese Parallaxe, das wirkt so billig, weil es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Ja, und hiermit irgendwie alles Neue ablehnen, ich weiß nicht, würde ich jetzt mal nicht sagen, dass wir hier alles Neue ablehnen. Wir fordern hier auch einiges Neues und wenn es dann kommt, ist ja auch mal okay. Aber das heißt jetzt auch nicht, dass irgendwie alles, was generell jetzt neu ist, ist ja auch nicht unbedingt deshalb gut, weil es neu ist.
Nein.
Und ich denke auch, dass hier das letzte Wort auch noch nicht gesprochen ist mit diesem ganzen iOS 7. Wenn schon Babys das nicht mitmachen. Weil das ist nämlich jetzt... Du müsstest das doch auch kennen.
Auf dem iPad 1, da läuft sowieso kein iOS 7.
Ja, aber das wirklich Erstaunliche ist, die allerkleinsten Kinder schnallen diese Bedienung von dem iPhone in null Komma nix. Mit einer geradezu...
So würde ich das jetzt nicht sehen. Das ist ja antrainiertes Verhalten und das klappt jetzt bei dem neuen nicht mehr. Das hat ihr nicht von selber rausgefunden, bei dem normalen.
Aber hallo.
Nee, das gucken die ab.
Nein.
Bist du sicher?
Ja.
Schick mal dein Kleinkind drüber, wir machen dir mal ein paar empirische Tests.
Das ist schon komplett ver-iOSifiziert. Von daher ist das...
Schon voll, komplett eppige Fanboyt, ja?
Nee, also ich erinnere mich auch, dass das schon mal so ähnlich war. Es gab mal einen schönen Artikel von jemanden, der so ein E-Mate hatte. Diese Klingonenhandtasche, dieser Newton mit Tastatur.
Der war in unserem Jahresendrätsel gefragt.
Klingonenhandtasche.
Das erste Translucent-Gehäuse.
Richtig, genau. Das war feist, ne? Das war ja... Das haben wir dieses Jahr... War das jetzt letztes Weihnachten? Oder haben wir das jetzt noch mal?
Keine Ahnung, erzähl weiter.
Nein, nicht mein Kind, sondern jemandes Kind, der... also er beschrieb einfach, wie leicht es diesem Kind gefallen sei, mit so einem E-Mate klarzukommen. Mit draufmalen und so weiter. Also dass der Zugang da einfach ist. Und ich meine, ich denke, ist mittlerweile auch klar, dass natürlich diese ganze Touch-Generation von Geräten eine Zugänglichkeit für Leute geschaffen hat, die eben naturgemäß mit dieser Default Komplexität herkömmlicher PCs nicht klarkommt. Das schließt halt ältere, nicht so netzaffine Leute ein, genauso wie eben Kinder, kleine Kinder. Die sich natürlich dann später auch in beliebig komplexe Systeme reinfummeln können. Aber das mit diesem Touch und dem Swipe, mit diesem dieses gestenbedient Konzept, das schnallen sie irgendwie alle. Und ohne dass man ihnen groß irgendwas erklären muss. Kann ich ausschließen, dass da jetzt auch mal ein Abgucken mit dabei war. Aber auch das funktioniert besser als, wenn jetzt ein Kind dir eine halbe Stunde dabei zuschaut, wie du was in die Command-Line einhatst, dann macht er das ja auch nicht gleich nach.
Kontroll, alt, entfernen, zum Anmelden drücken. Letztens, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo war das? Ich glaube im Flugzeug, da sagst du dann auch, es gibt ja immer so Business-Leute, die haben dann immer irgendwie so schäbige Notebooks oder so. Ihr kennt das ja, du als Zugfahrer wahrscheinlich auch, wenn dann so dieses Excel-OS gebootet wird. Und wir sitzen dann da so vor dem Rechner und machen es sich schön und so im Kostüm oder im Anzug und noch ein Kaffee dazu. Und dann bootet das und es bootet und es bootet.
Da vorne haben die auch diese 20 Zoll Laptops.
Ja, und dann guckst du, um dir spielt eine Runde Tiny Wings, guckst rüber, ah, es bootet immer noch. Und dann bitte warten, jetzt geht es auch wirklich los. Und dann kommt schon das Lock-in-Fenster und dann dauert es aber noch mal ein bisschen, bis die Eingabemaske kommt, weil, ach nee, erst musste Kontroll-Alte entfernen. Dann hat sie ihr Passwort eingegeben und es rödelte. Ich wäre schon total wahnsinnig geworden.
Und dann ist es endlich oben und dann kommt das Schaffen, er klappt schnell zu, gibt die Fahrkarte, macht wieder auf und, ah, Scheiß, abgestürzt.
Ja, nee, aber dann erst mal, bis sich die ganzen Icons auf dem Desktop, es war wie so eine Zeitreise, nur dass es halt wirklich Windows 7 war. Und dann so rataratarata und dann wirklich erst mal das Outlook OS, also das E-Mail-Betriebssystem macht, das Subsystem gebootet und als Excel, da kommt man sich echt, da denkt man echt so, Mensch, die armen Leute, also dass die im 21. Jahrhundert noch so was über sich ergehen lassen.
Ich hatte ja bei meinem neuen Job als allererstes mal ein Dell Notebook in die Hand gedrückt bekommen und da dachte ich auch so, der sieboote dieses Teil und ich denke mir, wie lange bootet der denn noch? Wann zeigt der mir denn endlich mal ein Login-Screen? Und dann so nach zwei, drei Minuten komme ich drauf, da steht was von Control Alt Delete. Stimmt, man muss bei Windows ja diesen affigen Affengriff erstmal machen, damit man sich anmelden kann. Das haben sie irgendwie immer noch nicht aus dem System raus.
Dein Mikrofon zeigt auch auf deine Puppille als auf dein Sprechzentrum. Oh, jetzt viel direkter. Die Dynamik, vielleicht ganz anderer Dynamikanschlag hier.
Dein Mikrofon zeigt auf dein Nasenloch.
Das ist auch bewusst so gewählt, in mein Nasenloch, da resoniert es noch nämlich.
Da kommen die Höhen raus.
Da kommt der Huckel-typische nasale Sound bei zustande. Das ist mein Trademark.
Gewagte Thesen hier beim Overmax 114. Ja, was gibt es denn überhaupt noch so? Gab es nicht so ein bisschen Erata nachzuliefern? Roddy, du sagst, wir oder du oder ich hätten Müll erzählt.
Ich hatte erzählt, dass man irgendwelche Dämon schreiben könnte. Das ist so nicht ganz richtig. Richtig ist, es gibt irgendwie einen neuen Background-Mode. Da startet iOS die eigene App im Hintergrund. iOS ist ja relativ aggressiv, wenn eine App nichts mehr zu tun hat, dann wird sie einfach abgeschossen. Wenn der User dann wieder draufklickt, dann wird sie wieder gestartet und die App soll sich bitte schön wieder so konfigurieren, wie sie vorher war, damit der User nicht merkt, dass sie zwischendrin nicht gelaufen ist. Was okay ist, man bekommt da einige Hilfen, um das hinzukriegen. Aber jetzt hat Apple mal ein Einsehen gehabt und festgestellt, ja doch, es gibt so einige Use-Cases, wo es sinnvoll ist, dass die App im Hintergrund läuft. Und trotzdem wollen sie einem natürlich die App abschießen können. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, dass iOS die App im Hintergrund startet. Die ist dann nicht zu sehen, sondern läuft nur als Hintergrund. Die App kann irgendwas machen und da gibt es so ein paar Möglichkeiten. Das eine nennt sich Background Fetching. iOS versucht herauszufinden, wann welche App irgendwie Daten aus dem Netz holt und sich selbst updatet. Und sie versprechen, wir werden sehen, wie gut es dann hinterher funktioniert, dass sie irgendwann herausfinden, der User hat morgens um 7 seinen Wecker und das erste, was er tut, nachdem der Wecker geklingelt hat, macht sein Twitter-Programm auf und guckt mal nach, ob neue Tweets für ihn gekommen sind. Das heißt, wenn der User sowieso diese Twitter-App irgendwie um 3 nach 7 immer startet, dann können wir die ja im Hintergrund schon um 3 vor 7 starten, dass die sich die neuesten Daten zieht, die Daten aktuell hat, sodass wenn der User sie dann 3 nach 7 startet, die schon die aktuellen Daten hat. Nennt sich Background-Fetching. Das versprechen sie. Also wie gut das dann funktioniert, wie gesagt.
Jetzt müsste man mal Tips Gesicht-Livestreams.
Die Skepsis in Reiform so. Das zweite sind sogenannte Silent Notifications, Remote Notifications, die Silent sind, die vom Notification-Server kommen, wie die anderen, die angezeigt werden. Nur, dass sie genau das Gleiche tun, sie starten die App und die App kann dann Daten ziehen und kann sich dann wieder beenden mit ich hatte Daten oder nein, es gab keine Daten oder hat halt nicht funktioniert. So, damit die App dann später noch mal gestartet werden kann. So und das dritte, was ich eigentlich am interessantesten finde, das sind die sogenannten URL-Sessions oder NSURL-Sessions, nennen die das. Das ist so eine Art URL-Transfer, den ich beim OS eintüten kann. Ich kann also sagen, hier die Adresse, lad mir das mal runter.
Und in der Zeit muss die App nicht laufen und man wird geweckt, wenn es da ist. Richtig, das hatte ich ja schon erzählt.
Genau, aber eben auch als als Hintergrund gestartet.
Also Files.
Stell dir vor, du willst einen Podcast haben, 200 MB groß und du bist aber irgendwie unterwegs und du hast gerade nur 10 Kilobyte-Sekunde, würde ja ewig dauern. Dann geht deine App aus, das OS lädt das ganze Ding mit ihren eigenen Routinen und wenn es da ist, wird deine App, wird Bescheid gesagt, jetzt hier, da ist es.
Und sie versprechen, sie versprechen, dass diese URL-Sessions ein Reboot überleben. Der macht also die URL-Session, er macht den Download weiter, obwohl du das OS neu gestartet hast, zwischendrin das iPhone aus hattest oder so. Das versprechen sie.
Da ist ja wieder der State.
Da ist er wieder der State.
Und wenn das HTTP das dann nicht kann, hier mit Ranges und wie auch immer das da alles heißt, dann fängt es ja von vorne an, nehme ich an.
Ja, aber ich meine die Zeiten, wo das irgendwelche Server nicht können, die sind doch langsam vorbei, oder?
Es gibt noch viele schlecht konfigurierte Webster.
Ja gut, aber ich sag mal, wenn du eine App bist, die das verwendet, um mit Servern zu reden, die dir selber gehören, dann solltest du in der Lage sein, das hinzukriegen.
Ja, aber das bei Podcasting zum Beispiel nicht der Fall.
Ja, Podcasting hat ja so seinen eigenen Set von Problemen.
Genau, zum Beispiel, dass die nicht selber gehören.
Ja, aber prinzipiell ist es was, wenn es funktioniert, dann sollte das auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Also ich finde das ja an sich eine sehr wünschenswerte Geschichte. Ist das jetzt sozusagen alles, was wir an Background-Aktivität zusätzlich bekommen?
Ja, im Prinzip schon. Bei iOS 7 hat ja diesen neuen Multitasking-Switcher, wo du, wenn du durch die Apps durchswipes, jeweils ein Bild siehst von der App, wie sie gerade läuft oder glaubst es zu sehen. Der Trick ist nämlich, das was du siehst ist nur ein Screenshot im Zweifelsfall. Und wenn deine App aus dem Hintergrund, im Hintergrund aufgeweckt wird, solltest du als App nämlich auch dein User-Interface updaten. Und wenn du dich dann wieder beendest, macht das OS von deinem geupgedateten User-Interface einen Snapshot, einen Screenshot quasi. Und der wird dann auch in dem App-Switcher angezeigt, sodass du als User die Illusion bekommst, deine App wäre im Hintergrund, würde laufen und hätte aktuelle Daten. Obwohl sie nicht lauscht, sie hat irgendwann mal Daten geholt, aber sie läuft nicht. Achso, und das mit den Notifications ist natürlich so, dass du, wenn du so eine Silent-Notification bekommst, kannst du als App natürlich sagen, ja, das ist eine wichtige Notification, da kann ich ja auch eine lokale Notification noch an den User schicken. Also insofern, wenn ich den einen Talk richtig verstanden hab, wollen sie diese Remote-Notifications, die ganz an der App vorbeigehen, auch mehr oder weniger dann einstampfen?
Sprich mehr Silent-Notifications mit Laufmal und wenn das Programm es dann hat, macht das selber dann eine Human-Readable-Locale-Notification und dann heißt es auch, dass die Daten vorhanden sind und nicht erst nochmal nachgeladen werden muss aus, gibt eh keinen Netz.
Genau, wenn du da deine Direct Message bekommen hast, bekommst die, dein Server sagt dir, hier ist eine neue Direct Message, dann kann deine App im Hintergrund die Direct Message runterladen, kann die Direct Message als Notification anzeigen und wenn der User sagt, das will ich jetzt lesen, weil es ist ja nur der Anfang davon oder so, dann kommt die App nach vorne und hat aber schon die aktuellen Daten, weil sie im Hintergrund ja schon die Daten runtergeladen hat.
Ich frage mich mal, was da für User-Agents dabei rauskommen, was für User-Agents Trinkster dabei rauskommen, wenn das OS jetzt die Downloads macht.
Das weiß ich nicht, aber im Zweifelsfall kannst du natürlich sagen...
Es hat die Downloads ja auch vorher schon gemacht für dich, wenn du das über die Standard-Routinen gemacht hast.
Ich glaube im Zweifelsfall kannst du den selber angeben.
Ja stimmt.
Also insofern...
Nee stimmt, du hast recht, natürlich klar. Jetzt wird ja im Prinzip schon das selbe Framework benutzt.
Also wenn du die kompletten billigen Routinen nimmst mit NS-Data-from-all, dann hat das ja eh alles schon auch das OS gemacht.
Ja, aber diese NS-URL-Connection, das ist ja das, was die meisten Leute verwenden, weil es leistungsfähig ist. Das ist ja nichts anderes. Ich glaube, dass die URL-Session ja auch nur darauf abbildet.
Ja, hoffentlich macht die mal auch alles richtig.
Ja, das werden wir dann sehen. Also ich meine, so eine neue Technik, die muss halt auch abhängen. Und bei iOS 7.1 wird es dann hoffentlich ganz gut funktionieren.
Also der Martin von Instacast hat ja auf seiner Webseite auch schon angekündigt, dass er für iOS 7 wieder eine neue Version rausbringen will von Instacast. Also im Sinne von...
Das ist total sinnvoll.
Eine ganz neue, die halt nicht Instacast 3 ist, sondern dann wohl Instacast 4 oder so. Ja, also sozusagen wieder alles neu und dann wahrscheinlich auch in neuem Gewandewelt, würde ich mal vermuten. Weil wenn man glaube ich jetzt schon gleich für iOS 7 macht, dann will man sich dann wahrscheinlich auch dem Look and Feel da irgendwie gleich mit anpassen. Na, mal schauen. Also gerade was so Downloaden betrifft, also man möchte ja meinen, dass so Downloaden bei so Podcast-Apps eine Stärke ist. Also ich meine, das ist ja so, abgesehen vom Auswählen geht es ja vor allem darum. Und da gibt es noch so ein paar Probleme. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du weißt, ob iOS 7 da was Neues bringt. Aber zum Beispiel, so ist mir das berichtet worden. Du kannst ja so rein, also Podcast-App weiß hier neue Folge. Du bist unterwegs, willst die hören. Und dir ist es total wichtig, jetzt sofort die so schnell wie möglich zu hören. Willst nicht warten, bis die runtergeladen ist. Also gehst du in dieses, na dann stream ich das halt, weil du kannst ja quasi die Verbindung auch aufmachen und direkt abspielen. Und vorausgesetzt, es kommt schnell genug, reißt ja der Stream dann auch nicht ab. Und vorausgesetzt natürlich auch, der Stream reißt nicht ab. Sonst reißt der Stream ab. So, jetzt möchtest du aber natürlich, dass wenn du jetzt im Rahmen dieses Streamings schon die Hälfte runtergeladen hast, dann für den eigentlichen Download, den du dann vielleicht trotzdem noch initiieren möchtest, nicht noch mal diese Hälfte auch noch mal runterladen willst. Dass quasi so das, was da gestreamt wird, auch gleich gecashed wird. Und das sieht, glaube ich, wenn man das halt so mit dem iOS, HTTP-Kram macht, ist das so ein bisschen so eine Entweder-Oder-Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht genau, bei welcher Abis das jetzt konkret läuft, aber das fände ich mal ganz interessant, ob solche Aspekte auch noch mit berücksichtigt werden.
Also ich hatte den Anwendungsfall noch nicht, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob du tatsächlich explizit Ranges downloaden kannst von irgendwelchen Sachen, wo du ihm sagst, ja fang mir bitte erst bei 2500 an.
Ja, das kannst du unter Garantie, aber dann sagst du halt auch explizit, ich will es hier runterladen, aber dieses Streaming ist ja so, mach Connection auf, gib mir Daten und...
Ja, naja, wenn du natürlich irgendwie, sag mal so, dieses billige, stream mir das mal direkt in meinen Player rein, von der und der Quelle, da hast du dann natürlich keinen Zugriff auf die schon weggestreamten Daten hast. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen klar, also da müsstest du dir, wenn, dann schon eine eigene Lösung bauen.
Ich bin mir jetzt grad nicht so sicher, ob es das Streaming oder das Downloading das Problem ist, was irgendwie nicht mit teilweise schon vorhandenen Daten arbeiten kann. Kann ja sein, dass wenn du selber das Streaming machst und du würdest die Daten wegschreiben, musst du eben immer noch diesen Download-Prozess der SOS sagen. Kann ich auch nicht sagen, aber irgendwie, das sind solche Sachen. Was ich auch noch mal ein bisschen getestet habe, was auch so ein bisschen haarig war, ist, wenn man mal einen Podcast privat machen will. Also wenn die Webseite quasi mit einem Passwort versehen ist, so Login-Passwort, Basic Authentication und so. Und die Downloads auch. Also manche Player haben so korrekten Support für der Feed ist hinter Authentication. Manche kommen dann aber nicht klar mit, wenn die Datei dann auch noch mal Authentication hat. Da funktionieren die Sachen gut, die das irgendwie immer weniger komplett im OS hinterlassen, wo dann irgendwie klar ist, hier für diese Domänen gibt es eine Authentication und die hat schon stattgefunden und wenn ich jetzt darüber auch noch was runter lade, klappt das irgendwie auch noch. Dann gibt es so Podcast-Apps, die dann tatsächlich das komplett in der Cloud lösen. Und das fand ich schon ein bisschen befremdlich, weil dann quasi nicht nur die Notifizierung, also das soll ja sozusagen, also diese Cloud ist ja dazu da.
Was meinst du mit in der Cloud, die laden das quasi von dem Ursprünglich-Server woanders hin?
Naja, so Pocket Casts macht das zum Beispiel. Die haben sozusagen eigene Server laufen und die protzen ja auch immer damit, dass sie irgendwie total schnell die Feeds checken, was daran liegt, dass sie die Feeds halt auf ihrem Server checken. Was soweit ganz okay ist, solange es sich dabei um Public Feeds handelt. Das heißt hier, Mobile-Macs neue Folge ist draußen, der Server kriegt das irgendwie mit und der Client kriegt mit, dass es da was Neues gibt, weil ihm sein Pocket Cast Server sagt, dass da was Neues ist. So, wenn du aber jetzt einen privaten Feed hast, der halt mit Username und Passwort versehen ist, ja, dann ist natürlich die Frage, wer checkt hier. Und es checkt in dem Fall halt auch der Pocket Cast Server und speichert halt das Passwort gleich mit.
Aber darf ich da jetzt mal heretisch sein und fragen, wenn ich den Feed privat mache, ist es dann noch Podcasting?
Ja, also ich bin auch gerade so ein bisschen irritiert. Was sind das denn für Podcasts, die mit Usernamen und Passwort stattfinden?
Firmeninterne Podcasts.
Naja, oder so Plus-Angebote.
Vielleicht auch, ja, aber mein Beispiel wäre jetzt Firmeninterne Podcasts. Podcasts, die einfach eine definierte Reichweite haben sollen und die einfach nicht für everybody sind.
Sowas gibt's?
Das kannst du wahrscheinlich dein E-Nur hinter der Firewall oder so runterladen.
Na ja, das ist jetzt noch nicht wie auf einem Enterprise-Level, sondern mehr so auf so einem experimentellen Level, so. Aber Podcasts sind ein totaler Segen für Kommunikation und das gilt auch für interne Unternehmenskommunikation.
Was hat uns das Führungsteam diese Woche zu sagen, in epischer Länge?
So wie...
Ja, nee, ist schon mehr so...
Nee, ist schon klar.
Sharing information, sharing ideas. Also, das kann man schon sehr kreativ nutzen. Und wenn du, was weiß ich, wenn du auch irgendwie ein irgendwie geartetes Projekt hast, bei dem mehrere Leute beteiligt sind, aber das, was da eben zu kommunizieren... Du machst ja auch deine Mailing-Listen nicht gleich automatisch public. Oder? Ich meine, auf wie vielen Mailing-Listen bist du, die nicht public sind?
Ja gut, aber so ein...
Da gibt es in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keinen Unterschied. Das möchtest du halt mit Podcasting auch haben können. Ja, und natürlich, wenn du auch solche Premium-Angebote machst, so mit hier, ich mach hier einen extrem aufwendigen Dienst so und willst dir das bezahlen lassen, warum nicht? Ich meine, ich mach sowas nicht, aber ich hab das nie ausgeschlossen, sowas auch mal zu machen, nur hab ich in dem Sinne keinen exklusiven Content. Also wenn man jetzt, weiß ich, in irgendeinem Feld arbeitet, wo man total was drauf hat, so und das ist für manche Leute einfach eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine wertvolle Information, die du da zu verbreiten in der Lage bist. Warum nicht sich dafür bezahlen lassen und warum nicht auch auf der Basis von so einer Bezahlung Subscription bezahlen lassen? Ist ja was anderes als das, was wir jetzt hier machen.
Also ich muss sagen, dieses Pocket-Cast-Problem, ich sehe zwar ein, dass das irgendwie ein Problem ist, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es halt deren Art, die Sache zu lösen.
Das geht nicht, dass sie Passwörter speichern auf irgendeinem anderen Server.
Nein, das geht natürlich nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Tun sie es denn? Also das ist natürlich...
Ich meine, das Argument was dann kommt ist natürlich so, wie sollen wir denn sonst meinem kleinen Bescheid sagen, dass was Neues da ist? Haben die ja früher auch gemacht so. Klar, wahrscheinlich haben die sich mittlerweile das komplette Feed-Parsing aus ihrem Klein draus operiert und sind sozusagen überhaupt nicht in der Lage, das mehr selber zu machen. Ich sag nur mal.
Hat natürlich auch so einen Vorteil, wenn man dieses extrem aufwändige XML-Parsing jetzt nicht auf dem Klein macht.
Ja, worauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus? Ich wollte auf diese ganze Download-Geschichte hinaus, wir kommen so ein bisschen vom Weg ab. Ich fiel mir nur gerade ein, dass das so ein Thema ist. Also wenn man sozusagen Apps baut und die haben was mit HTTP und Download zu tun, sollten jetzt irgendwelche Entwickler hellhörig sein, lohnt sich immer mal das Ganze mit Authentication zu checken, ob das irgendwie funktioniert und ob man das richtig macht. Und richtig machen heißt, wenn so eine Authentication erforderlich ist, da auch den entsprechenden Dialog anzuzeigen und wenn man so was eingegeben hat, das dann eben gegebenenfalls auch in der Keychain abzulegen. Damit es dann eben auch für Folgezugriffe, Downloads im Hintergrund und so weiter, wo man dann vielleicht gar keine Möglichkeit mehr hat, nochmal UI hochzuknallen, das dann eben auch im Zugriff hat.
Du hast vollkommen recht. Aber ich denke, das wird NSURL-Session sicherlich können. Weil diese ganzen Sachen machen sie ja jetzt schon. Also das soll, gut, vielleicht erzähle ich Unsinn, aber es sollte eigentlich gehen. Also es ist schon mächtig, das Framework an der Stelle.
Na ja, also Apple kann das auf jeden Fall, das ist mir schon klar. Na ja, haben wir noch was zu iOS nachzutragen?
Erstmal nichts übermäßig Wichtiges. Also ich habe mir einige Sachen aufgeschrieben, aber es ist jetzt eigentlich alles, wo nichts, wo ich sagen würde, das muss jetzt hier in epscher Breite ausgeführt werden.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen, die haben wir, glaube ich, in den beiden letzten Folgen überhaupt noch nicht angesprochen. Nämlich einerseits dieses iOS in the car.
Aber diesem Bikini-Höschen-Icon. Dieses Icon sieht doch so aus wie so ein Kreis, da ist so ein Bikini-Höschen eingespannt in diesem Kreis. Ach, das ist ein Lenkrad. Ach, ein Lenkrad ist das. Ich hatte so Strand-Assoziation. Guck dir das Icon nochmal an.
Ja, jetzt wo du es sagst, weiß ich was du meinst, aber ich hatte diese Assoziation so nicht so richtig.
apple.com/ios, iOS 7. Naja, nicht ganz, ich weiß, aber so als es da auftauchte.
Da gibt es so verschiedene Aspekte, die ich da ganz interessant finde. Also erstens, was heißt das genau in the car? Also meinen sie damit, dass da ein Gerät ist, was iOS macht oder ist es mehr so ein, das Auto hat da Display und kann jetzt AirPlay und du kannst es anschließen? Das sind die jüngste Revelations. Ich glaube auf Apple Insider stand da irgendwas, wo das in diesem SDK jetzt wohl tatsächlich so USB und WLAN die Optionen sind.
WLAN klingt dann wiederum nach AirPlay. Es gibt einen großen WWDC-Talk zum Thema Peripherals, der jetzt nicht auf iOS in the car gemünzt ist, aber da kommt auch USB und WLAN und so weiter zur Sprache. Unter anderem eben auch Bluetooth, wo sie halt auch solche Sachen wie Notifications über Bluetooth machen und so.
Ja gut, aber hier geht es ja richtig um die Übernahme des Bildschirms. Also die Beispiele, die sie hier gebracht haben, ist ja die komplette Navigation auf dem Screen, der da drin ist, quasi Fullscreen Display von iOS. Und das heißt ja wiederum auch, dass in dem Moment, wo du eine Anwendung machst, die K-tauglich ist, und Apple hat es ja hier mit ihrer Navigation gezeigt, dass sie auch jenseits der vorherrschenden Aspect-Rice-Rose klarkommen muss.
Sie haben ja bisher auch nur Beispiele gezeigt für, hier kommt ein Call rein, Musik-Player und ein Map, sieht man ja hier auch in den Screenshots. Also du kannst jetzt nicht Angry Birds auf deinem Auto spielen sozusagen, sondern das sind ja dann schon so Custom-Tailored Views.
Also interessant finde ich ja an diesem ganzen Display, erstens, dass die Status-Dinger unten sind, also links unten das LTE-Ding, rechts unten die Zeit und die Batterie. Und in der Mitte ist ein Home-Button, der ja scheinbar irgendwie ein Bedienelement ist.
Wo ist ein Home-Button? Auf dem Bildschirm.
Auf dem Bildschirm gibt es einen Home-Button. Also ich sag mal so, die Anzeige von der Batterie, die Anzeige von der Batterie spricht so ein bisschen dagegen, dass sie tatsächlich ein iOS-Gerät ins Car einbauen.
Es geht um dein iOS-Gerät.
Du meinst das iPhone macht AirPlay vom Bild zum Auto?
Genau. Wahrscheinlich über Dinge.
Das heißt, man braucht es nicht mal mehr aus der Tasche holen, sondern steigt ein und Kling!
Ja, aber es ist ja noch mehr als das, weil du koppelst. Also wenn du das über USB, also wenn du darüber telefonierst und das quasi in die Infrastruktur des Autos voll einbinden willst, dann musst du ja auch die im Auto eingebauten Mikrofone und Lautsprecher und so weiter benutzen für die Freisprecheinrichtungen. So etwas. Also die Integration geht jetzt weiter als nur der Bildschirm, aber sie umfasst. Halt auch den Bildschirm. Also solche Freisprecheintegrationen gibt es ja auch heute schon, einfach auf Basis von Audio in Out. Aber das geht dann eben darüber hinaus. Und alles eben wahrscheinlich über diesen Lightning-Kram.
Ja, das ist die Frage, wie es über Lightning geht. Wenn ich mir das angucke, dann ist ja das Batteriesymbol rechts unten, zeigt ja nicht an, dass es geladen wird. Also wenn ich das iPhone in den Lightning-Connector anschließe, dann würde ich ja davon ausgehen, dass das iPhone auch gleichzeitig geladen wird. Dann müsste er da unten anzeigen, dass es das täte. Das ist da aber nicht.
Ich würde ja sagen, das sind einfach noch hier irgendwelche Buzz-Bing-Mock-Ups und noch kein Live-Actionshots. Und wahrscheinlich in einem Jahr oder vielleicht auch weniger gibt es ja mal so ein YouTube-Video, wo einer mal zeigt, wie es wirklich aussieht.
Good point.
Also ich finde, das sieht auch irgendwie... Also ich meine, so viel haben sie ja jetzt nicht gezahlt. Also zu iOS 7 soll das ja schon da sein, aber wann haben sie gesagt, wird das also integriert bei den Herstellern? Ist doch alles so fabel, vielleicht demnächst mal.
Ja, das weiß ja, wie das ist mit so Auto-Herstellern. Das kann ja schon lange dauern.
Hier im Chat meint ja einer, man kann jetzt schon Custom Views auf dem Apple TV als Second Screen rausgeben. Also von...
Na ja, klar.
Von einem iOS-App oder was?
Ja, also du hast... Wenn du irgendeine Art von Bildschirm anschließt, egal ob jetzt Apple TV über AirPlay oder aber tatsächlich über Kabel, dann hast du ja einen zweiten Screen und auf dem kannst du irgendwas tun. Also es gibt ja so Spiele, die dann, weiß ich nicht, zeigen dir die Straße an, während du dann auf dem iPhone selber nur irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, irgendwelche Bedienelemente hast und dann längst du damit oder so. Also das gibt es ja schon relativ lange.
Ja, ich würde da mal, also, weil ich da nicht schon für Integrationsnachrichten gehört habe in der Hinsicht, ich warte mal noch ab.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite, wenn Apple das jetzt ankündigt und sagt, sie wollen das machen und sie wollen das richtig machen, dann besteht natürlich die Hoffnung, dass es dann tatsächlich auch mal richtig passiert. Und es sieht ja, also zumindest alles, was man da sieht in den Mock-ups, das sieht ja danach aus, als wäre das ein Touchscreen.
Ja, den Eindruck habe ich auch.
Also es geht davon aus, dass es einer ist. Ja, das bedeutet, dass da eben auch ein Protokoll gefahren wird, was eben auch diese Touch-Information wieder zurückbringen kann. Das gegebenenfalls halt vielleicht auch über WLAN. Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen wie jetzt schon mit AirPlay, wo du ja auch zum Beispiel die Fernbedienung des Apple TV ja auch wieder Rückwirkungen hat auf dein sendendes Gerät. Also wenn du deinen Film abspielst, dann kannst du auf deinem iPhone Pause drücken, aber du kannst auch die Pause-Taste des Apple TV drücken und das meldet das über diese Verbindung ja wieder als Control-Information zurück. Genauso wäre das dann hier wahrscheinlich auch.
AirPlay mit Touch, Event, Rückkanal, ja warum nicht?
Ja, na gut, das war das eine, worüber wir nicht gesprochen haben. Das ist jetzt vorbei. Jetzt haben wir darüber gesprochen. Und das andere, was wir so ein bisschen ausgelassen haben, komischerweise haben wir immer danach darüber gesprochen, ist die Tatsache, dass es jetzt auch Facetime-Audio gibt.
Ja, habe ich schon getestet, funktioniert.
Und was denkst du, wie das so...
Bei dem Telkurs ankommt gar nicht gut.
Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass es auch wieder nur komischerweise erstmal per W-Lan geht.
Komischerweise.
Ach jetzt, wo das richtige Facetime mit Video geht, auch über 3G, aber das mit... das normale, nur was?
Stand irgendwo. Ich hab's nicht geprüft bisher, aber...
Können wir das jetzt hier prüfen, oder was?
Ja, müssen wir beide mal kurz aus dem W-Lan raus. Und es ist nicht so, dass wenn man einen anruft, dass er dann automatisch Facetime Audien, wie du mal schon irgendwann meintest, aber wenn man zum Beispiel in den Contacts ist, in den Messages ist, und dann oben auf Kontakt, auf Info klickt, dann kommt ja ein Telefonzeichen und irgendwie noch andere Zeichen, wenn man aufs Telefon klickt, dann kommt auch wieder so ein Sheet hochgeslided, wo man halt sagen kann, Voice normal oder halt Facetime Audio, muss man sich dann sozusagen ausdenken.
Also hier, ich kann jetzt hier bei Facetime, bei Dennis Ahrens, kann ich auf dem Hörer einfach nur klicken.
Moment, ich muss erstmal jetzt hier so ausmachen. Hab ich jetzt gemacht?
So, ich klick jetzt hier bei Dennis...
Bei Facetime auf den Hörer.
Ihr seid jetzt beide im 3G?
Ja, ich bin auf zwei Balken LTE.
Ich hab einen Balken. Na doch, geht aber. Okay, war also Fake-Information.
Dann geh mal ran.
Hier, sag mal, Tuke. Kommt das hier rüber? Nee, ne? Kommt nicht an. Kommt nicht an. Ich mach mal Speaker. Ja, du aber hier. Warum hört man dich nicht? Ach, hier oben. Aber so richtig lange, oder?
Aber richtig lange.
Ja, ich hab auch nur zwei Balken LTE.
Ja, Tim hat keinen Empfang hier.
Ja, also Facetime Audio geht über Edge sogar jetzt in dem Fall. Hat da problemlos von LTE auf Edge sogar downgecycelt.
Nicht schlecht.
Aber das war ja noch schlimmer als Satellitenradio, Fernsehen, weiß schon. Okay, aber geht auf jeden Fall. Ja, aber sonst gibt's da eigentlich nicht so viel zu berichten. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Codex sie benutzen, aber denk mal, was richtig toll ist. Wahrscheinlich Apple nimmt kein Opus, sondern diesen AAC Low Latency.
Low Delay.
Irgendwie sowas, die haben ja da auch so was am Start.
Low Delay klang das jetzt zwar nicht, aber ja.
Na gut, der Codex kann's ja machen, die Leitung kann er ja nicht beeinflussen.
Der Opus ist ja nicht GNU, oder? Der ist doch was Freieres. Ohne jetzt diese Diskussion anzufangen. Aber der ist keine GNU-Lizenz, ne Opus?
Der Opus ist glaube ich richtig lizenziert.
Irgendwie sowas BSD-mäßiges? Also, keine Ahnung, muss man sich mal durch die Sachen durchklicken, vielleicht benutzen, das ist tatsächlich im Hintergrund. Und es ist nur in irgendeinem ReadMe ist plötzlich dann, und außerdem danken wir noch der Verwendung.
3-Clause BSD-License. Wie sich das gehört.
2-Clause. Ich sage 2-Clause.
Ja, wir sagen auch das. Aber ich meine, ob das nun 2 oder 3 ist, mir ehrlich gesagt an der Stelle ziemlich egal. Hauptsache BSD. Falls das übrigens noch jemand nicht mitbekommen hat, und ihr sucht nach der richtigen Lizenz für die Open Source Software, BSD.
Oder MIC, aber die ist ja auch BSD.
Ja, alles was so BSD ist.
Welche Lizenz hat es denn? Nee, welche? Na mit Lizenz.
Soviel zum religiösen Teil dieser Sendung.
Stimmt.
Aber wenigstens sind wir uns einig.
Ich musste ja heute den ganzen Tag Linux administrieren. Na ja.
Wart wirklich? Aber zahlt.
Aber es ist schon, diese scheiß Fruchtfliegen. Tim, du musst ja mal deinen Müll rausblicken.
Ja, ihr müsst ja mal eure Bierflaschen besser auswaschen, wenn ihr hier irgendwie geht.
Mal schön ausdrinken.
Und dann sieht es hier aus wie ein Knifer nach dem Drei.
Kennt ihr, die Frucht fliegen schon aufs Bier?
Na, was sollten die sonst gehen hier?
Na, die Bananenschalen, die hier oben liegen.
Pizza, Schokolade. Stimmt, Früchte sind hier nicht.
Die Bananenschalen haben die Ratten in 5 Minuten weggefressen. Wollen wir noch ein bisschen auf die anderen hauen?
Erstmal Kulturprogramm. Ich hab ja heute den Trailer zu diesem Jobs-Film gesehen. Boah, ich...
War der gut.
Man, ey, dieser Essten... Ja, wie auch immer, aber dieser Film, den kann ich mir nicht angucken, glaube ich. Da hab ich mich beim Trailer schon fremdgeschämt irgendwie. Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen.
Auf den Schirm!
Das ist halt so...
Ist der bei apple.com? Ja, bei IMDB auf jeden Fall ist er.
Das fände ich ja mal interessant, ob er da ist oder ob die den endorsen oder nicht.
Ich tippe nein.
Wie heißt der? Einfach nur Jobs?
Einfach nur Jobs mit kleinem J und großem OBS. Gehen wir auf IMDB, da gibt es den Trailer. Ah, nee, die ganze Sprechweise, diese ganze Dialogführung, das ist so an der Grenze zum Klamauk-Film. Hat das schon irgendwie...
Ich bin ja gespannt über den anderen Film, ob der besser wird.
Ja, das ist hier fullscreen enough. Über zwei Minuten, aber wenn es schlecht ist, machen wir Schluss, oder?
Mal sehen, ob ihr das auch so schlimm findet wie ich.
Hochschule kommt an den teuren Erfahrungen. Das Computer-Terminal, das auf die Fernseh-TV aufhängt?
Nobody's making anything like this.
Trust me, I'm an I-N-T-E-P-E-N-D-E-N-T-L-P.
Naja, sieht eben aber ganz schön ähnlich.
Aber jetzt warte mal bis zum Schluss noch. Er bringt's einfach nicht rüber, finde ich.
Hollywoodish.
Ach, really?
Ein Hollywoodfilm bis Hollywoodish.
Ja, aber so richtig schlimm fände ich irgendwie so. Also ich mein, wir haben den ja alle noch reden hören und so weiter und der...
Na ja, also ehrlich gesagt, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt hier total begeistert bin gerade von irgendwas, aber...
Oh, klickt mal den Lovelace Trailer.
Ich find mich jetzt auch noch nicht gnadenlos. Ich meine, ich find das ist viel zu früh.
Definitiv.
Ich meine, der Typ ist grad mal...
Nicht mal zwei Jahre tot.
Ja, vor allem der erzeugt noch wahrscheinlich noch auf mehrere Jahre Energie am Apple Campus.
Ja, aber guck mal, der andere Film von diesem Social Network, wie heißt der? Der auch auf Seven, glaube ich, gemacht hat. Oder das Drehbuch zumindest. Der besteht aus drei Szenen wohl. Der andere Steve-Film, es gibt zwei.
Ach, du meinst ja diesen mit I'm a Mac, den Vögel?
What?
Justin Long?
Den Justin-Long-Film, diesen schnell mal hingerotzten?
Nee, den gibt's ja noch nicht. Doch. Ich meine, der kommt erst noch.
Ach so, noch einer.
Der richtige Steve-Film. Ja, das ist ja hier nur der Abschauer-Film, das machen die ja oft in Hollywood.
Wie das ist der Abschauer-Film?
Na guck mal, es gab ja auch, wenn du dich erinnern kannst, The Prestige, und kurz vorher gab es noch einen, der sich in diese, wir machen den Film mit einem Zauberer, sich so schnell noch in diesen Hype reinschmuggelt und da hieß er Illusionist. Und das sind immer so diese Geschichten, auch genauso mit irgendwelchen Monstertypen. Da kommt halt der, weiß nicht, wieder so ein Vampir-Film und kurz vorher kommt noch so ein El Chippo-Vampir-Film, die wollen auf der Welle mitschwimmen. Oder bei Finding Nemo kam da nicht auch so ein anderer Fisch-Film?
Nee, das war das mit den Ameisen.
Genau, Bugs Live und Ends. Das ist immer genau so. Und das ist halt hier die Billig-Version. Und die andere Version ist von dem Typen, der, ich glaube, das Drehbuch geschrieben hat, wie heißt das? Das Social Network hat er gemacht. David Fincher, ist das von dem? Wie hieß der denn dann?
Ich hab da noch gar nichts von gehört, das ist noch ein anderer.
Aaron Sorkin, genau, Dankeschön. Ich bringe mal so ein paar Sachen durcheinander. Aber dafür haben wir den Chat, der korrigiert mich.
Aber da ist gar kein Film von ihm angekündigt für den.
Doch, hat er doch schon groß darüber erzählt und so und es soll ein Stiefel sein und er steht aus drei Szenen und zwar die Geburt des Mac, die Geburt des Tralala und die Geburt des Tralala.
Aber guck mal, hier steht nirgends was von irgendeinem Stiefel.
Alter, Jungs, erzählt mir doch jetzt nichts hier, das kann ja nicht sein.
Und wenn es jemand weiß, dann die E-I-D.
Aaron, sorge nur, der dritte Vorschlag bei Google ist die Jobs, also er erzählt mir noch nichts hier. So Jobs Biotopic to Playout in 3 Scenes hier.
Aber dann hat er damit noch nicht angefangen.
Ja, aber das ist, da wo das dicke Geld fließt, der kommt schon noch irgendwann, der Film.
Also die ersten Kulturen, das ist so, da denkt man erst, ja whatever, da denkt man erst mal gleich so an The 70s Show so und dann sind da irgendwelche so eine blöde Witze irgendwie mit drin.
Mann, das ist ein Trailer.
Aber Steve.
Ist ja fast noch religiös. Du musst deinen Mikrofon schon nochmal so 2 cm, weil das ist außerhalb des Wirkungsbereichs.
Test 1, 2, 3, Sprechprobe. Der Steve, der, wie gesagt, wir haben ja das Bild alle noch vor Augen. Wir haben ihn alle sprechen hören. Wir haben irgendwie alle gesehen, wie er seinen Reality-Distortion-Field aufbaut. Und wenn ich den da angucke, dann denke ich mir, was ist denn das für eine Napfselsel?
Na, wie willst du denn das machen? Ich meine, welcher Schauspieler soll sich da hinsetzen?
Also selbst bei diesem Film Pirates of the Silicon Valley, dieser TV-Typ, der hat das sogar besser hinbekommen als Ashton.
Wir fassen zusammen, Huckel ist dagegen.
Huckel trotzdem?
Ne, also ich mein, also den...
Apple-Fan-Boycott.
Ja, ne, ich weiß nicht, glaub ich, den Film, den spar ich mir echt. Also es sei denn, irgendwann seh ich dann auf IMDb, also er hat irgendwie 8,0 Wertungen oder zumindest 7,5 oder sowas, aber...
Dass sie sich überhaupt an sowas ran trauen. Also das finde ich eigentlich... Also ich würde, wäre ich jetzt Filmemacher und ich würde auch nur im Entferntesten auf die Idee kommen, Steve Jobs zu verfilmen. Das würde für mich bedeuten, als würde mir bei den Dreharbeiten Stanley Kubrick die ganze Zeit zuschauen. Weißt du, also einen Film über jemanden zu machen, der sozusagen das Maximum an Qualitätsgefühl immer durchgesetzt hat oder gehabt hat. Weißt du, was ich meine? Also dieser hohe Anspruch an alles und so weiter. Und dann wachst du es irgendwie so ein halbgares Teil da abzuliefern, was einfach mal, keine Ahnung, wie so eine Android-App da hochkommt.
Vorsicht, nicht über Farben sprechen. Ja, aber Hollywood ist zu 90% Geschäfte-Macherei. Hier geht es nicht um Qualität.
Ich sag ja nur, wenn ich Filmemacher wäre, nicht Hollywood-Mister oder so.
Du, das ist halt die Michael-Dell-Version des Films. Wir warten jetzt noch auf die Steve-Jobs-Version des Films. Dann wird vielleicht alles besser.
Wer macht denn diesen Jobs-Film überhaupt? Welcher Typ macht das? Der kommt gleich auf meine IMDb-Blacklist. Joshua Michael Stern und Matt Roll. Ich guck gerade mal.
Underworld 14.
Ja, irgendwelche B-Movies mit Kevin Costner auch, zumindest, aber irgendwelche Never-Heard-Before-Movies.
Lass noch mal hören.
Swing Boat, Never Wars, The Contractor, Emmityville. Und der Writer hat nix vorher gemacht. Na ja, seht selbst, seht nur, was ihr davon habt. Chat verbrühtern sich schon alle und sagen, wir gucken den auf jeden Fall.
Dieses Freenote ist irgendwie kaputt.
Mögen euch die Augen bluten? Nein.
Ich glaube, da hätten wir uns auch was Schöneres einfallen lassen können.
Ich hätte ja lieber einen Film so mit, der von Stop seine besten Pieces, die Kino-Länge, die besten Keynotes, die besten... Diese iPod-Präsentation, diese erste WBDC-Appearance.
Ich würde sagen, ich hätte gerne eine extra long-running Version von dieser Keynote, live, iPhoto und iLive.
In epischer Länge ist es nicht irgendwie mit seinen Halbfotos auseinandergesetzt. Das wär's doch. Eine lange Nacht machst du da nicht raus.
Die lange Nacht der iLive-Templates.
Wo dann irgendwann frustriert die Kamera ins Publikum wirft, weil die einfach nicht angehen will und keine Fotos importieren. Und das Gleiche passiert ihm doch nochmal bei diesem komischen, furchtbaren, Motorola iTunes Handy. Und dazwischen bitteschön noch die Szene, wo Windows 98 in der Präsentation abschmiert. Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab versucht, mich da schlau zu machen, aber die Informationslage ist so schlecht, dass ich mir eigentlich nicht zutraue, da irgendwie was zu sagen. Außer, dass diese Firma da irgendwas mit dem Codesigning gefunden hat und irgendwas auf, ich glaube, der Black Cat-Konferenz vorstellen will. Aber vorher haben sie sich nicht in die Karten...
Du meinst da, wo es jetzt auch für die Samsung schon einen Patch gibt? Dieser aktuelle Bug halt gerade.
Ja, genau, dieser aktuelle Bug.
Na, irgendwo hab ich eine Beschreibung gelesen, da ich das vorher überhaupt gar nicht kannte, konnte ich mir die Puzzleteilchen nicht so ganz zusammensetzen, aber die arbeiten da irgendwie so mit zwei Dateien, also schummeln da so eine unter und das OS nimmt dann am falschen Moment die falsche Datei und deswegen kann man sich da seine Hashes irgendwie mit reinschmuggeln oder sowas.
Also das Ding ist wohl, dass du dir als App dann beliebige Zugriffsrechte sichern kannst. Also das Zugriffsmodell von Android ist ja irgendwie so, dass du signiert Zugriffsrechte hast auf bestimmte Systemdienste und mit dieser Signatur gehst du da irgendwie in den Google Play Store und der Kunde guckt halt einmal, wenn er die App klickt, sind das die Rechte, die ich der App zubilligen will oder nicht? Und wenn du der Meinung bist, ja, das ist okay, dann kannst du sie halt installieren und hast der App die entsprechenden Rechte gegeben. Ein Freund von mir brachte den Killer einwand und sagte, naja, aber bisher jede App, die ich dort gesehen hab, nimmt sich sowieso alle Rechte. Insofern, hm.
Und das ist auch nur bei Programmen, die du gerade installierst, also das ist nichts mit nachträglich ausbrechen oder es wird nichts gebrochen, was noch nicht da ist, sondern du musst diesen Schrott dafür auch überhaupt erst mal installieren, damit du ihn kriegst. Also das ist alles gar nicht so schlimm. Und die Samsung-Jungs haben schon Patch bekommen. Google hat schon Patch bereitgestellt, der ist natürlich bei den ganzen USen aber noch nicht angekommen. Und die Cyanogenmod-Leute haben ihren Patch schon selber nachgecodet, oder wie auch immer, und da ist schon drin.
Also es ist wohl sehr, sehr weit zurück die Version betroffen.
Muss ich jetzt irgendwas tun um dieses Nexus 7 vor dem Explodieren?
Einfach nichts installieren.
Einfach nichts installieren, das ist ja nicht so schwierig.
Ansonsten, keine Ahnung, ob du davon irgendjemanden, irgendwie ein Update für irgendwas kriegst. Also es schlug irgendwie große Wellen, aber...
Diese Black Cat ist erst noch.
Die Wellen sind auch schon wieder geglättet, habe ich das Gefühl.
Aber die Konferenz ist erst noch. Oder war die schon?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe mir das vor ein paar Tagen angeguckt und keine Ahnung. Irgendwie war das auch gleich wieder raus aus den News, vielleicht war es doch nicht so spannend.
Oder vielleicht...
Das ist jetzt gemein, wenn ich das sage, aber vielleicht wundert sich bei Android auch keiner drüber.
Also 27. Juli bis 1. August.
Also ist noch eine Weile hin.
Wo wir gerade so bei Sicherheit sind, das ist ja auch ein die Sicherheit sind. In Zeiten von... Prism und Temporar und... Ich glaube es gibt eigentlich auch einen Namen für dieses französische Projekt.
Ich habe es nicht verfolgt.
Nicht zu sehr in Stereotypen, aber wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwas mit...
Visite ma tante.
Keine physimatenten hier.
Ja, wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall, allgemein wird thematisiert, dass wir ja alle überwacht werden. Aber ich habe irgendwie immer noch so den Eindruck, es beregt sich kein nennenswerter Widerstand, was entweder dann, oder es ist ein bisschen daran liegt, was viele Leute vermuten, das ist kein Interesse.
Ich überlege schon, ob ich jetzt doch die Cloud benutze, weil sie meine Daten ja eh abschnorcheln. Dann kann ich auch deren Speicher wenigstens davon nehmen. Das ist die Vollaufgabe sozusagen.
Kann ich jetzt nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Darauf wollte ich jetzt auch nicht hinaus, was man jetzt da irgendwie tun oder nicht tun soll. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt jetzt das Thema. Aber was ich merke, ist, dass es auf einmal so eine Diskussion über so eine neue Diskussion über Verschlüsselung gibt. Zwar so im Allgemeinen. Da gibt es ja nur so diese Fraktion, die dann immer gleich anfängt irgendwelche Krypto-Partys zu schmeißen und dann so ja, wir müssen jetzt alle verschlüsseln. Und wir müssen jetzt alle PGP benutzen. Wo ich dann nur sagen kann ja, und wie soll man das machen auf dem iPhone so? Oder? Also ich meine, gibt es eigentlich irgendeine Mail-Up, die PGP drin hat?
Du meinst, ich könnte reich werden?
Also sagen wir mal so, es hat ja eine Weile gedauert, bis Apple überhaupt Mail-Ups zugelassen hat. Aber inzwischen gibt es sie. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist auch eine mit PGP eingebaut dabei. Würde mich ja nicht wundern.
Von PGP selbst.
Na ja, also PGP will sich einfach auch im Jahre 30 irgendwie nicht so richtig durchsetzen.
Preisig?
Ah, es gibt Secure Mail, Good Pub, ah ne, das ist kein, aber es gibt Secure Mail, Business, für nur 44 Euro im App Store.
Wenn es zu deiner Sicherheit wert ist.
Boah, sieht das scheiße aus.
Na ja, ich denke ja eh, dass es eigentlich ein bisschen automatisierter gehen müsste und dass alles irgendwie an den eigenen Accounten, mehr oder weniger, automatisch und damit auch an die Domänen gebunden sein müsste und das macht ja eigentlich S-Mime. Nur das Problem mit S-Mime ist halt, du brauchst dann eben wieder ein Zertifikat, was dir von irgendjemand ausgestellt werden muss. Was ein bisschen albern ist, wenn man sozusagen Herr seiner eigenen Domänen ist, ist das ja irgendwie alles gar gar. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht in so eine lange DNS-Seg-Diskussion reingehen, sondern was eigentlich ja gerade wild diskutiert wird, sind eben diese ganzen verkrüpteten Messenger. So, ich meine, wir hatten ja hier schon mal dieses Rima besprochen, das ist ja irgendwie eigentlich ganz nett gemacht.
Das ist eigentlich schon ziemlich cool.
Macht den Eindruck, als ob das da auch so, sagen wir mal, mit dem Key-Austausch und der Versicherung, dass man jetzt wirklich mit der richtigen Person redet, schon mal ganz gut macht?
Die Frage ist nur, wenn die sich sowieso per Bektor auf mein Telefon einhacken können, was nützt man dann so was noch?
Wer kann sich per Bektor auf dein Telefon einhacken?
Na du meinst doch nicht, dass die NSA sich gerade darauf verlässt, dass wir alle keine Krypto benutzen und die dann so locker auf Glasfaserebene da abschnorcheln können, sondern wenn es denen drauf ankommt, dann können die sich da auch auf mein Telefon einloggen. Da kannst du ja mal von ausgehen. Dann sitzt auch bei Apple da irgendein Mitarbeiter, der sich dafür kümmert, dass das möglich ist. Na was denkst du denn? Du bist die NSA, du willst die ganze Welt abschnorcheln. Da ist eine riesen Firma, die wieviel Hunderte von Millionen von Devices verkauft, wo nur so eine ganz kleine Backdoor rein muss. Das heißt, du brauchst da irgendwo nur so eine ganz kleine Ecke haben, wo du dann da reinkommen kannst, die auch niemand kennt, außer die NSA. Und du meinst ja, das haben die nicht gemacht. Ich meine, selbst bei Windows ist dieser Scheiß drin. Da gab's doch, die haben noch diesen NSA-Schlüssel in Windows da irgendwie entdeckt. Oder zwei sind's sogar, zwei NSA-Schlüssel. Wann? Muss ich mir mal die Quellen merken, das ist schlimm.
Na ja, da hab ich nichts von gehört.
Ich schon, gabst du ne Artikel. Hast du auch gelesen? Ach, mir nicht?
Nein, wir hätten nur gerne gewusst, wie lange ich das eigentlich schon hätte wissen müssen. Also ob das hier eine Information der letzten Wochen, Monate, Jahre oder Jahrzehnte ist.
Ich glaub, der Schlüssel, also die Story war irgendwie frisch, aber der Schlüssel ist wohl schon, haben sie dann zurückgehend geforscht, schon ganz schön lange drin. Der gleiche. Ja, aber die Story, dass das so gefunden wurde, die wurde vor ein paar Jahren gefunden, hat keiner zugehört, jetzt wurde er nochmal gesucht, jetzt wurde nochmal gesucht, jetzt nochmal ein anderer entdeckt und jetzt bei der aktuellen Nachrichtenlage wurde halt eine große Story draus gemacht.
Also mir hat jemand mir hat jemand eine Message auf app.net geschrieben, wo er fragt, was machen eigentlich RUT-Zertifikate der US-Regierung in iOS?
Also 1999 gab es schon eine Meldung dazu.
Dieses Unterstrich NSA-Key.
Sehr klug, so was so zu nennen, oder?
Ich meine, wenn es... Next Step...
Wenn es ein NSA-Key ist, dann ist es schon ein Fehler, das so zu nennen, aber es ist besonders ein Fehler, wenn es keiner ist.
Der NS- Asymmetrie-Key. Next Step.
Was ich damit sagen würde, die haben auf jeden Fall Möglichkeiten, auch wenn sie nicht per Glasfaser alles mitlesen. Also so ein richtiger ist ja angeblich deren Ziel. Irgendwie so einen Terroristen zu fangen. Oder vielleicht ist es ja auch der dicke Wirtschaftsboss, wo sie mal irgendwie was wissen müssen, wie viel sie zu bieten haben, damit sie mehr bieten als die anderen, aber weniger als sie sollten oder könnten. Und dann wollen die doch auch auf so ein Device raufgehen direkt. Sie brauchen ja nichts weiter machen, was kommt da schon so großartig an? Also das Wichtigste, was ich hier an meinem iPhone mache, sind ja eigentlich meine Keytaps. Also Keytaps, die ich hier so mache. Und dann vielleicht noch das, was mir die Gegenseite dann rüber schiebt, wenn sie den nicht sowieso auch mit schnorcheln und dessen Keytaps auch so kriegen. Dann haben sie doch schon alles, was ich schreibe, und dann haben sie das auch schon.
Also hier heißt es ja gleich im ersten Satz, dass das ein variablen Name war, den sie in Windows NT gefunden haben, weil das aus Versehen mit Debugging-Symbolen ausgeliefert wurde. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob aus Versehen, aber hier steht, has been released unstripped of its symbolic debugging data. Also das ist nicht so, dass da jemand jetzt irgendwie user-sichtbaren Content als NSA-Key bezeichnet hat, sondern es ist halt ein Variablename gewesen.
Ja, ja, das hab ich schon verstanden. Das ist trotzdem ein Fehler.
Das ist schon im Source Code die Variable.
Also ob das auch stimmt oder nicht, ist eigentlich total egal. Ich würde jetzt bei aktueller Lage davon ausgehen, dass die NSA, zumindest bei den großen amerikanischen Firmen, dass sie da ihren Fuß in der Tür haben.
Und du meinst, die sind auch in meinem iPhone.
Wenn sie wollen.
Und den iPhone deiner Kinder.
Ja, die kennen die Podcasts, die jetzt normalerweise hinter dem Passwort verborgen sind, auch von dir.
Und ich glaube auch, dass es denen ja gar nicht so um Terroristen geht, weil damit kann man ja kein Geld verdienen, weil die wollen ja auch Geld verdienen, sondern es geht auch im Großen und Ganzen um Wirtschaftsspionage.
Das wäre doch ein super Grund, wenn man dieses Mal sein kaputtes iPhone, so Apple, trägt und die sich dann irgendwie beschweren, dass ja diese ganzen Wassersensoren da losgegangen sind.
Wie waren die? Die wären rot oder weiß oder was? Na, sag einfach, das musstest du machen, weil die NSA wäre in dem Telefon drin gewesen und...
Du hast sie ersäufen.
Genau, einfach rausgespült.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du damit weit kommst.
Du hast genau gesehen, wie die Ratten das sinkende Schiff verlassen.
Kommen so kleine Männchen unter Wasser raus.
Da waren so Schlieren.
Egal, was ich damit sagen will, ist, wenn ich meinem Gerät sozusagen in dieser Hinsicht nicht vertrauen kann, dann nützt mir auch die tolle Streamer End-to-End Krypto nichts.
Du meinst, das ist alles vorbei?
Naja, ich meine, die Krypto-Chain ist halt so stark wie ihr schwächstes Glied. Und letzten Endes kannst du dann natürlich auch einem iOS nicht vertrauen.
So sieht es aus, das war mein Punkt.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Und wer mir jetzt ankommt, ich soll Linux benutzen, ja, der soll mir bitte die tausend Jahre Zeit mitgeben, die ich jede einzelne Source Code-Zeile lesen kann, weil auch da gab es schon den Fall, dass bei OpenBSD oder NetBSD oder irgendeinem BSD, FreeBSD war es glaube ich nicht, ich glaube OpenBSD sogar, dass sie da irgendwelche FBI-Agenten oder was auch immer mit am IPSec-Code geschrieben haben, weil sie da irgendwie für so ein paar Monate Time-Frame, Window-Zeit, weiß schon, war da irgendwie auch ein Backdoor oder ein Loch oder was auch immer drin. Also die Jungs wissen schon, wie die das machen. Und das sind nur die Fälle, die wir kennen. Die Spitze des Eisberges, sagt man. Also, können wir nicht erzählen, dass nicht bei den Jungs auch irgendwo was drin ist. Hier ist übrigens lecker Schokolade, und ich mach nochmal Werbung. Weißt du, kroatische Schokolade jetzt?
So kleine Bärchen, wie sie heißen, stehen nicht drauf.
Kleine Pero-Bärchen.
Die sind auf jeden Fall Roskompliant.
Steht auf der Tüte. Und schmatzen sehr gut, ja.
Jetzt muss ich schweizen.
Also ich hol mir jetzt noch ein Bier.
Ich ess jetzt auf jeden Fall keine mehr.
Und noch mit deinem O-Saft. Also ich würde weiterhin dieses Remind fehlen, weil es ganz gut ist. Man, Wucki.
Er geht jetzt echt so gerade ein bisschen auf den Zünder. Das hab ich gerade vorher gegessen.
Jetzt geht's los.
Komm, jedenfalls die Tür, Dennis hier. Ich hab die Schnauze voll von dem Geschmack und dem Geweder die ganze Zeit. Boarfter Milch hier noch mit Wattebeusche.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall scheint es gerade total abzugehen in diesem Kryptobereich. Also außer das Rima gibt es jetzt irgendwie noch einen weiteren Kandidaten hier, deine alte Ex-Firma, weiß nicht, ob du dir das schon mal angeschaut hast, du wirktest etwas überrascht vorhin, aber XO, Entschuldigung, nicht XS, XLO.
Aber auch mit dieser Endung ist es mir nicht...
Also wer Hocker nicht kennt, vielleicht Huckel wäre dein Part, das mal ordentlich zu erklären kurz.
Kurz abbriss, zwei Telefone wollen Daten austauschen oder Computer und Phone will Daten austauschen ohne Setup und das geht so wie mit Bump quasi mit rüber swipen einfach zwischen den zwei Geräten. Geo und Zeitkoordinaten sind dafür die entscheidenden Faktoren. Funktioniert ziemlich gut, da kann man auf wall.hocker.com zum Beispiel auf seinem Browser eine Webseite aufmachen, die Hocker-App dazu und dann kann man das so rausschleudern den Content und er landet dann einfach ohne großen Setup auf dem Rechner. Kann man auch verschlüsseln, kann man auch sagen, an welche Geräte da was geschickt werden soll und so. Also man kann es auch ganz gut steuern, wenn man dann doch will. Ja, gibt es schon eine ganze Weile.
Das ist jetzt aber anscheinend eine komplett neue Version, oder?
Nein, das ist eine andere App.
Und was ich an der Stelle sagen muss, sie haben jetzt wirklich in der neuesten Version mega hässliche Icons geschafft zu produzieren. Also da ist mir fast die Retina explodiert. Implodiert, als ich das gesehen hab. Also wer da gerade zuhört, kauft euch mal bitte da nochmal zwei Stunden von eurem Designer, damit das nochmal ordentlich wird. Aber abgesehen davon habe ich mich mit Hocker XO noch gar nicht befasst. Und Lauscha, jetzt ist gespannt dein Wort.
Ich hab da auch ehrlich gesagt nicht sehr viel mehr zu sagen, als dass es gibt. Aber ich hab einfach mal nur die Contender da zusammentragen wollen. Vielleicht gibt es ja sogar noch weitere, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Das Ganze war jetzt auch ein bisschen davon ausgelöst worden, dass es auch noch ein Announcement gab für eine kommende, die auf den schönen Namen Hemmlis, ist das richtig? Hemmlis, ne? Ja, ich glaube Hemmlis. Hemmlis lauscht. Oh, hatte ich hier auch mal die Seite offen. Das war halt irgendwie so ein bisschen, hab ich recht?
Hemmlis?
Genau, Hemmlis. Und das Bemerkenswerte an Hemmlis ist erstmal das, dass es sich hierbei um ein Projekt von, naja, also nicht der Flatter-Crew, aber sozusagen nahezu identischen Leuten handelt, also sozusagen so diese ganze Flatter-Führungsebene. Ich spiele das Video hier nochmal kurz für euch, irgendwie ab ohne Ton so, weil das ist jetzt hier so ein wesentlicher Blabla, also Peter Sunde und Linus und der Live, also sozusagen so die Chef-Etage von Flatter wirft sich da ins Programm und macht so ein bisschen mit dem Prism-Fear-Mongering jetzt hier die Ankündigung für ihr Produkt. Das ist aber noch in der Entwicklung, ist also noch gar nicht da und ich weiß noch gar nicht, was dabei rauskommt. Im Netz habe ich nur gesehen, wie sich einige gegenseitig da gleich die Körper eingetreten haben mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen darüber, was denn nun von Peter Sunde und der ganzen Piratenzumpf was von denen denn zu halten sei. Für mich nicht ganz so nachvollziehbare Argumentationen. Ich meine, solange das Ding nicht auf dem Tisch liegt, kann man da jetzt gar nichts zu sagen. Deshalb sind sie da ohnehin gerade noch in so einem Crowdfunding-Prozess.
Sie sind schon mal 80 Prozent mit 80.000?
Ja, also da scheint schon einiges zusammenzukommen, was mich jetzt auch nicht besonders überrascht.
Und es scheint eine iOS 7 App zu sein. Zumindest sind die Screenshots so zusammengeschoppt.
Und sie haben erst vor einem Tag und sechs Stunden angefangen? Steht da unten?
Ja. Na ja, wie gesagt, gestern ist das irgendwie rausgeschossen und als Holgi das irgendwie gepostet hatte, da war es noch bei, ich glaube, bei 800 Dollar oder so. Und dann stand da irgendwie 0,89% gefundet. Und ich dachte mir so, das ist jetzt mal nicht so viel.
Ja, aber da hat es gerade erst angefallen wahrscheinlich.
Aber ja, ein Tag sechs Stunden, na ja.
Kannst du mit PayPal oder Bitcoin bezahlen? Ich frage mich, wie viel Prozent davon mit Bitcoin zusammengekommen sind. Ja, mal schauen. Ich habe da noch keine dedizierte Meinung dazu. Auf der anderen Seite sind diese ganzen Geräte-only-Messaging-Services für mich auch immer so ein bisschen, weil wenn das irgendwie nicht auch auf meinem Mac läuft, dann ist irgendwie auch braun.
Wie nutzt du das iMessages auf dem Mac?
Es gab dann übrigens auch noch so einen völlig krassen Artikel. Mani hat mir auch noch zugeschoben so einen völlig absurden Artikel über dieses Projekt hier Hemmles, wo einer so voll seinen ganzen Hass irgendwie ausgespült hat. Das fand ich wirklich absurd. Da irgendwie tonnenweise irgendwelche Chatprotokolle auf Twitter oder ab.net Twitter wahrscheinlich gepostet hat, wo sie sich dann hier mit dieser Hemmles-Crew auseinander gesetzt haben. Ja, und was sie denn überhaupt behaupten könnten, sie werden jetzt hier irgendwie besonders sicher und so. Das ist ein Produkt, das noch gar nicht da ist. Sie können natürlich alles Mögliche behaupten. Am Ende zählt, was sie da liefern. Aber dann ist es auch so mit dieser Argumentation, ja, wenn Apple ja schon sagt, dass sie irgendwie nicht an die Daten rankommen können und solche Behauptungen. Das hatten wir glaube ich letztes Mal hier schon ganz gut analysiert, dass das Quatsch ist. Natürlich kann Apple, wenn sie wollten, an unsere iMessage-Daten rankommen, weil wenn sie in der Lage sind, uns irgendwie Key Recovery zu bieten, dass ich wieder in meinen Account reinkomme, dann können sie ja genauso gut auf Daten rankommen. Mat-Puddle-Test?
Der Mat-Puddle-Test funktioniert folgendermaßen. Stell dir vor, du läufst durch ein Mat-Puddle, durch ein Schlammloch, rutscht aus, dein Device fällt unrecoverably in diesen Mat-Puddle und du haust dir so den Kopf an, dass du dich auf keinen Fall mehr an dein Passwort erinnern kannst. Der Mat-Puddle-Test ist jetzt, man nehme ein neues Device und versuche sein Passwort zu recovern und wenn man das Passwort recovert hat auf dem neuen Device und man bekommt alle seine Daten wieder, dann kann der Anbieter dieser Cloud auch die ganzen Daten immer wieder neu recovern.
Genau.
Und das war so die Argumentation zu dem Apple, wie heißt das Ding? Apple ID. Dass nämlich die Apple ID genau diesem Mat-Puddle-Test nicht besteht und damit halt auch iMessage.
Naja, was war das hier noch mit CryptoCat?
Ja, na, da... Also ich meine, ich sage ja immer allen Leuten, die mich jetzt ausfragen, oder die Studenten so, ja, irgendwie, wie verschlüsselt man denn und so weiter und so fort. Guckst du so in deren Gesichter und weißt schon, ihr wollt und ihr könnt gar nicht alles verschlüsseln, was ihr euch jetzt vorstellt zu verschlüsseln. Weil solange ich denken kann, ist halt so Sicherheit immer auch mehr auf Wand. Und die wenigsten Leute sind einfach bereit, diesen mehr auf Wand zu betreiben, wenn es halt so aufs Tägliche runter bricht.
Nicht nur mehr aufwand, sondern auch mehr Leiden und weniger...
Ja, man muss halt auch einfach sich damit befassen. Es gibt halt nicht diesen so, ich klicke jetzt aufs Schlösschen und alles ist sicher-Button. Das gibt diese Abstraktion nicht. Und ganz viele Leute wollen das und glauben das. Aber ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass wenn man sich irgendwie so verschlüsseln, verschützen wie auch immer will, muss man selber ein bisschen Hirnschmalz und ein bisschen mehr Aufwand investieren. Und dann gibt es aber trotzdem natürlich diese ganzen Applikationen, die sagen, hier gibt es den Schlösschen-Button und alles ist ganz sicher. Und KryptoCAD war auch so eine Chat-Messenger-Application, die auf Verschlüsselung und so weiter gesetzt hat. Und da gab es jetzt so ein Disclosure, dass man diese, ich weiß nicht, ob es die Zertifikat oder was, die konnte man halt, letztendlich brach es darauf runter, dass man zweieinhalb Jahre alle Konversationen, die Krypten konnte von KryptoCAD, weil sie halt eben...
Innerhalb von Minuten.
Weil sie halt ihre Krypto halt so irgendwie, komm wir machen mal hier Ruby und Rails, hab keine Ahnung wieso, weiß schon so. Wir machen jetzt mal Krypto-Unterhalt, mal Hirnschmalz zu investieren und so weiter.
Sie haben sich zur Schlüsselgeneration nicht richtig den Binär-Code genommen, also die Hexwerte, sondern die ASCII-Zahlen der Hexwerte oder sowas, was natürlich nur 0 bis 9a bis f ist anstatt irgendwie 0 bis 255 oder irgendwie so.
Man könnte es halt brute-forcen in kürzester Zeit. Warte, was steht hier? Ich muss gerade mal lesen, es ist schon wieder so ein paar Tage her, dass ich es gelesen habe. Ja, das sind ja alles so viele Texte. To long did not read. Genau, das ist das, was ich brauche. If you used group chat in CryptoCAD from October 17th, 2011 bis 2013, assume your message were compromised. Messages also if you or the person you are talking to was an inversion from the time span, then assume your messages are being compromised. Und wie haben sie das jetzt gemacht? Lastly, I think everyone involved with CryptoCAD are incompetent.
Blablabla, okay.
Okay, okay, in seinem To long did not read. Ach so, decryptoCAD cracks the ECC public keys generated by CryptoCAD in wenigen Minuten sozusagen. Also du kannst halt die ganzen Keys sozusagen brutforcen.
So wie bei dem Jahr damals, ne? Als irgendjemand den Testcode nicht rausgeworfen hat und der auch nur irgendwie Keys mit mit nur ganz wenigen echten Bits produziert hat.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, genau. Eigentlich ist so die Moral von der Geschichte oder was heißt die Moral der Geschichte, aber wieder so ein kleiner Hinweis, also überall wo es diesen Schlösschenbutton gibt und man denkt so, ach ja cool, jetzt bin ich sicher und so, ne seid ihr nicht. Sehr wahrscheinlich nicht. Irgendwie, ihr müsst selber ein bisschen nachdenken und gucken, was ihr da tut und halt vor allen Dingen möglichst viel von diesem Verschlüsselungsprozess selber machen, die Keys selber generieren, irgendwie euch selber ein bisschen kümmern, weil, sobald ihr halt wieder in irgendwelchen dritten Instanzen vertraut, dann, wie Rudi schon vorhin sagte, ist nur so sicher wie das schwächste Glied in der Kette und wenn ihr dann ganz viele Glieder in der Kette gar nicht kennt bzw. nicht selber kontrolliert, dann kann man das auch gleich sein lassen. Ja, so viel dazu.
Krypto ist hart. Und Krypto ist irgendwie nichts für Anfänger.
Nee, also ich meine, es gibt schon, es gibt definitiv Bereiche, wo man das haben will und es gibt auch Gründe, bestimmte Sachen zu verschlüsseln, aber wie gesagt, wenn euch was wichtig ist, dann beschäftigt euch selber ein bisschen damit.
Man könnte es auch noch anders formulieren. Es gibt große Firmen, die schmeißen sehr viel Geld da drauf, dass ihre Krypto nicht gebrochen wird, weil sonst ihre Konsolen geöffnet werden können. Und die mussten alle mit ansehen, wie es dann doch irgendjemand aufgemacht hat, das Zeug. Also ja, ist hart und bleibt hart.
Ja, das heißt nicht, dass man es gleich sein lassen soll für alle Sachen und gleich alles abgeben soll, aber eher beschäftigt euch ein bisschen damit. Und wenn ihr es verstanden habt, dann erzählt es euren Freunden, die es noch nicht verstanden haben.
Ich hab hier gerade mal in mein Podcast-Archiv reingeschaut.
Und?
Jetzt erst.
Jetzt wird's mir erst klar. Es ist ein bisschen älter, braucht länger für den... Das war jetzt vom Juni. Die Aufnahme ist vom Mai 2006. Also das ist jetzt schon geschlagene sieben Jahre her. Hab ich mal Whitfield Diffie interviewt. Also der Diffie.
Den Diffie Hellman.
Von Diffie Hellman, den Diffie, genau. Den ich irgendwie in Prag auf einer absurden Security-Konferenz getroffen hab. Und den hab ich da irgendwie ins Hotel geführt. Was man so macht bei der NSA.
Spezielle Behandlung.
Ich kann mich gerade gar nicht an so viele Highlights erinnern. Ich weiß nur, dass es ein sehr interessantes Gespräch war. Vielleicht mag da ja mal jemand reinhören. Müsst ihr mir eigentlich auch selber noch mal anhören, das ist echt interessant.
Gib mal ein Detail dazu, dass man das dann auch findet.
Ja, ich kann mich irgendwie mit diesem Scheiß-IRC-Frinot-Fuck irgendwie nicht mehr einloggen hier mit meinem anderen Kurs.
Ansonsten grundsätzlich auch, was Krypto betrifft, immer SSL nutzen, auch wenn man nur einen normalen IRC-Chat benutzt, ist egal. Ja, das ist...
Hat die Episode irgendeinen Namen, dann kann man sie vielleicht wieder finden.
Ich find sie auch.
Ach, CRI-008.
Genau. CRI-008. Damals hatten die Sendung noch keine besonderen Namen.
Krypto schmipto. Lass uns doch mal über den Göffel riechen.
Lass uns lieber erst nochmal kurz erklären, was mit Bitcoin passiert.
Ja, irgendwie, also ich meine...
Hast du dich ein bisschen stabilisiert nach unten?
Ja, ich meine, das ist jetzt immer noch nicht dramatisch. Also im Vergleich, weil ich das schon letztes Mal sagte, zum Jahresanfang sind es immer noch gigantisch hoch letztendlich, aber es senkt sich schon so ein bisschen.
Es ist schon ganz schön schnell radikal gefallen, von 80 in Richtung bis 50 runter war es sogar. Jetzt pendelt es gerade so, ich sehe gerade bei Roddy 66, ansonsten heute Morgen oder gestern war es immer so um 60 rum, vielleicht pendelt es sich da auch wieder hin. Also irgendwie kleine Talfahrt und es stabilisiert sich jetzt langsam so wieder, wo es aber aufhören wird mit dem Stabilisieren, keine Ahnung. Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn es so um die 60 rum bleibt. Ob das jetzt aber ein guter Zeitpunkt zum Einsteigen ist, wie mich immer alle fragen. Wenn ich das wüsste, wäre ich stinkend reich und auch ich kann diese Frage nicht beantworten.
Stinkend reich.
Aber andere Nachrichten in dem Bereich gibt es eigentlich auch gar nicht.
Habe ich das erzählt, dass der Bundestag beschlossen hat, dass Bitcoins, die älter sind als in einem Jahr, steuerfrei sind?
Haben sie das wirklich beschlossen oder sind sie nur drauf gekommen, dass man doch die...
Wir hören uns einen FDP-Typie, der anscheinend Bitcoins hat. Ich weiß nicht, was seine Motivation ist. Er hat da mal nachgefragt, wie das dann so steuermäßig zu behandeln wäre. Und wahrscheinlich weil auch alle keine Ahnung haben usw. und gesagt haben, wir machen es so wie bei Gold. Wenn man die in einem Jahr hält, ist es steuerfrei.
Ist das nicht bei Aktien auch so?
Nein, bei Aktien war es bis 2009 oder 2007 oder gab es eine Übergangsfrist, da war es steuerfrei. Und alle Aktien, die man nach 2009 kauft, die sind der Gewinn zu versteuern.
Aber gibt es nicht eine Haltefrist, nach der das steuerfrei ist?
Bei Aktien glaube ich nicht. Aber bei Gold gibt es die halt, weil Gold zum Sparen und tralala und überhaupt. Und Bitcoin ist jetzt auf der gleichen Stufe wie Gold, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und natürlich sind meine Bitcoins erlänger als ein Jahr alt. Nee, aber ist auf jeden Fall, weil man vorher irgendwie überlegt, wie kann ich den Start am besten beschreiten. Da ist der Link. Und die haben mich jetzt ein bisschen legalisiert. Das ist doch ganz gut, da fühlt man sich gleich viel lockerer.
Was kriegt denn die FDP?
Das Foto dazu finde ich nett. Wie sind da irgendwie tatsächlich so?
Ich hatte so eine Goldcoin, so eine Bitcoins, diese echten Coins gedruckt während meiner Hand, weil der Jörg aus Room 77 hat mir mal seine Coins gegeben. Er hatte dann irgendwie zwei Stück von. Eine war 10 Dollar und ich glaube, eine 25 oder so. Und bei dem Kurs damals hat man dann so überlegt, wir halten ja gerade so 800 Euro in der Hand. Und es war schon irgendwie ganz ganz witzig.
Was sind das für Teile?
Das sind normal mit irgendwie glaube ich ein bisschen Silber oder so geprägte Münzen, die aber auf der einen Seite, wie man hier im Bild sieht, haben die so ein Hologramm. Und das ist so aufgeklebt. Und unter diesem Hologramm ist wohl so ein gefaltetes Stück Papier, wo der Secret Key von einem Bitcoin drin steht. Und zwar du kriegst die per Post zu dir geschickt mit auch einem, wie genau ist es, weiß ich nicht. Aber du kriegst sie geschickt und dann ist auf diesem Key noch nichts drauf, sondern du musst dem, der die druckt, erst mal bestätigen, dass der angekommen ist, die Münze. Und in dem Augenblick überweist der dann die Bitcoins auf diesen Key, der da drauf steht. Das heißt, du musst dem dann schon vertrauen, weil der kennt natürlich auch diesen Key, sonst könnte das ja nicht drauf überweisen. Oder ich weiß nicht, wie sein System genau ist. Vielleicht hat das ja irgendwo in ein Programm gepackt und der weiß es nicht, sondern nur sein Programm weiß es und vergisst es danach. Ist egal, er könnte es auf jeden Fall aber wissen. Und aber so läuft es, dass auf diesem Stück Zettelchen da irgendwie der Secret Key drauf ist. Und da es nur dieser Typ so macht und die ganze Welt muss dann sozusagen diesem Typ vertrauen, dass er es auch wirklich immer drauf überweist, kannst du sozusagen diesen Coin so von einem zum nächsten so weitergeben und gibst irgendwie so 25 Bitcoins weiter. Und wenn irgendwann mal einer keinen Bock mehr hat, diese Münze irgendwie zu benutzen, dann könnte das theoretisch aufknacken, sich den Zettel rausnehmen und das Ding so einlösen. Und dann feststellen, Scheiße, der Typ hat nie die 25 Bitcoins da reingepackt. Ja, ne, kann man wahrscheinlich sogar, kriegt man die Transaction, weil man kann ja die Blockchain sehen, kriegt man sogar die Transaction, wo man sieht, dass es was gemacht hat.
Wenn man aber diesen Zettel da rausnimmt, dann zerstört man das Video oder was?
Dann muss man das Hologramm da abmachen. Irgendwie so soll wohl die Idee dahinter sein. Also gar nicht so schlecht.
Wo gibt es diese Bitcoin? Gibt es auch einen Link dazu?
Da ist... Da gibt es einen Internet. Bestimmt der Chat wird uns gleich irgendwie was hinschmeißen.
Doch mal nach Bitcoin meinst du.
Bitcoin, Coin. Ja, hab ich mal wieder vergessen. Aber...
ja.
Ich denke mal, irgendwer wird es gleich in den Chat posten. Physikal Bitcoins, da war doch gerade schon was.
Ja, genau. Kaza...
Ah ja, genau.
Glauben in Zahlen, oder was? Viris? Wie war das? Wir konnten alle kein Latein, ne?
Nee.
Aber letztmal haben wir es ja richtig gemacht.
Ich hab da zu Hause so ein Papier, da steht drauf, dass ich es könnte. Aber das ist aus Bayern. Das Papier.
Warum tippst du nicht gleich den ganzen Spruch ein und dann würde Google schon sagen, was es ist.
Ja, Google Translate kann auch Latein. Das ist...
Weil man darf Google nicht immer vertrauen, wenn es um Geld geht.
Es geht aber um Latein. Da?
Du willst doch la.de.
Das ist das Bitcoin-Motto angeblich.
Strengths and Numbers. Kräfte, das ist das Virus.
Malen nach Zahlen, nee.
Spirograph.
Na gut, alles klar. Bitcoin steuerfrei, da kann ja nichts mehr passieren.
Ansonsten?
Wenn wahrscheinlich einer von den Grünen gefragt hätte, dann wär's sofort irgendwie hochversteuert geworden.
Terroristen.
Gut, dass einer von der FDP gefragt hat.
Ansonsten war ja wohl, dass diese Ami-Behörde da hat an lauter Unternehmen irgendwie so ein Letter geschickt, dass sie doch irgendwie aufhören sollen Geldwäsche zu beschreiben, unter anderem auch an die Bitcoin-Fundation. Ich glaube, ich hatte es kurz mal erwähnt. Da hat der Kurs auch kurz gezappelt. Die haben gesagt, sie brauchen ein bisschen Zeit, um irgendwie das zu beantworten. Haben sie dann getan am 2.7. mit irgendwie eine 5 oder 6 Seiten langen Brief, wo sie erklären, warum sie nicht in Geld handeln und kein Money durch die Gegend schieben und nichts mit Geldwäsche zu tun haben und warum dann Bitcoin was Gutes ist. Und irgendwie, also richtig, die haben dann einen Anwalt herangesetzt und mal so ein ordentliches Schreiben angefertigt, um zu erklären, dass Bitcoin alles ok ist. Und falls das, ja, amerikanisch Finanzamt oder was auch immer das da geschrieben hat, falls sie noch Fragen haben, würden sie sich ja gerne auch mit denen an einen Tisch setzen und denen alles erklären und erläutern, was irgendwie so notwendig wäre. Ist ganz witzig zu lesen, wie man profimäßig auf so eine Schreiben antwortet. Auch wenn es in Englisch ist, aber...
Hast du da auch noch den passenden Link zu dieser Antwort?
Warte, warte, bei Bitcoin Charts, bei Bitcoin Charts, da gibt es alles hier. Response to State of California Warnings hier, zack, einmal den da. Da steht das als PDF.
Ja, davon sprechend, dass es ja immer wieder Manifestationen von verrückten Dingen auch in Metall gibt. Hat das hier Woddy ja auch.
Noch einen ganz kleinen Kurznachtrag, was du noch übersehen würdest. Aber wenn Tim immer so schnell switcht, wenn es nicht seine Themen sind, und zwar flatter, nimmt jetzt auch Bitcoins.
Oh, stimmt, du hast recht.
Ja, und das muss schon nochmal erwähnt werden.
Ich frage mich, ob die Leute dann auch mit Bitcoins flattern und ich dann für mein Zeug in Bitcoins geflattert werde. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Derzeit ist es auch nur Einzahlung. Also du kannst quasi den Einzahlungsprozess jetzt über Bitcoins abwickeln. Also wenn du sozusagen deine Bitcoins verflattern willst, dann kannst du das tun. Auszahlungen nach Bitcoin wird wohl erwogen und da warten sie irgendwie noch auf die User-Reaction, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Das sollte für die auch günstiger sein, dann sparen sie Bankengebühren oder sowas, oder?
Naja, angenommen, ich würde jetzt Geld abheben auf Bitcoin und dann mir das quasi durch Mt. Gox in Euro wandeln lassen.
Nee, nee, nee, auf Silk Road in Ware.
So, dann muss ich doch auch Geld zahlen für die Auszahlungen bei Mt.
Ja, aber die haben doch auch ein Transaktionsgebühr.
Ich meine, davon lebt doch der Laden.
Bei Mt. Gox, wenn du dann einen Euros haben willst, zahlst du 0,6%, ja.
0,6%.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Und ab 1000 Dollar oder so sinkt es auch.
0,5 ist mehr, 2 oder so plus irgendwas.
Und es sinkt auf 0,55%, wenn man über eine gewisse Summe kommt.
Sechs Prozent.
Sechs Promille.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall weniger als PayPal. Und vielleicht wird es ja auch noch mehr, ne? Das Geld. Ja, oder weniger. Ja, muss man halt schnell sein, ne, sozusagen. Also das ist so das Problem. Ist die Frage, mit welchem Prozessor die dann letzten Endester arbeiten?
Ob der nicht auch noch mal das drauf denkt.
Mit welchem Exchange meinst du?
Ja, genau, also bei Flatter, irgendwo stand das, was sie machen, aber ich hab's mir ehrlich gesagt nicht durchgedesen.
Ja, aber ich mein, sie fangen langsam an und das ist auf jeden Fall ja eine gute, gute Entwicklung. Ich hab eh das Gefühl, bei Flatter irgendwie, da fehlt so ein bisschen der Anstoß, um mal irgendwie, der große Durchbruch fehlt halt noch. Ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt mit Bitcoin kommt, aber auf jeden Fall ist es wieder mal ein Stück in die richtige Richtung. Und für Bitcoin ist es ja auf jeden Fall auch gut, wenn da wieder was Größeres ist, was auch Bitcoins unterstützt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber bidirektional wäre schon ganz interessant. Also BIBS, Bitcoin Internet Payment System.
Ja, da gibt's jetzt mehr.
Ich bin gespannt und noch nicht so ganz davon überzeugt, dass diese ganze Bitcoin-Bezahlwelt wirklich so voll in diese Services im Netz so überall eingreift.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Schwer zu sagen.
Der andere Service, der er noch gibt, ist Bitpay.
Und das ist im Prinzip, die verhalten sich quasi wie Paypal, oder was?
Und ich meine, das ist auch noch Coinbase, aber das ist immer noch iOS.
Heißt das denn, dass sie mir das dann auch gleich in Euro sozusagen...
Der Bitpay ist zum Bezahlen. Du kaufst irgendwas und dein Händler nimmt halt auch Bitcoins, dann wirst du automatisch zu Bitpay weitergeleitet, zahlst da in Bitcoins, die merken, dass du bezahlt hast und bestätigen dem Händler, dass jetzt folgende Summe, für den theoretisch sichtbar nur ein Euro angekommen ist. Und die machen sozusagen diesen Change.
Also wenn ich das richtig deute, Bitcoin setzt sich durch. Bitcoin macht sich zumindest als Idee gerade breit, um quasi den eigentlichen Wire-Transfer zu ersetzen.
Worldwide-Payment.
Einfach kurzfristig in Bitcoins umgewandelt, das Geld, aber man muss damit nicht die Bankennetze benutzen und so weiter. Das ist eigentlich schon mal ein sehr interessanter Effekt, den Bitcoin haben kann.
Die Sache, die ich letztens schon mal mit einem Kumpel unterhalten habe, eigentlich müsste Paypal ja damit einsteigen, weil das halt das nächste große Business ist, bevor alle anderen das machen und Paypal damit überflüssig ist. Aber Paypal sitzt natürlich noch auf dem hohen Thron und die wollen die halt gar nicht erst groß werden lassen, deswegen steigen sie natürlich nicht ein. Aber irgendwann müssen sie sich überlegen, machen wir jetzt oder machen wir nicht. Und das ist der interessante Punkt, weil wenn sie es tun, dann in dem Augenblick hat sich es dann auch durchgesetzt. Aber so lange, also die versuchen natürlich so spät wie möglich irgendwie auch auf Bitcoins einzusteigen, weil die haben ja ihr Business erstmal und die sind jetzt auch nicht klein dabei, Paypal. Also die können sich da schon noch eine weite Zeit lassen.
Zumal Paypal auch irgendwie von der Verbreitung her deutlich gefühlt in den letzten zwei Jahren zugelegt hat. Also irgendwie kann ich im Internet einkaufen und eigentlich alles außer Amazon hat Paypal.
Oder beides. Oder Apple. Ja, das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Zumal, ich meine, wir machen uns irgendwie auch überhaupt gar keine, also was ich sehr interessant finde, ist in den USA, also auf der einen Seite kommt uns ja hier unser Bankensystem und unsere Zahlungswelt in Europa und Deutschland im Besonderen kommt uns ja total antik vor, weil die nicht so was machen wie Paypal. So gefühlt jetzt, unabhängig davon, was man jetzt von Paypal als Firma so halten kann oder sollte. Aber die Wahrheit ist ja, dass Paypal eigentlich nur deshalb wirklich so groß und so geil ist, weil das ganze Banken- und Finanzsystem in den USA vollständig im Mittelalter stecken geblieben ist.
Noch schlimmer als bei uns, meinste.
Alter, die wissen nicht, was Online-Banking ist. Die schicken da Shacks, Papier.
Wenn du mal einen Amerikaner wirklich schocken willst, also einen, der jetzt noch nicht lange oder noch gar nicht in Europa war, sag zu ihm, ich hab in den letzten 20 Jahren keinen Shack angefasst. Dann gucken die dich an, als käme du von einem anderen Planeten.
Ja, so Shacks ist da immer noch, glaube ich, ein ganz großes Ding.
Das letzte Mal, das hab ich vor ein paar Wochen hingekriegt.
Ich hab aber in den letzten 20 Jahren, den letzten Shack, den ich bekommen habe, nicht von mir. Das letzte Mal, dass ich mit Shack bezahlt wurde, war vom ZDF. Natürlich auf so einer Konferenz, wo es um die Zukunft ging und so weiter. Das fand ich ganz lustig.
Aber ich mein, im Prinzip ist ja das Konzept schon ganz witzig, dass du so eine Banknote kriegst, wo du den Betrag selber drauf schreibst. Also das ist ja schon irgendwie auch, irgendwie so, ist schon nicht schlecht die Idee.
Ja gut, aber halt in digital dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen praktischer, weil muss er halt nicht, ich meine, ja.
Ich glaub, ich bin seit der ersten Woche, wo du es bei der Postbank irgendwie hier mit SSL irgendwie Online-Banking machen kannst, ohne Java. Alle anderen Banken hatten früher irgendwie Java oder so ein komisches Zeug da am Start oder extra Apps, keine Ahnung.
Dafür hatte sie die Postbank-Öffnungszeiten beim Online-Banking. Hatte sie doch noch ganz lange.
Sparkasse.
Ja, weil es nur die Sparkasse hatte, die nicht die Postbank.
Die Postbank waren die ersten, die da so pur SSL, so browser-only irgendwie Online-Bank gemacht haben und die gesagt, genau das ist das, was ich haben will. Und seitdem hab ich nichts anderes gemacht.
Ja oder, ich meine, aber es gibt hier auch immer noch die OMEs und so, die ihren Überweisungsträger und jetzt hab ich gehört, dieses Skimming, wo sie irgendwelche Apparaturen davor, die EC-Automaten schrauben, das ist jetzt nicht der heiße Scheiß mehr, sondern was die machen, ist die bauen so Attrappen vor die Briefkästen an den Banken, wo die OMEs über ihre unterschreibenden Überweisungsträger rein tun und fischen sich die raus und haben dann halt so valide, unterschriebene Papierdokumente, die von Banken dann immer noch für irgendwas akzeptiert werden. Und benutzen die dann, um den Schabalack zu treiben.
Ja, aber die OMEs sterben auch bald aus.
Worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte mit PayPal ist, der Value von PayPal ist ja eigentlich ihr User-Interface und ihre Verbreitung.
Gut, das User-Interface, ja gut, aber ja.
Das ist aber okay. Also ich meine, mit PayPal hab ich schnell mal was bezahlt. Click einloggen, ja sagen, fertig.
Haben Sie ja mit den Händlern über so ein Standard-App integriert, der Händler schickt zu PayPal, du bezahlst, die signalisieren dem Händler, ist alles okay, der Händler sagt, super, meine Kohle ist da.
Alle Leute, die dir schon mal gegen dieses Appi programmieren mussten, kotzen alle, aber es ist halt da. Deswegen in dem Moment, wo Bitcoin relevant ist, als alternativer Geld-Transfer, vor allem als alternativer, also wer wirklich Angst haben muss davor, sind eigentlich die Kreditkarten-Unternehmen. Weil die sind ja derzeit sozusagen, dass die Kohle...
Ja, die haben ja sowieso auch so vor PayPal schon Angst, also die kacken sowieso schon die ganze Zeit ab.
Ja, ja, ich meine, auf jeden Fall, ich wiederhole mich, aber wenn irgendein Markt auf diesem Planeten ready for disruption ist, dann ist es Finance. Also das ist einfach, und das muss auch unbedingt stattfinden. Und da wird sicherlich nicht nur Bitcoin jetzt eine Rolle spielen, sondern es ist genauso auch hier so diese Square, oder wie die heißen, also die auch diese ganzen Payment-Sachen mit Kreditkarten irgendwie anders aufziehen, sprich Zugang auch kleinerer Unternehmen zu solchen Abbruchsystemen. Also grundsätzlich wird der Finanzfluss einfach flexibler. Und an den Stellen, wo er eben auch die traditionellen Hierarchien durchbricht, wird es irgendwie auch natürlich auch spannend, welche Auswirkungen das für die Wirtschaft als solche hat.
Und was ist deine Voraussage? Wie lange dauert es noch bis der erste Bankenchef Vorratsdatenspeicherung wegen Bitcoins verlangt?
Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Also jetzt mal abgesehen, dass es sinnlos ist.
Aber Bitcoin ist doch die fleisch gewordene Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ich meine mehr Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ja, nein. Abgesehen davon, dass es sinnlos ist. Aber ich meine, wenn jetzt die Disruption kommt, dann kommen ja die Anwälte und dann kommen die absurden Forderungen. Ich meine, dann kannst du da bei der CSU einfach mal anrufen. Die fordern das dann sicherlich auch gerne gleich. Sobald das Finanzsystem erst mal drauf kommt, dass Bitcoin ja irgendwie das Finanztransaktionsfleisch gewordene Pirate Bay für die ist, da wird doch der Ton rauer dann, oder?
Du kannst doch nochmal Coinbase reintun. Hat man zwar schon ein paar Mal verlinkt, aber...
Ist auch so ein Payment-Anbieter?
Ja, und Hosted Wallet und so. Und die sind auch gerade immer fleißig noch am wachsen.
Hosted Wallet ist jetzt von Coinbase oder ist nochmal ein anderer Dienst?
So jetzt aber, der Titan...
Ich mach jetzt nicht nochmal die Überleitung.
Wir haben heute schon über die Titanen-Hardware gesprochen. Aber ich hab hier etwas, das ist wirklich zeitlos.
Einfach nur zeitlos. Krass leicht.
Krass leicht, ja.
Weitere Adjektive sparen wir uns einfach mal. Aber Roddy hat es vorhin benutzt, um seinen Eis zu verspeisen.
Und zwar den Titanium Spork, so wird er bei ThinkGeek verkauft.
Und du hast dir tatsächlich von ThinkGeek einen Titanium Spork gekauft.
Ja, warum nicht? Der ist super. Man kann zum Beispiel Eis damit essen. Der ist wirklich total leicht und sehr stabil.
Und bei durchspielen könnte ich den jetzt schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Zeug so spröde ist, dass es bricht, aber auf jeden Fall, der hält einiges aus.
Mehr als Plastik auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf Deutsch nenne ich ihn immer Göffel. Ach so, man muss vielleicht sagen, das Ding sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein Löffel, aber er hat vorne noch so kleine Zinken.
Das ist echt die Evolution des Bestecks.
Man kann ihn sowohl als Löffel, als auch als Gabel benutzen.
Also wirklich. Die Zinken können für so eine Nudelsuppe, da kriegst du die Soße und die Nudeln gleichzeitig. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Das ist unter Umständen für Kinder sogar ganz praktisch. Sie können sich nämlich manchmal nicht entscheiden, ob sie lieber Löffel oder Gabel haben wollen für die Nudeln.
Also, immer wenn ich so Asie esse...
Der heißt offiziell wie?
Spork.
Spoon and Fork.
Spoon and Fork. Und nicht Göffel, Gabel und Löffel. Du kriegst ihn sicherlich auch irgendwo als Göffel. Keine Ahnung. Es gibt möglicherweise auch Konkurrenzprodukte, aber dieser aus Titanium, der ist eben besonders stabil und besonders leicht und ich finde ihn super.
Ja, also ich muss auch sagen, es gibt ja diese anderen Dinge, da wurde ich auch gerade im Chat verlinkt, wo auf der einen Seite Löffel und auf der anderen Seite Gabel ist, aber das ist irgendwie nicht das gleiche, wie der Spork. Und ich denke jedes Mal, wenn ich Asieressen esse und da diese Stäbchen gereicht bekomme, denke ich darüber nach, wieso? Und warum diese Stäbchen eigentlich sein müssen, ich weigere mich auch ganz oft mit Stäbchen zu essen und denke über die Evolution des Essbestecks tatsächlich nach und also das ist Augenöffnend.
Hier im Chat haben noch einige etwas andere.
Ja, aber die mit dem, wo der Löffel und die Gabel auf beiden Seiten unterschiedlich ist, ist halt nicht so schön.
die Idee ist offensichtlich nicht so schwierig.
gibt es auch einen Uri Geller Spork schon.
Also irgendwie, sie scheinen offensichtlich zu sein, die Idee, aber ich finde den also auf jeden Fall mal gut. Für 9 Dollar, ich weiß nicht, ob er im deutschen ThinkGeek inzwischen auch zu haben ist.
im deutschen Amazon kriegst du das auf jeden Fall in allen Formen und Farben.
Optimus Kocher Titanium Spork von Katadyn.
Das ist auch sehr schön hier, es besteht Light Marfire. Da ist die Gabel auf der einen Seite und der Löffel auf der anderen.
Das ist bei der Bundeswehr so, oder? Haben die nicht so ein Kombi, oder?
Nee, da hast du drei Einzelteile, bzw. vier, die du so untereinander steckst.
Ja, aber ich muss sagen, die Kombination...
Oh, was ist denn das hier?
True Utility Tool Spork Knife Chrome.
Ui, was macht denn das?
Na ja.
Sieht cool aus. Was macht denn das? Das ist einfach so ein Klappteil irgendwie Spork Knife oder Gabellöffel, also eine Spork und irgendwie einen Karabinerhaken in einem zum zusammenklappen. Ah, aber der hat sozusagen auch noch eine Sägefunktion. Das heißt, an der Rand, an dem Rand ist der Spork... Na ja, ist alles eine Frage. Ist halt ein...
Ist halt ein Spornreifen.
Ist halt ein Sporgerät.
Dieses Stäbchen.
Aber sieht nett aus. Mal gucken, ob man unter Göffel auch was findet.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn man das Ding dabei hat und dann... Was tatsächlich? Also bei uns in der Firma gibt es irgendwie Dienstags und Donnerstags gibt es immer so Tüten. Da gibt die Firma immer so Tüten aus. Und da ist halt manchmal...
Diese drei Dezenten Nudeln oder?
Nee, da ist so manchmal ein Salat drin und manchmal irgendwie so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein Bagel, so ein Belegter oder so. Und dann ist halt nicht in jeder Tüte ist halt die Plastikgabel drin, wenn es da mal Salat gibt. Und dann ist natürlich auch sonst nirgendwo eine Gabel aufzutreiben. Und dann kannst du deinen Salat entweder nur mit einem Messer oder nur mit einem Löffel essen oder du hast deinen Göffel dabei.
Reicht mir mal den Göffel, oh, Frikadein.
Also es gibt offensichtlich sehr viele Varianten, wie man sowas irgendwie bauen kann. Ja, ich hab noch nicht versucht, den im Handgepäck im Flugzeug mitzunehmen. Das wäre noch ein interessanter, ne.
Wart nicht mehr?
Wann bist du das letzte Mal geflogen? Ich kann mich an diese Zeiten erinnern, aber das ist glaube ich schon seit fast 15 Jahren nicht.
Die waren immer ziemlich schick, ich hab die immer oft geklaut, weil der Flugbesteck war immer so ein bisschen stabiler, weil die da ja das weiter benutzt.
So ein bisschen kleiner und so ein bisschen stabiler.
Ein bisschen kleiner und die Löffel waren so richtig, die hatten wir ein bisschen mehr Pepp, nicht so eine scharfkantigen Bleche, die sie ausknipsen, sondern so richtig, das war ordentlich in der Hand, fand ich gut.
Tim ist ganz fasziniert, was der Markt so hergibt.
Ja, ist wirklich erstaunlich. Also solche absurden Kombinationen.
Also auf jeden Fall ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Genau.
Findest du? Mit diesen Stäbchen, ich verstehe das auch nicht. Magst du keine Stäbchen?
Außer beim Sushi meinst du?
Ja, nicht mal beim Sushi eigentlich. Da esse ich es fast sogar lieber mit der Hand. Die graben ja auch nicht das Feld mit irgendwie so Pool-Q-Köse um, sondern die nehmen auch eine Schaufel. Und es gibt ja auch einen Löffel und so weiter.
Aber ich finde, bei Sushi-Stäbchen geht es aber eigentlich.
Ja, geht, aber würdest du sagen, dass das das optimale...
Ja, optimal, weiß ich nicht, aber da du den Sushi auch so eintunken willst, kannst du dann auch mit den Stäbchen oben und unten, da kommst du halt an möglichst viel Fläche vom Sushi noch dran, obwohl du ihn trotzdem festhältst. Und wenn du mit der Gabel aufspießt, dann ist es nicht mehr so richtig.
Aber man könnte auch ein passendes Sushi-Estool erfinden. Man müsste nicht.
So eine Zange mit so einer Federklammer.
Irgendwie sowas, wo man halt nicht so einen Geschirrspüler stecken kann.
So eine Pinzette, die so automatisch...
Was sich irgendwie sinnvoll von jedem in der Hand halten lässt und was man nicht irgendwie da tausend Tonnenweise Holz, Müll oder...
Und das nur, weil du nicht richtig mit Stäbchen essen kannst.
Ich finde Stäbchen blöd. Ich kann mit Stäbchen essen. Es ist halt so... Dieser kulturelle Effekt. Jetzt essen wir was Asiatisches und wir essen das mit Stäbchen, traditionell.
Ich hab mal bei einer Party, die ich gemacht hab, hatte ich mal einen echten Japaner dabei. Und da hatte ich auch Stäbchen hingestellt, weil ich so einen Reiskram gemacht hab. Und dann hat er sich aber irgendwie den Salat auf den Teller getan und hat dann so den normalen Blattsalat, wie man ihn kennt, dann mit Stäbchen gegessen. Das sah etwas komisch aus. Hat er aber sehr gut gemacht.
Das hat er wohl können.
Ja, er konnte das sehr, sehr gut. Gut, hast du noch ein Thema?
Das ist die letzte, oder?
Flasche.
Ist das nicht Clemens Flasche, die du da jetzt hast?
Nein, meine.
Wie deine.
Ich hab noch keine.
Ja, dann trink die doch.
Ich nehm die mit.
Ach so.
So einer bist du. So ein Mitnehmer. Mir ist das ehrlich gesagt egal, weil...
Dann, dann gib her.
Ist auch 05.
Ich will mich auch irgendwann mal besaufen zu Hause.
Du kannst mal das nächste Thema aufrufen, Dennis.
Ich wollte ja die Eidnacht ausklaßen, weil ich hab ja keinen Bock, so wie bei dir, dass ich es dann unterbrochen werde. Ich mach das ein bisschen schlauer.
Das kann sich aber hinziehen.
Macht doch mal eine gute Überleitung. Du kannst ja jetzt ein bisschen drauf achten. Ich wollte ja schon ab und zu mal Sachen sortieren und auch vorschieben und so. Aber es hat ja bei den Macs nicht geklappt und mit dem AirPlay hab ich es gelassen. Aber es wäre von auch schon ein besserer Thema gewesen bei Facetime und Audio-Geschichten.
Aber lass uns maximal noch bis Mitternacht machen. Ich muss mal wieder früh raus.
Also ich wollte irgendwann letztens hier meine neuen Boxen schick aufgestellt und meine Einstufe angeschlossen und wollte dann wieder ein bisschen Game of Thrones gucken, irgendwie mit schick Anlagensound und so. Und meine Rechner sind halt nicht mit Anlage verkabelt, weil es brummt auch rund überhaupt und haste nicht gesehen. Und wollte halt schick AirPlay benutzen, was ja bei QuakeTerm auch super funktioniert inzwischen. Also wenn du zum Beispiel den Keynote guckst, hier von Apple, im Browser sogar, und du hast als Audioquelle AirPlay, dann ist das sofort gleich in Sync. Das funktioniert ganz von alleine.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert auch bei YouTube, wenn du auf HTML5 stellst, sondern auch im Prinzip den Keynote.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen, dass es manchmal ging und manchmal nicht, aber noch nicht dauerhaft ging. Ist egal, ich guck ja meine Game of Thrones, ich hab ja da so ein Abo, und ich musste dann mit M-Player gucken. Und dann war das natürlich zeitversetzt. Und dann dachte ich mir, Zeitversetzt ist ja eigentlich kein Problem. Bei M-Player kann man ja die Zeit, das ist nur aus der Zeit, wo die Videos so schlecht gerippt waren, wo das Audio nicht in Sync war. Deswegen hat M-Player und eigentlich alle guten Player so ein Feature, mit dem du das Audio so in der Zeit so ein Zehntel Sekunden so ein bisschen nach vorne oder nach hinten schieben kannst.
Minus 1.950 Millisekunden.
Nee, 2.000.
Mann, ich hab rausgefunden, minus 1.950 ist besser.
Warte, warte. Jedenfalls dachte ich, okay, ich müsste jetzt hier klicken und das rausfinden, wie viel das so ist. Und dachte ich mir, naja, eigentlich, wenn die bei Apple immer so ein bisschen schlau sind, dann ist es exakt immer die gleiche Menge und ich google es jetzt mal schnell. Also hab ich das gegoogelt, was die Zeit ist und tatsächlich es sind immer zwei Sekunden exakt bei Design. Ich dachte ja so eine halbe Sekunde oder was, dass es zwei sind wusste ich jetzt auch nicht, aber auswuhlt. Ampliar 20x plus gedrückt, weil plus ist immer eine Zehntel Sekunde und zack, der Scheiß war in Sync und seitdem das geht. Also man kann jetzt prima Ampliar...
Kann man auch einen VLC einstellen, wenn man will, gibt es auch da die Option.
Mit der Zeit oder direkt, dass man sagt, man will Ampliar?
Man kann die Zeit einstellen.
Genau, was jetzt der nächste Schritt wäre, das müssten die bei VLC, also ich hoffe, die hören auch unsere Sendung, der Ampliar-Typ auch, der immer hier die schicke Ampliar Extended-Version macht. Noke, du bist ja auch Fan davon. Der müsste doch eigentlich, gibt es bestimmt irgendwie einen Apikoll mit dem man erkennen kann, dass man gerade Ampliar als Audio-Ausgabe hat, dass man es von selber merkt und die zwei Sekunden von selber drauf addiert und man gar nichts machen muss, so wie das halt bei QuickTime oder wie auch immer auch funktioniert. Und wenn man also nichts mehr machen muss, ist ja natürlich immer am coolsten.
Es gibt halt so Abzocker-Rapper-Programme für VLC, zum Beispiel AirVLC oder so. Die kommen dann halt so zu Presets und die machen nichts anderes, außer diesen Delay im VLC einzustellen. Und die wollen dann irgendwie einen Dollar oder was auch immer dafür haben. Das Geld könnt ihr euch sparen. Zwei Sekunden. Genau, ich hab nämlich AirFall benutzt und da war in dem Template 1950 Delay. Also die haben irgendwie 50 Millisekunden.
50 Millisekunden, das ist ja, was ist das, eine 20. Sekunde, das merkst du ja so auch gar nicht. Und vielleicht haben die das deswegen gemacht, weil das Paket ja bis zur Airport Express auch nochmal braucht, aber man hat ja zuhause in deinem Laden, wenn du mal guckst, das dauert nicht mal eine 1000. Sekunde. Also man hat da keine Packet Delays mehr, also nicht im lokalen Netzwerk. Deswegen eigentlich, wenn Apple sagt, es sind zwei Sekunden, sind es zwei Sekunden und dann würde ich den mal so trauen.
Flutschtet.
Denn was Apple sagt, ist Gesetz.
In dem Fall schon. Wenn es so um Design da beschrieben steht. Und jedenfalls, ich bin seitdem voll happy und kann jetzt hier schön über die Anlage irgendwie hören.
Und so auch ihr beide.
Also es kann sein, dass es, ich hab's mir noch nicht genau angeguckt, aber dass zu Mavericks was kommt. Weil die da irgendwie diesen ganzen wie Foundation-Kram vom iPhone da mit übernehmen.
Hast du schon mal reingeguckt wegen der Kanalgeschichte?
Ich hab mal reingeguckt, wie das ist mit der Trans-Applikations-Audio-Zeug unter iOS. Und das funktioniert im Wesentlichen ähnlich wie Audio-Units. Also du kannst halt so ein Effekt haben oder ein Instrumentprozessor, also der das MIDI-Audio macht, oder ein Audioeffekt, der Audio hin, Audio wieder zurück. Oder nur ein Generator, wie sie es nennen, also da kommt nur Audio raus. Ich hab diese von der Präsentation nur die Folien überflogen. Was es nicht zu sein scheint, ist sowas wie so ein Master-Slave-Modus, dass da irgendwie jetzt groß die eine Audio-Engine in der anderen läuft oder so. Das ist es auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber du hast irgendwie, also es scheint so zu sein, dass das iOS, ich weiß nicht, aber das ist glaube ich vorher schon so gewesen, dass wenn du ein USB-Audio-Device dransteckst, was sich konform verhält, dass du das halt dann einfach als Audio-Input und Output benutzen kannst. Und das auch Multitrack.
Was?
Wie?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden.
Wenn du ein USB-Audio-Device ans iPhone steckst oder an ein iOS-Device, dann kannst du das halt einfach als Input und Output benutzen.
Das ist das nicht jetzt auch schon so?
Aber das haben sie nochmal extra erwähnt und irgendwie kommen da auch Neuerungen. Irgendeiner Art, was genauer weiß ich nicht, aber das ist so.
Tja, sie könnten ja mal machen, dass das mal funktioniert mit diesem USB-Audio auf diesem Macintosh.
Was funktioniert da nicht?
Tja, wenn man es so genau wüsste, aber es gibt irgendwie einfach zu viele Unfälle mit USB und Audio. Nicht immer überall, aber ich...
Ich hab ja dieses Sennheiser-Headset und das hat noch mal so die beiden Klinkendinger. Und da die schon bei Sennheiser wussten, dass so ein Mikrofon-Ausgang, und da die wussten, dass ja viele Laptops nur einen Linen haben und nicht Mikrofonen, ist halt so ein USB-Adapter dabei, der halt dann ein Mikrofon in hat, wo du dann das Headset hier reinsteckst. Ich denke mal, das Headset gibt's schon ewig bei denen und das USB-Teil haben sie irgendwann dazu gelegt, damit sie weiter updatet sind. Und das funktioniert super eigentlich.
Ja, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass kein einziges USB-Audio-Gerät dieser Welt funktioniert. Ich meine, das wär sicherlich aufgefallen. Ja, aber ist halt auch nicht so, dass es da keine Probleme gäbe.
Aber grundsätzlich oder eher speziell mit bestimmten Geräten?
Ich weiß nicht, hier so in meinem Podcaster-Umfeld eigene Erfahrungen, in den letzten Jahren einfach immer wieder so Knackser, Kritzel läuft irgendwie aus dem Ruder. Problematik. Ich hab ja auch USB-Interfaces, da ist es vollkommen problemlos. Aber eben nicht unter allen Umständen. Manche sagen, das hat was damit zu tun, wie viele andere USB-Devices noch mit dran sind.
Kann durchaus sein.
Ja, kann durchaus sein. Einfach ein scheiß Interface eigentlich für Realtime USB. Das ist halt so funktioniert eigentlich, aber eigentlich ist es nicht geeignet. Das kann ich jetzt auch nicht weiter unterfüttern. Ich wollte nur noch mal kurz meinen Ärger da loswerden. Aber wo wir gerade bei Audio sind, können wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Werbung in eigener Sache machen hier für die Podcaster unter euch. Ihr werdet es wahrscheinlich eh schon mitbekommen haben, aber ich dachte, ich erklär's trotzdem noch mal. Hier unser Publisher, unser Podlove Publisher, der auch mittlerweile schon seit der letzten Sendung hier bei Mobamex die Sendung treibt und demnächst auch, glaube ich, noch die letzte Bastion der Metaebene nehmen wird, nämlich CAE, sozusagen der einzige noch nicht umgestellte aktive Podcast. Und ja, da gab es ein paar schöne Änderungen letzter Zeit, weil wir uns nämlich mehr um Auphonik gekümmert haben und so da jetzt mal so eine richtig schöne API-basierte Integration gemacht haben, die noch nicht so komplett ausgerollt ist. Jetzt gibt es schon irgendwie Import und demnächst gibt es auch noch Export. Das heißt, man kann sozusagen direkt aus seiner Publishing-Umgebung, wenn man so eine Sendung veröffentlicht, sich direkt diesen ganzen Metadatenschrubs von Auphonik mit einem Klick reinholen. Und damit ist das sozusagen mehr oder weniger vollständig gekoppelt. Und außerdem, wo wir gerade noch dabei waren, gab es dann auch noch ein ADN-Posting-Modul, das man dann auch gleich noch auf ADN rausraunzen kann.
Sag mal, dieser tolle Download-Button unter dem Player, den hatten wir ja schon mal thematisiert. Ich hab den ja auch im Einsatz und alles toll. Beim letzten Update haben wir ja auch kürzlich wieder eine neue Folge rausgeschrieben. Da hab ich mich wieder getraut, den Update-Button zu klicken. Diesmal gab es auch keine Migrationsbauchschmerzen. Aber dieser Download-Button, wie kommt der nochmal zustande? Ich hab mir damals erst den Podlove Webplay installiert und dann das Podlove Publisher Plugin.
Wie meinst du das, wie der zustande kommt? Wodurch der da erscheint? Na, weil du das in deinem Template da drin hast.
Ach, dieses Template war das, wo man das machen muss, ne? Na, ich hab's eben nicht drin. Also bei mir kommt der nicht.
Kannst du das auch von Hand da reinschreiben, aber dann, wie du hast das Template nicht drin. Du hast kein Template drin, bist sicher.
Na, bei mir ist zumindest nicht so eine Download-Button wie bei Mobile Max.
Ach, du hast den nicht drin, aber du hättest den gerne drin.
Ja, ich hätte den gerne drin.
Da musst du irgendwie Podlove-Downloads-Klammer zu.
Ah, das ist ein extra Tag, ja. Das hab ich irgendwie versucht zu finden.
Geh mal in diese Templates, mach mal Edit und dann gibst du in meine Ecke die Klammer ein. Und dann ist schon alles klar.
Verstehe. Aber ansonsten muss ich schon sagen, ich weiß ja gar nicht, wie man das vorher gemacht hat. Also ich mein, ich hab jetzt angefangen, da gab's schon in Sportlove und auf Phonic und ich mach halt meinen Wafffall, schieb das da hoch und obwohl ich jetzt auch immer nicht alles voll integriert laufe, lasse das jetzt auf Phonic das gleiche auf meinen Server schieb, sondern ich lad mir die Files dann auch noch manuell und dann schreibe ich auch nochmal die Episoden, krempel noch mal selber, aber letztendlich ist ja super wenig Arbeit, so abgesehen davon, dass wir jetzt auch noch die Shownotes selber schreiben und so weiter, aber ohne das ganze Zeug wäre das ja ein mega Krampf. Also die Leute, die da sozusagen vorher schon gepodcastet haben, denen ist das ja hoch anzurechnen auch mal, dass sie sich diesen ganzen Scheiß gegeben haben.
Oder anders, vorher haben es halt auch viele nicht gemacht und so hört es sich dann noch an, ne?
Ja, beziehungsweise es war wirklich freudig viel Arbeit. Also hier so vor zwei Jahren habe ich an so einer Mobamex-Sendung danach noch, nachdem wir hier vier Stunden gesessen haben und das Ganze eine Stunde mindestens Vorbereitung genossen hat, dann noch mal so zwei, drei Stunden normalerweise so in der Größenordnung damit verbracht. Irgendwann so nachts um zwei alle Shownotes zusammenzuführen und raus zu rendern und in iTunes reinzuwerfen und da die Metatext von Hand einzugeben und das Ganze in MP3 umzuwandeln und dann die richtige Datei und war es jetzt die oder war es jetzt die und hochladen und hat nicht geklappt und dann nur normales DSL und so. Also Zeiten, die ändern sich und ich will auch nie wieder hin zurück. Auf der anderen Seite ist ja wirklich auch noch eine Menge zu holen.
Also ich muss sagen, also ich habe benutzt es ja auch für die Band-Webseite und das war auch erstaunlich schmerzfrei, auch wenn es nur für ein paar Songs war.
Ja, aber das habe ich mir nämlich zum Beispiel auch gedacht tatsächlich, weil ich ja von Soundcloud so nachhaltig immer noch genervt bin, weil ich jetzt irgendwie so ein privates WordPress erstmal mache und da irgendwie auch so die ganzen Recordings einfach mit so einem Podlove-Webplayer einfach reinschiebe.
Das einzige, was ich mich frage ist...
Oder vielleicht mit dem Publisher.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit irgendwie, also jetzt ist es ja so, die sind da im normalen Stream der Blogposts mit dabei, gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, noch eine zweite Seite aufzusetzen, wo jetzt nur die Songs, also nur die Episoden drin sind?
Ja, in den Expert-Settings. Da kannst du sowieso extra noch mal eine Archivseite machen, du kannst das aber auch vor allem von vornherein auch mal trennen von den Blogposts. Also du kannst einfach sagen, hier ist das Blog, und hier ist die Liste, jeder will es halt irgendwie anders haben und die meisten wollen es halt irgendwie gemischt haben. Weil es ist eigentlich getrennt und wir haben bei Design schon mal diese Trennung aufgehoben. Deswegen ist es manchmal auch etwas verwirrend, aber die Verwirrung kommt halt primär dadurch, wie eben WordPress mit diesem ganzen Clem Wim umgeht. Und das ist nämlich, naja, das ist nicht schön eigentlich.
Okay, wenn ich dich jetzt hier schon mal gerade nochmal Support habe... Nein, ich frag dich gleich, wenn die Sendung vorbei ist, weil bei mir... Also ich frag dich gleich.
Bei mir ist ja gleich vorbei.
Das gehört jetzt nicht unbedingt in die Sendung bei den kleinen Technikproblemen.
Das ist ja was ganz Allgemeines, was alle betrifft.
Bei mir im Download-Button, den habe ich jetzt tatsächlich mit diesem Tag, da tauchen jetzt die Simple Chapters und das nicht existierende Torrent auch in der Liste mit auf. Obwohl ich die weder... Also gucken wir später nochmal.
Weil du da angeklickt hast in den Assets, dass sie downloadable sind. Das ist insofern noch ein bisschen schlecht gelöst, als dass, wenn du die anlegst, dass das Downloadable-Fleck immer bei Default gesetzt ist. Und ich finde, es sollte nur bei Audio- und Video-Falls bei Default gesetzt sein.
Da kommen wir auf den gleichen Ender, würde ich sagen.
Es ist immer wieder interessant zu sehen. Manchmal macht man mit so einer Software, das werdet ihr jetzt auch gut kennen, manchmal... also das Leichteste ist, große neue Features zu machen. Und die harte Arbeit ist, die dann so lange zu polieren und zu schleifen, bis sie auch wirklich jeder verstanden hat und sie wirklich auch funktionieren und so bug-free sind, dass es summt.
Da hab ich auch gleich noch ein Bug direkt.
Aber erstmal sowas auf den Tisch schmeißen, ist meistens gar nicht so das Problem.
Und der Schritt 3, das ist eigentlich der schwierigste. Wenn du dann mal das runde polierte Paket hast, neue Sachen einzubauen, ohne die alten kaputt zu machen.
Aber wir haben ja alle Tests.
Ja, ja, haben wir jetzt mittlerweile auch.
Genau, und jetzt ist noch der spezielle Bug, dass ich mal früher Torrens da mit reintun wollte, die aber wieder aus den Podcast-Assets gelöscht habe, oder Episode-Assets, wie es heißt. Aber hier in den Downloads tauchen sie noch auf.
Na, weil es das noch gibt, weil sie noch bei Bitlove sind.
Ich hab nie Bitlove gemacht. Ich hab das mal angelegt, da dieses Setting. Aber ich hab's wieder gelöscht, und jetzt hängst du aber irgendwie noch so ghostmäßig mit drin. Da gibt's hier so einen Torrent, aber der are no Torrents. Ich hatte den mal hier so, also hier war es mal drin, aber es hab ich wieder gelöscht. Und da ist es jetzt auch nicht mehr und...
Das sieht nach einem Fehler aus.
Aber das ist ja alles nicht problematisch. Ja, eigentlich war das auch schon das, dass ich nochmal so auch lobend sozusagen darüber sprechen wollte und eigentlich das auch nur jedem nach wie vor empfehlen kann, auch mal so einen Podcast zu probieren. Ist alles gar nicht so schwer. Man muss auch gar nicht... Wir machen ja auch immer noch nicht das Metaebene-approved setup, sondern wir machen ja immer noch so ein bisschen unseren eigenen Punk. Und das funktioniert halt mit den Tools schon vergleichsweise sorgenfrei, also auch... Das macht doch auch Ophonic, dass wenn du zwei Kanäle aufnimmst und die sind jetzt nicht perfekt gelevelt, dass der die dann gleichlevelt und solche Sachen halt, wo du sonst irgendwelche Grütze produzieren willst, wo die Leute, aah, warum ist der so laut und der andere so leise und dieser ganze Krempel halt.
Ja, damit kommen wir jetzt zum Ende. Und wir kommen mehr zum Ende, als ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Ach ja, richtig, wir wollten ja noch was, noch eine kleine Sache.
Da war noch was.
Da war doch scheiße, da war doch noch was.
Genau, denn ihr hörtet die letzte Mobamex-Sendung.
Die allerletzte, wir haben es nur 115 Folgen durchgehalten.
14.
Weil News gibt es eh keine mehr.
14?
Sommerloch ist es.
Ihr habt es gemerkt in den letzten Folgen, die Apple-Themen sind einfach nicht mehr da. Wir saugen uns hier.
Und nur DSL mit Clemens macht auch keinen Spaß. Und wir haben uns überlegt, die nächste Sendung ist, wenn neue Geräte kommen, nämlich iWatch wahrscheinlich.
Also so eine Sonder...
2018?
Oder irgendwelche anderen Special-Events, wir sind ja da locker. Zum Mac Pro könnte man auch eine machen.
Zur Exhumierung von Steve.
Oder wenn das erste Biopic von Johnny Ive abgedreht wird.
Aber der Chat ahnt es schon. Euch kriegt man nicht so ohne weiteres in das Licht geführt. So ganz vorbei ist dann auch wieder nicht. Aber wir machen jetzt mal hier Butter bei Fische. Und der Podcast wird umbenannt. Und wir streichen diesen Namen, den wir schon immer gehasst haben. Das wird einfach nicht mehr Mobamex heißen können, weil das geht einfach mal gar nicht. Ich bin auch häufig so auf Leute gestoßen. Ja, also Mobamex, das hör ich nicht, weil naja, ist ja nur Apple und so. Und manchmal ist es ja auch nur Apple.
Aber manchmal ist es auch noch DSL.
Wir haben nämlich nicht nur Country, sondern wir haben auch Western.
Und Schlager.
Und Schlager. Genau, und das wollen wir dann auch betonen. Und wir haben lange überlegt, was man da tun kann. Aber es war irgendwie immer klar, also Mobile Max ist es irgendwie nicht. Ist auch so ein bisschen Not Invented Here-Syndrom. Ganz klassisch. Also das muss man natürlich auch berücksichtigen. Aber natürlich, wie es so unsere Art ist, werden wir bezüglich des neuen Namens euch natürlich noch schön auf kleiner Flamme dünsten. Ihr könnt ja gerne Wetten abschließen und die irgendwie GPK signiert auf euren Festplatten hinterlegen oder so.
Auch S-Mime, wer das kann.
Also irgendwie so mit irgendwelchen approved Zeitstempeln irgendwie einfrieren und digital unterschrieben für die Nachwelt die Behauptung festhalten. Aber naja, wir haben auf jeden Fall lange dran gearbeitet, den neuen Namen zu finden und hier auch überhaupt das Ganze auch akustisch in ein anderes Bett zu kleiden.
Jemand schlägt vor, die Vorschläge in die Blockchain zu schreiben. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ach, als Kommentar für Überweisungen sozusagen in Bitcoin gegossen.
Mobile Linux, ja genau. Schreibt einfach in die Kommentare eure... Also wir stellen dann... Wenn wir wiederkommen, stellen wir vielleicht mal die schönsten User-Ideen zur Benennung vor. Ich bin mir sicher, ihr seid da sehr kreativ. Auch die abseitigsten.
Also dass es mit Cast nichts zu tun haben wird, das ist schon mal ganz klar, ja. Also das ist auch kein Pod drin.
Wir haben auch keinen Cast.
Multicast finde ich auch kein schlechter Name.
Wir haben jetzt keinen Max mehr. Max hat ja vor langer Zeit schon aufgehört, deswegen ist das Max aus dem Namen raus. Genau. Und ohne Casten können wir auch keinen Podcast. Okay, die Luft wird hin.
Vorsicht, der Podcast hat mir erzählt, dass er uns zuhört. Der legt sich jetzt bestimmt schon ab.
Es gibt einen Podcasten?
Na Clemens.
Achso, das ist der Podcast?
Ja.
Ansonsten wird sicherlich auch einiges so bleiben, wie es war. Wir bemühen uns uns auch weiterhin, hier locker, flockig aus der Hüfte zu schießen. Aber ganz ehrlich, diese ganze Fanboy-Orientierung und so weiter, das muss auch mal ein Ende haben.
Dafür sind wir viel zu kritisch.
Genau, ab heute wird zurückgeschossen.
Aber auch in die eigenen Reihen.
Also eure Kommentare im Chat, eure Vorschläge zeigen schon mir mal wieder, wie schwierig das ist, für dich auf einen guten Namen zu kommen. Aber lasst euch einfach überraschen. Und die nächste Sendung wird es dann einfach. Also ein paar gute Vorschläge.
Steuerung alt entfernt. Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Aber so richtig, also Vorschläge brauchen wir keine mehr. Das Ding ist bereits in Beton gegossen und hart seiner Veröffentlichung. Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wann ist die nächste Sendung? Jetzt kommt die nächste schlechte Nachricht. Wir werden hier wahrscheinlich eine kleine Sommerpause einlegen. Und ganz genau weiß ich es noch nicht, wir machen in drei oder vier Wochen weiter. Eins von beiden.
Wir müssen ja wieder zu Kräften kommen.
Genau, von dem Schock.
Nach 114 Sendungen.
Müssen wir uns erholen. Ja, was etwaige Umstellungen technischer Natur betrifft, das Schlimmste ist eigentlich schon durch. Seitdem ich hier auf den Publisher umgestellt habe, werden wir natürlich da so Optik und Grafik und so weiter den ganzen Klimmbilm auch noch anpassen. Aber auch erst, wenn es soweit ist. Und, tja, in dem Sinne hoffe ich, bleibt ihr uns erhalten. Sollte irgendjemand vielleicht eine neue Sendung nicht in seinem Feed vorfinden, vielleicht auch nochmal checken, ob er irgendwie Domainwechsel vielleicht irgendwelche Merkwürdigkeiten mit sich gebracht hat.
Ja, ihr werdet das schon auf Twitter und so weiter irgendwo mitkriegen.
Genau, aber eins kann ich euch versprechen, ihr kommt eh nicht drauf.
Wobei der Name ja schon in Sendungen gefallen ist, ne?
Du willst ja nur, dass die 115 Sendungen nachholt. 14, Entschuldigung.
Ja, aber das ist versteckt halt, ne? Also das weiß ja keiner.
Und hinterher werden alle sagen, ahhh.
Warum wird der Name jetzt nicht genannt? Na warum wohl? Spannend bleibt's und insofern sagen wir vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Ja, empfehlen sie uns weiter.
Empfehlen sie uns weiter, auch wenn ihr nicht wisst, was ihr jetzt weiterempfehlen sollt. Aber die Rufnummern bleiben hier alle identisch.
Das war's für heute.
Danke fürs Zuhören und bis bald!